GOOD AFTERNOON I LIKE TO CALL TO
ORDER THE.
HEARING OF THE OUR COMMITTEE ON
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
OF APRIL SEVENTEEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. HOW WE GONNA START AS
A SUBCOMMITTEE LET US JUST A
COUPLE OF ANNOUNCEMENTS SO ITEM
SEVEN AB TWENTY ONE NINETY FOUR
QUIRK HAS BEEN? ALL POLL AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR AND THAT
WE HAVE FOUR ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA ON NAMELY ITEM
NUMBER THREE NINETEEN FIFTY
SEVEN BERMAN ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
SEVEN. BONTA ITEM THEM FIFTEEN
AB TWENTY EIGHT.
TWELFTH LIMO AND.
FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE AB THIRTY
TWO TWENTY NINE WITH THAT I KNOW
TO SET THEM IS TO LOW IS HERE.
AND HE HAS A B. TWENTY FOUR OH
TO AND THAT'S ITEM NUMBER TEN SO
THIS TIME LIKE TO INVITE HIM TO
US TO PRESENT HIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND MISTER
CHAIR OFFER LET ME TO PRESENT.
TO YOU AS A SUBCOMMITTEE THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR. OH TO
AND THIS IS WITH RESPECT TO
CONSUMER PROTECTION FOR.
CANNABIS OF PURCHASING AND
PREVENTS THE LICENSEES ON FROM
SHARING INFORMATION FROM A
CONSUMERS TO THIRD PARTIES
WITHOUT CONSENT OF THIS IS TO
ENSURE THAT EVERY PREVENT.
SUCH INFORMATION BEING SHARED
WITH EMPLOYERS ARE FOR
ADVERTISING OTHER AYE
CAPABILITIES.
WITHOUT CONSENT AND SO WITH ME
IN SUPPORT DISTRICTS IN BRYANT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA GROWERS
ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME AND.
PLEASE SEPERTI
SURE THANK YOU JASON BROWN TO
HAVE TO CALIFORNIA GROWERS
ASSOCIATION. CURRENT LAW
PROVIDES THE PROTECTION FOR THE
PRIVACY OF. THAT MEDICAL
PATIENTS WHO ARE MAKING
PURCHASES NOT NECESSARILY
PROVIDING THE SAME PRIVACY TO
THOSE ADULT USE PURCHASERS IN
THIS BILL CLOSES THAT GAP AND
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORTED
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
LEADERSHIP ON THE BILL. THANK
YOU.
NO THANK YOU A NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE.
I ADDITIONAL WITNESS IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL PLEASE HUG A
COMFORT.
AND A PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF
AS WELL AS A YOUNG ORGANIZATION
THAT YOU'RE AFFILIATED WITH
PLEASE.
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
YOU.
GOT IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES OR
INDIVIDUALS IN SUPPORT OF BILL.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL WANTS ARE
PLEASE.
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SEEING NONE. ARE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE PANEL.
WHICH I CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
DR VOTE WHEN YOU OF ART CAN BE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I BELIEVE
THIS IS A GOOD DEBT CONSUMER
PROTECTION BILL SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING IT AS SOON AS WE HAVE
QUORUM THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF FOR BEING. HERE
.
NO.
NO OFFERS.
SURE
BUT.
THAT'S LIKE MISTER LEVINE IS
HERE WITH US SO I AT THIS TIME
IS TO LEVINE WHICH LIKE TO
PRESENT YOUR BILL.
AND YOU HAVE AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY TWO.
.
I BELIEVE THAT'S ITEM NUMBER
FIVE SO.
IF YOU LIKE IT'S SITUATED AND
YOU MAY PROCEED.
I THINK WE SHOULD GO I'M SORRY
I'M SO WE STILL ARE DOING IT
THAT HAS A SUBCOMMITTEE BY THE
WAY GREAT THANK YOU AND I WILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIRMAN
CHAO AND.
AND MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY TWO WHICH
DEALS WITH ONLINE DATA PRIVACY.
ACCORDING TO STATISTICS FROM THE
NATIONAL TELECOMMUNICATIONS AND
INFORMATION ADMINISTRATION IN
THE PEW RESEARCH CENTER.
SEVENTY FOUR POINT SIX PERCENT
OF THE UNITED STATES POPULATION
UTILIZES THE INTERNET AND SIXTY
NINE PERCENT INTERACTS WITH ONE.
OR MORE FORMS OF SOCIAL MEDIA.
THE INFALLIBLE AMOUNTS OF
PERSONAL DATA PRODUCED ON THE
INTERNET. MEANS THAT REGULATIONS
ARE REQUIRED TO SAFEGUARD
CONSUMERS THEIR PRIVACY AND DATA
ON THE INTERNET. I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE REFERENCE IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S TWENTY
SIXTEEN REPORT WHICH FOUND THAT
IN THE LAST FOUR YEARS. NEARLY
FIFTY MILLION RECORDS OF
CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN BREACHED
AND THE MAJORITY OF THESE
PREACHERS RESULTED FROM SECURITY
FAILURES.
FURTHERMORE THE REPORT NOTED
THAT IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
ORGANIZATIONS EMPLOYEE STRONG
PRIVACY PRACTICES
TO PROTECT PRIVACY. BUSINESSES
MUST HAVE PRIVACY POLICIES THAT
ARE EASY TO READ AND ACCESS
INFORM CONSUMERS ABOUT MATERIAL
CHANGES TO THEIR DATA HANDLING
PRACTICES. AND CAREFULLY SELECT
THERE DID DEFAULT SETTINGS WHICH
OFTEN DETERMINE HOW DATA IS
COLLECTED USED AND SHARED.
TO FILL SO TO FACILITATE THIS
EFFORT I AM PROPOSING TO NARROW
THIS BILL.
TO HAVE THE DATA PROTECTION
AUTHORITY OFFER ASSISTANCE TO
CONSUMERS IN NAVIGATING HOW TO
CONTROL THE USE
SHARING AND PROTECTION OF THEIR
DATA AT THE OUTSET. WE LOOK FOR
TO WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS IN
THIS EFFORT WITH ME TODAY TO
VOICE SUPPORT IN CONCEPT FOR THE
BILL. IS MIKE SHAPIRO THE CHIEF
PRIVACY OFFICER FOR SANTA CLARA
COUNTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME IN
THE YOU MADE A PROCEED.
GREAT THANK YOU AGAIN MIKE
SHAPIRO CHIEF PRIVACY OFFICER
THE COUNTY SANTA CLARA I'M HAPPY
TO BE HERE TODAY.
I'M I THINK IT'S INTERESTING AND
WHAT WE'VE BEEN SAYING.
RECENTLY I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
OUR CONSTITUENTS BOTH WITHIN
THE COUNTY AS WELL AS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA YOUR HAVE
NOTICED THAT THERE'S A BIT OF AN
UP TICK IN DATA BREACHES.
WHETHER THEY'RE JUST NOTICING
THAT BECAUSE IT'S BEING REPORTED
ON OUR BECAUSE THIS VERY TO THE
REACHES OF SO MUCH MORE
SIGNIFICANT. I THINK IT IT'S
INCUMBENT UPON US IS WHETHER
WERE GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEES
ELECTED OFFICIALS TO TAKE A LOT
OF ACTION.
I.
ACTUALLY REACHED OUT TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE TO
DISCUSS ARE HIS PROPOSAL AND.
THERE'S INTERESTING.
TO ACTUALLY HAVE A DISCUSSION
WITH HIM AND THEN TO KIND OF
LEARN A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
DIRECTION WANTED TO TAKE IT.
I THINK THAT AS A PRIVACY
PROFESSIONAL MYSELF WE DO NEED
TO CONSIDER BOUNCING THE
BUSINESS INTERESTS WITH THE
PRIVACY INTERESTS OF THE PUBLIC.
I FEEL THAT OFTENTIMES ONE OF
THE OTHER CAN TAKE A LOOK AT A
PRECEDENCE I THINK DRIVING AT
THAT BALANCE IS NOT SOMETHING WE
CAN IT ANY LONGER AVOID. I THINK
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT OUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT PRIVACY AND I THINK WHAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE IS
PROPOSING IS SOMETHING.
REASONABLE STEPANEK RIGHT
DIRECTION.
WHAT I THINK WE CAN'T DO
CONSIDERING THE SEVERITY OF THE
DATA BREACHES WHETHER IT'S WITH
FACEBOOK CAMBER TELEMATICA? OR
WHETHER IT'S WITH EXPERIENCE
SOME OF THE OTHERS THAT WE'VE
SEEN RECENTLY.
BUT I DON'T THINK WE CAN DO IS I
DON'T THINK WE COULD SAY WE
UNDERSTAND WE KNOW ABOUT THESE
BREACHES.
WITH MATT WE DISCUSSED IT AND
YET WE DECIDE TO DO NOTHING.
SO I WOULD ASK THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING A REASONABLE STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION WE COULD
TAKE TO ACTUALLY TAKE CONSUMERS
AND OUR CONSTITUENTS PRIVACY
INTO CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL PLEASE. COME FORWARD
AND IDENTIFY YOURSELF IF. I
DON'T SEE ANY.
HUBBELL OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THINK YOU.
MY NAME IS SARAH BOOT I'M HERE
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
TODAY. I'M I WANT TO START OUT
BY SAYING THAT FOR THE RECORD WE
ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE BILL
THAT IS IN PRINT.
BUT.
THE AUTHORS OFFICE HAS REACHED
OUT TO US NUMEROUS TIMES TO
DISCUSS THE BILL AND THEY THEY
DID PRESENT US WITH THIS NEW
CONCEPT AYE IN ADVANCE OF
TODAY'S HEARING IN SO. WANT
THANK MISTER LEVINE FOR THAT IS
WONDERFUL STAFF REALLY
APPRECIATE IT.
ALTHOUGH WE HAVEN'T SEEN
LANGUAGE YET THE CONCEPT THAT'S
BEEN DESCRIBED I'M CERTAINLY
SEEMS REASONABLE OBVIOUSLY
PROVIDING MORE RESOURCES TO
CONSUMERS WHENEVER POSSIBLE IS A
GREAT THING.
DOT WITHOUT SAID.
WE DO RESERVE THE RIGHT TO
DETERMINE OUR POSITION ON THE
NEW CONCEPT ONCE WE HAVE THE
LANGUAGE IN FRONT OF US.
WE CERTAINLY WILL BE WILLING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ON THIS
BILL.
BUT WILL HAVE QUESTIONS
OBVIOUSLY.
AS TO HOW THIS NEW ENTITY WILL
BE SET UP IN THE SCOPE OF ITS
RESPONSIBILITIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KEVIN MCKINLEY WITH
INTERNET ASSOCIATION.
WANTED TO THINK AUTHOR FOR THE
DIRECTIONS TAKEN THE BILL WE
THINK IT'S A POSITIVE STEP.
THESE ARE ISSUES THAT OUR MEMBER
COMPANIES TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY.
AND WE WANT TO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO EMPOWER CONSUMERS TO USE
THE TOOLS THAT ARE AVAILABLE
TODAY.
WE DO HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW
THIS WILL DEVELOPING BE
IMPLEMENTED. AND SO WILL WORK
WITH AUTHOR GOING FORWARD ON
THOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES SO IN
OPPOSITION.
ONTO THIS BILL PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
LIKE.
YOUR NAME IN THE ORGANIZATIONS
ARE YOU REPRESENT.
I'VE MARKET FUSSY ABOUT HALF
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
I LET MYSELF FOR THE REMARKS OF
THE TWO PREVIOUS TEST FIRES AND
APPRECIATE THAT AUTHOR'S. OTHER
DIRECTIONS TAKE HIS BILL THANK
YOU MATCH A NICE PLACE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISS CHURCH
DOESN'T FAZE ON BEHALF OF TECHNO
LIKE TWO LINER COMMENTS WITH
THOSE OF THE PRESENTERS AS WELL
THEY KICK YOU. MATCH.
NEXT PLACE.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL CANDOR
BECAUSE OUR ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION I
WOULD ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH
THE PREVIOUS TESTIMONIES AS WELL
THANK YOU. HOCKEY MATCH.
OTHER ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SCENE NINE LET'S COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE COMMENTS QUESTIONS
FROM THE PANEL.
MR.
I SURE KILEY CHO HAD PLEASE
NEGATIVE FOR MR LEVINE. ACT
COULD JUST ELABORATE A LITTLE
BIT MORE ON WHAT THE NEW VERSION
OF THE BILL IS GOING TO DO.
SO AS I STATED I'M NARROWING THE
BILL TO HAVE THAT DATA
PROTECTION AUTHORITY OFFER
ASSISTANCE TO CONSUMERS IN
NAVIGATING HOW TO CONTROL THE
USE
SHARING AND PROTECTION OF THEIR
DATA. OUT AT THE OUTSET I THINK
THE POINT THAT TODD THAT THE
WITNESSES HAVE MADE.
THIS AFTERNOON. IS THAT WE HAVE
REALLY BEGUN A CONVERSATION
ABOUT THIS CONCEPT AND AS A
LAWMAKER I'M GRATEFUL TO HAVE
STAKEHOLDERS TO WORK WITH US TO
CRAFT. OF WHAT THIS WILL DO TO
PART PROTECT CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS.
AND SO THE NEW.
WE'RE STILL GONNA HAVE THIS NEW
ENTITY THE CALIFORNIA DATA
PROTECTION AUTHORITY.
I THINK THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
WORKING WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS WORKS VERY
WELL FOR CONSUMERS BUT ALSO.
I THINK FROM THE PERSPECTIVE
THAT ALL OF US SHARE CAN REDUCE
ANY COSTS.
TO THE STATE AS WELL AND SO
WERE WERE FLEXIBLE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WILL MAKE THIS WORK.
OKAY THANK YEAH SEEMS LIKE MAYBE
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT AN
EXISTING REGULATED TO DO.
SO IF YOU LOOK AT THAT THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WHICH IS
QUITE DETAILED IT TALKS ABOUT
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY CALLED OPP.
IN THE DOJ WHICH WAS DE FUNDED
IT AND IT WAS RELIC RELATIVE TO
ENFORCEMENT.
AND IF IF THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THAT'S WHAT THAT
WAS ABOUT.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT ENFORCEMENT
THIS IS ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
THE TOOLS AND RESOURCES MANY OF
WHICH ARE LAWS THAT WE'VE PASSED
ARE UNDERSTANDABLE AND
AVAILABLE.
TO.
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS AS WELL AS.
INTEREST RIGHT HOW TO PROTECT
ONE'S PRIVACY ONLINE.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE.
SEEN AN ARM.
I.
LIKE CERTAIN PARTS OF THE BILL
ARE IT AS IT'S A CURRENTLY
PRINTED.
FOR EXAMPLE THE PART THAT WOULD
PROVIDE MORE CONSUMER PROTECTION
ALL YET I THINK THERE ARE PARTS
OF THE BILL THAT MAY BE
REDUNDANT EXAMPLE A CERTAIN
PARTS OF THE BILL. MAY ALREADY
BE BEEN COVERED BY A ON THE
CURRENT LAW FOR EXAMPLE CHINA
CHINA CHINA LIKE LAW WHICH
COVERS A LOT OF THE POLICY
ISSUE.
BUT UNDERSTANDING THAT DIE YOU
ARE GOING WITH THIS NEW CONCEPT
HIGHLY STUCK SO ARE AMONG
SUPPORT IT ARE SO THAT YOU WILL
HAVE A CHANCE TO BASICALLY A
FINE TUNED OUT CONCEPT AND
HOPEFULLY.
YOU KNOW YOU COME UP WITH
SOMETHING THAT ZEL MILLER RD
TELL AND NOT ACCEPTABLE
SO I'LL. AS SOON AS WE HAVE
QUORUM THEN WE COULD WE COULD DO
THAT BUT I'M GONNA ASK YOU TO
CLOSE.
SINCE THERE ARE NO GOOD FOR THE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
YOUR RESEARCH I WANNA SAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP FOR YOUR STAFF'S TIME
ON THIS AS WELL TO ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
PROVIDED FEEDBACK.
TO ME ON THIS AS I BEGAN
DRAFTING THIS LEGISLATION LAST
YEAR I HAD NOT ANTICIPATED THE
UPROAR THAT. WE RECEIVED AFTER.
THE DISCOVERY OF THE CAMBRIDGE
ANALYTICAL FACEBOOK ISSUE BUT
THAT'S JUST ONE ISSUE AND I
THINK THAT IS IMPORTANT FOR US
AS THE LEGISLATURE TO.
LOOK AT IT FROM A BIGGER
PICTURE PERSPECTIVE AND THINK
LONGER TERM THAN JUST ONE OUT
ONE THING THAT THAT.
FLARED OUT AND HAVE A HOLISTIC
APPROACH XIN INCREMENTALLY.
THIS IS ONE WAY FOR US TO
ADDRESS THIS AND BE RESPONSIVE
TO OUR CONSTITUENTS SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH COMMITTEE FOR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
SO WE STILL DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM
SO.
BUT WE DO HAVE AUTHORS.
WITH US IN THE LET'S SEE GO DOWN
THE LIST I THINK THE NEXT ERA
PRESENTER IS SOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SIGN OFF.
AND HE HAS ITEM NUMBER ONE
THAT'S AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY ONE A
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BURSTS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
ONE WHICH WILL PREVENT BUSINESS
OWNERS PERSONAL AND SENSITIVE
INFORMATION FROM BEING EASILY
ACCESSIBLE ONLINE.
TODAY'S STATEMENTS OF
INFORMATION FILED BY
CORPORATIONS AND LLC'S CAN BE
VIEWED ONLINE BY ANY INDIVIDUAL
WITH INTERNET ACCESS.
ALTHOUGH ALLOWING THE PUBLIC TO
REVIEW THESE BUSINESS FILINGS
ONLINE DOES IMPROVE GOVERNMENT
TRANSPARENCY AND EFFICIENCY.
SOME OF THE INFORMATION PROVIDED
OF THESE FINDINGS CAN BE USED.
MISS YOU SUBSTANTIALLY.
THE PERSONAL SIGNATURES PROVIDED
ON THE FINAL IT'S CAN QUICKLY BE
PULLED FROM THE DOCUMENT AND
USED APPROXIMATELY SIGN OTHER
DOCUMENTS INCLUDING CHEQUES.
THE RESIDENTIAL ADDRESSES
PROVIDED BY SOME BUSINESS OWNERS
CAN USE TO FIND IMAGES AND THE
EXACT LOCATION OF AN OWNER'S
PERSONAL HOME.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY ONE WOULD
PROVIDE A MODEST SOLUTION BY
REDACTING RESIDENTIAL ADDRESSES
AND PERSONAL SIGNATURES FROM ALL
FUTURE BUSINESS FILINGS POSTED
ON THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
ONLINE DATABASE.
ADDITIONALLY THE FULL UNALTERED
PILINGS WOULD STILL BE AVAILABLE
UPON REQUEST
THIS BILL STRIKE THE PERFECT
BALANCE BETWEEN PROTECTING
BUSINESS OWNERS PERSONAL
INFORMATION AND PROVIDING
NECESSARY DISCLOSURE TO THE
PUBLIC. I LIKE TO JUST POINT OUT
I'M I WENT ONLINE AND PULLED.
THIS FOR A BUSINESS CALLED FAR
SITE STUDIOS THAT WAS FILED IN
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT. AND WITH
THAT INFORMATION I WAS ABLE TO
GET A PHOTO OF THE OWNER'S HOME.
AND THEN THIS OWNERS EXTREMELY
GENEROUS TO THE GIRL SCOUTS OF
AMERICA. AND ITS DECIDED TO GIVE
A CHECK FOR A MILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S A WHOLE LOT OF COOKIES
MISTER OBERNOLTE YOU'RE VERY
KIND AND GENEROUS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO ASK OUR
SERIBU TO TESTIFY AS WELL PLEASE
SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON OUTSIDE MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS AGAIN SARAH BOOT
WITH THAT CALTRAIN FOR.
I'LL BE BRIEF AYE MR STEINORTH
ALREADY COVERED THE KEY POINTS
OF THIS MODEST BUT COMMON SENSE
BILL. THE CHAMBER SUPPORTS AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY ONE BECAUSE IT
STRIKES A BALANCE BETWEEN
PROTECTING THE SENSITIVE
PERSONAL INFORMATION OF BUSINESS
OWNERS WHILE STILL ENSURING THAT
THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE
FULL ACCESS TO BUSINESS FILINGS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
CNN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ALL KINDS.
GO AHEAD FIRST OVER.
A SETTLEMENT STEINORTH I I
ACTUALLY THINK THIS IS A GREAT
BILL IT'S MUCH NEEDED. AND.
HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT I I HAD A
COUPLE QUESTIONS FOR YOU MAYBE I
JUST KIND OF SUGGESTIONS SO I AS
YOU POINTED OUT. THE.
CURRENT PRACTICE OF THE
SECRETARY OF STATE IS JUST TO
SCAN. THE FORMS THAT ARE
SUBMITTED FOR THEIR APPROVAL SO
I'M WONDERING WHAT THEIR NEW
SUGGESTED PROTOCOL IS GOING TO
BE ARE THEY. GOING TO HAVE TO
REDACT EVERY FORM THAT IS
PRESENTED TO THEM. YES THE IDEAS
PRESS TO HAVE THEM REDACT THE
HOME ADDRESS AND ALSO THE
SIGNATURE NOW IT'S BEEN BOMBED
PROPOSED AS WELL THAT BUSINESS
OWNERS COULD.
SUGGESTED THEY USE A PO BOX
STYLE ADDRESS LIKE UPS STORE
INSTEAD OF THEIR HOME ADDRESS OR
THEIR BUSINESS STOREFRONT.
I WOULD ARGUE THAT THAT ALSO
ADDS AN EXTRA CHALLENGE TO THE
BUSINESS OWNER IN THE EXPENSE OF
TRYING TO.
SECURE THOSE ADDRESSES.
OKAY SO THE.
IF THAT IS THAT I CAN I CAN SEE
THE SECRETARY OF STATE BEGINNING
TO DO THAT MOVING FORWARD BUT
THEY HAVE A DATABASE WITH
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF THESE
FORMS ALREADY. THAT'S AND I
THINK IT'S GONNA BE VERY ONEROUS
TASK TO GO HAVE TO REDACT EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THEM SO NOT SURE
HOW THEY WOULD GO ABOUT DOING
THAT RIGHT WILL THIS BILL
ACTUALLY ASK FOR THEM TO DO IT
AS A BUSINESS BOARD AS OPPOSED
TO GOING BACK IN. ARREARS SO
IT'S NOT ASKING TO GO BACK TO
LIKE YOUR FILING THAT WAS DATED
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT I WOULD STILL
HAVE YOUR. YOUR PERSONAL ADDRESS
FROM THERE BUT FOR YOUR
ADDITIONAL NEWER FILINGS FROM
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN YOU'RE
REFERENCING YOUR EXISTING TWO
THOUSAND A FILING YOU COULD
SUBMIT A NEW ONE. AND THEN THAT
WOULD HAVE THE REDACTION BEAR
WITH SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE.
OKAY SO START THIS IS JUST FOR
NEW FILING UNDERGRADUATE.
BUSINESS PHOTOS NINETEEN SO
ANYONE THAT WANTED TO FORGE A
MILLION DOLLAR CHECK FOR GIRL
SCOUT COOKIES WILL STILL BE
CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
WELL THEN YOU WOULD BE UP TO TWO
HAD A LOT OF GIRL SCOUT COOKIES.
ALRIGHT AND THAT ONE JUST A.
SUGGESTION WOULD BE THE WORDING
OF THE BILLS IT STANDS.
REQUIRES THE SECRETARY OF STATE
TO PROVIDE THIS INFORMATION
ONLINE EXCEPT FOR A COUPLE OF
THINGS THAT'S DIFFERENT THEY ON.
REQUIRING THEM NOT TO POST THE
THINGS THAT WERE IN THE WEST AND
SO IF YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
AMEND THE BILL MAYBE YOU CAN.
YOU CAN CLARIFY THAT THEY SHALL
NOT POST THOSE THINGS ONLINE GOT
IT THAT'S A VERY GOOD SUGGESTION
RIGHT YOU ARE WILL ENJOY YOUR
GIRL SCOUT COOKIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
CNN I WANNA I THINK YOU ALSO.
FOR BRINGING THE THE BILL
FORWARD.
WHEN I WAS IN LAW PRACTICE I
ACTUALLY HAVE FILED A LOT OF THE
SAYS THE MEANS OF INFORMATION SO
I AND I FULLY UNDERSTAND THE
SITUATION AND. ARE IN FACT I I
KNOW THERE. WERE A NUMBER OF
TRIPS THAT I MADE TO THE SECULAR
STATES OFFICE YOU KNOW
PERSONALLY FIGHTING THESE THINGS
SO I'D I DO I DO WITH ALSO AGREE
THAT THAT THIS BILL STARTS RIGHT
BALANCE BETWEEN PROTECTING
PRIVACY AND. THE PUBLIC'S RIGHT
TO KNOW SO SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL AND I WOULD
NOT DIE WHICH LIKE A CLOSE I
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN AYE
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE A FULL QUORUM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WE HAVE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIMO.
WELCOME I BELIEVE YOU HAVE THREE
BILLS AND ONE OF THEM IS ON
CONSENT.
.
THINK IT WAS FOUR AND ONE WAS ON
CONSENT THAT'S ONE TWO THAT'S
RIGHT.
WHILE.
TODAY'S THE.
THAT SEEKS SO WHAT WHICH ONE
WHICH LIKE A SILENT.
DO I GO IN ORDER WE COULD DIE TO
TOOT.
TWO TWO TWO FIVE.
THAT WOULD BE AB TWO TWO TO FIVE
AND ANYTIME YOU'RE READY YOU MAY
PROCEED AND BY THE WAY THIS IS.
.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT ON THE AGENDA
SO.
GO AT IT THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL TWO TWO
TWO FIVE RATIFIES THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE BY RE. INSERTING
UNIFORM STANDARDS FOR NON
PERMANENT RECORDS IN THE STATE
WITHOUT THIS REQUIREMENT THAT
NON PERMANENT RECORDS FOLLOW ANY
SORT OF ELECTRONIC STORAGE
STANDARD AND WITHOUT ANY
STATUTORY CLARITY FOR HOW TO
HANDLE THESE RECORDS. THERE IS
ARGUABLY A HUGE RISK POSED TO
THE STATE.
THIS BILL ALSO ENSURES THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ENTITIES DO NOT
CREATE VULNERABILITIES IN THE
CLOUD WHEN THEIR RECORDS ARE
MAINTAINED IN THE SAME CLOUD
COMPUTING STORAGE SERVICE I SEE
AGENCIES.
I RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE
CONCERNS OVER CERTAIN THAT
SECURITY STANDARDS AND THE
DEFINITION OF CLOUD COMPUTING I
WILL WORK WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
TO ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS IN
APPROPRIATIONS. AND SHOULD THIS
BILL MOVED OUT I HAVE WITH ME AT
TED ANIMAL HOUSE OR WITH THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE BUT
HERE JUST FOR TECHNICAL A
TESTIMONY IF NEEDED. AND JUST TO
GIVE YOU ALL AN EXAMPLE OF WHY
T. I.
NON PERMANENT RECORD IS A WE
WOULD LOOK AT SOMETHING LIKE A
VOTER REGISTRATION AFFIDAVIT
THAT IS KEPT FOR A HUNDRED YEARS
AND SEALED THAT'S AN EXAMPLE
JUST SO PEOPLE KNOW WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH EFFORTS WHAT
IS PLEASE WELCOME THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'D HAD
MORE HOUSE ARE ON BEHALF OF
SECRETARY OF STATE ALEX MEDIA.
EARLIER TODAY AS SECRETARY
VIDEO WAS PLEASE TAKE A SUPPORT
POSITION ON AB TWO. TWO TWO FIVE
THIS BILL DOES COMPLEMENT RECENT
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS TO UPDATE
THIS AREA OF LAW PARTICULARLY
THE PROVISION THAT ENSURES BOTH
PERMANENT NON PERMANENT
DOCUMENTS ARE COVERED. AND.
UNIFIES THE DEFINITION OF CLOUD
STORAGE I TRUSTED SYSTEM THAT
WORKS REAL WELL FOR AGENCIES
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEY'RE REQUIRED TO DO.
MAYBE TWO TWO TWO FIVE DOES
MAKE IT. EASIER FOR STATE BOTH
AND LOCAL AGENCIES DIRECTOR AND.
WE LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR AND OTHER
INTERESTED PARTIES AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE Q. SEVEN MEMBER
THE NONPROFIT BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MEASURE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SCENE NINE.
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SCENE THEN LET'S COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
MISTER OBERNOLTE GO AHEAD.
THANKS VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR SO
I. I THINK IT'S A GOOD BILL ARE
DONE HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT ONE
SUGGESTION I HAVE FOR YOU IS
THAT. WITHIN THE BILL YOU'RE
REFERENCING NON PERMANENT
RECORDS AND NON PERMANENT
DOCUMENTS
AND IT'S CLEAR THAT FROM THE
CONTEXT THAT YOU MEAN THAT IN
THE THE WORD NON PERMANENT IN A
LEGAL SENSE. HOWEVER THAT WORD
ALSO HAS A TECHNICAL MEANING AND
BECAUSE WE'RE DEALING WITH CLOUD
COMPUTING I THINK IT'S GONNA BE
VERY IMPORTANT NOT TO CONFLATE
THOSE TWO MEETINGS AND SO ON TO
SUGGEST THAT IF YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO AMENDED. THAT YOU
CONSIDER PUTTING A RECITAL IN
WHICH YOU TO FIND EXACTLY WHAT
YOU MEAN BY. A BY NON PERMANENT
RECORD.
RIGHT POINT WELL TAKEN AND WE'RE
DEFINITELY WORKING ON THAT
CLARIFICATION.
SO WE GOT WE STILL DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM SO WHEN WE DO HAVE
QUENTIN WILLA. ON THROUGH THE
MOTION ACCORDINGLY SAY WITHOUT
WHICH I CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK A
FRIEND AYE VOTE WHEN.
THERE'S QUIRK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND LET'S MOVE ONTO THE
NEXT ITEM OF YEARS AND THAT IS
SO PROBABLY TWENTY EIGHT TWELVE.
THAT WAS A CONSENT OF STATE THAT
ONCE ON.
SO I THINK IT'S THIRTY TEN
THIRTY TEN THAT'S CORRECT.
MAYBE TEN RIGHT THERE.
THAT'S ITEM EIGHTEEN ON THE
AGENDA.
THANK YOU I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED TO IN THE COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCES THAT THINK THE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE STAFF. UP FOR
WORKING WITH ME TO NARROW THE
AMOUNT OF DATA THAT NEEDS TO BE
COLLECTED IN ORDER TO MAKE IT
PAY DAY ONE LOAN AT A TIME
POLICY WORK.
CHERRY MEMBERS AT LAST NIGHT THE
ASSEMBLY BANKING COMMITTEE
PASSED A A. B. THIRTY TWENTY
APPROVING A ONE LOAN AT A TIME
PAYDAY LOAN POLICY. WITH THIS
BILL AND WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
PROHIBITED PAYDAY LENDER FROM
ENTERING INTO AN ADDITIONAL
PAYDAY LOAN WITH A BAR OR IF
THAT BAR ALREADY HAS AN
OUTSTANDING PAYDAY LOAN. TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS LENDERS WOULD
NEED A REAL TIME DATA BASE TO
ACCURATELY CONTAINS INFORMATION.
ON WHICH FIRES HAVE CURRENT
ACTIVE PD LOANS THIS BILL
PROVIDES FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT TO ESTABLISH
AND MAINTAIN THE DATABASE
INCLUDING ENSURING THAT THE DATA
IS KEPT SAFE. THROUGH THE
CURRENT INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
PROTECTION PRACTICES AS
CONTAINED IN CURRENT LAW.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL EXPRESSLY
STATES THAT PERSONAL INFORMATION
COLLECTED BY LENDERS AND THE DB
IS NOT AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC THROUGH A PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT REQUEST.
MEMBERS OF MY INTENT SHOULD THIS
BILL MOVE FORWARD IS TO PROVIDE
FOR THE CREATION OF A DATABASE
THAT CONTAINS ONLY WHAT IS
REQUIRED TO IMPLEMENT THE
POLICY.
AND THE DATA COLLECTED REMAIN AS
SECURE AS POSSIBLE. AND TO DAY
WITH ME THING.
I THOUGHT SUSAN.
NOT.
SO WITH THAT YEAH OKAY SURE ARE
AT THE.
WE.
MOST OF THREE TO HAVE MYSELF YES
I DO HAVE THIS IN MIND ON HERE
ARE WITH ME IN SUPPORTOF THE
BILL FROM THE.
CONSUMERS UNION TO JUSTIFY
SORRY NO THANK YOU SORRY FOR THE
MIX UP THERE ARE SO MANY RELATED
BILLS HERE AND WE HAVE A VERY
BUSY BUSY AN AMAZING AUTHOR HERE
SO. US IS EMERGING WITH
CONSUMERS UNION A WE SUPPORT.
THAT THE IDEA OF ENSURING THAT
THERE IS A WAY TO ENFORCE THE
ONE LOAN AT A TIME REQUIREMENT.
AGAIN THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
COMPONENT TO ENSURE THAT.
WE ARE NOT ALONE LENDERS TO
STACK CONSUMERS WITH MULTIPLE
LOANS AT ONCE THERE IS AMPLE
EVIDENCE FROM THE DDO AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS SHOWING THAT WHEN
CONSUMERS HOBBIES MULTIPLE LOANS
OUT ALL AT ONCE ARE SORT OF
BORROWING FROM PETER TO PAY
PAUL.
AND IT CAN REALLY TO.
SPIRAL DOWN INTO FINANCIAL RUIN
SO BADLY THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
COMPONENT OF.
ARE WHAT'S GOING TO BE
DISCUSSED ON THE NEXT BILL.
DID THEIR WORK CHANGING THE LAW
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE ONE ON A
TIME PER CUSTOMER TO PREVENT
PEOPLE FROM BEING STUCK IN A
CYCLE OF DEBT. SO FOR THOSE
REASONS BEYOND THE REQUEST OUT
AND I VOTE THANK YOU STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
SEEING NONE LIKE TO INVITE
OPPOSITION TO COME FORWARD.
WELCOME THANK YOU.
MARGARET LAD STEAM HERE ON
BEHALF OF ADVANCE AMERICA I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO HAVE. NARROW THE
BILL IS RECOMMENDED FOR THAT BUT
IN THE ANALYSIS THAT WE TAKE
STRONG ISSUE WITH THEM SIR BOTH
ELEMENTS OF THE BILL AND ARGUED
THAT THIS IS NOT A CONSUMER
PROTECTION OR A PRIVACY BILL.
UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW A CONSUMER
CAN ONLY TAKE OUT A PAYDAY LOAN
OF THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY BILLS THAT LIMIT
HOW MANY CREDIT CARDS EACH OF
YOU CAN HAVE IN YOUR WALLET HOW
MANY CARLOAD YOU CAN HAVE OR HOW
MANY MORTGAGE YOU CAN YOU CAN
HAVE. IF YOU LIMIT THE NUMBER OF
PAYDAY LOANS THAT A CUSTOMER CAN
TAKE OUT AT ANY ONE TIME THESE
ARE COME BORROWERS WHO ALREADY
HAVE VERY LIMITED. CREDIT
OPTIONS THEY WILL GO TO THE
UNREGULATED UNLICENSED LENDERS
WHO EITHER OPERATE ON THE
INTERNET OR OPERATE ON STREET
CORNERS IN A VARIETY OF OTHER
PLACES.
THEY HAVE NO CONSUMER PROTECTION
IF THEY'RE NOT TAKING A LOAN
FROM A LICENSED REGULATED LENDER
THE DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT HAS A VERY
AGGRESSIVELY TRIED TO GO AFTER
UNLICENSED LENDERS WHO OPERATE
FROM GUAM. THE ISLE OF MAN AND
OTHER PLACES AND THEY'VE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO GET TO THOSE
BORROWERS TO THOSE LENDERS SO
THERE'S NO CONSUMER PROTECTION
IN THAT REGARD.
I WOULD ALSO ARGUE THAT ON THE
DATABASE THERE ARE SO MANY
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS THIS IS A
STATE MANDATED DATABASE WHERE
LICENSEES WILL HAVE TO TRANSMIT
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS ORDER I
AM INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYER
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER. AS WELL
AS BY DEFINITION FINANCIAL
INFORMATION AND SENSITIVE
FINANCIAL INFORMATION TO THE
STATE.
THE STATE IS VERY LIKELY TO USE
A VENDOR TO HAVE THIS DATABASE
IN THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS WE AS LICENSEES. HAVE
ABOUT THE HOW THESE THIS WILL
OPERATE IN VERY LIKELY ARE
CONSUMERS WILL FEEL VERY LITTLE
COMFORT.
THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT THAT THE
VENDOR FOR THE STATE HAVE ANY
INSURANCE IN CASE OF A DATA
BREACH. THERE'S NO INDEMNITY FOR
LICENSEES IF THERE IS A STATE
MATTER DATA BREACH.
WILL HAVE TO.
.
DO WE HAVE TO BEAR THE COST AS
LICENSEES WHO'S GOING TO BEAR
THE COST WHO WILL PAY THAT.
WHAT ABOUT A BREACH NOTICE WILL
THAT REACH KNOWS COME FROM THE
VENDOR WILL COME FROM THE
LICENSEE?
UNDER THE CURRENT CURRENTLY
PENDING IN THE SENATE THERE'S A
LAW THAT CREATES LIABILITY FOR
DATA BREACHES WHO WILL PAY THAT
LIABILITY.
IS THE DEPARTMENT SOME BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT ONE OF THEIR EXAMINERS
WHO IS COMING TO OUR OFFICES IF
THEIR COMPUTER IS STOLEN.
WHO'S GOING TO BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THAT LIABILITY.
IF THERE'S NEGLIGENCE WHAT
HAPPENS
ON THE END THERE NO LIMITATIONS
IN THIS BILL ON THE VENDORS USE
OF THE INFORMATION THAT WE WERE
MET. SO THAT BILL CURRENTLY IS
SILENT ON WHETHER THE VETS
DESCRIBED AS A CONFIDENTIAL
DATABASE BUT IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT
THAT INFORMATION ON THAT WHAT
THE VENDOR CAN AND CANNOT DO. SO
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF UNDER
ANSWERED QUESTIONS AND FOR ALL
OF THESE REASONS WE MUST. OPPOSE
AB THIRTY TEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
CHAIRMAN CHAO I'M TONY.
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF
REGULATORY AFFAIRS FOR
EXPERIENCE.
HOW WERE CREDIT ABOUT BUREAU
BASED AND?
CALIFORNIA HAS TO.
PRIMARY CONCERNS THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SHARE WITH THE COMMITTEE.
IS THAT THE CREATION OF THE.
STATE CONTROLLED DATABASE.
WOULD REALLY NOT HELP THE
CONSUMER IN TERMS OF HELPING
THAT CONSUMER BUILD THEIR CREDIT
HISTORY.
UNLIKE OTHER CREDIT BUREAU
DATABASES.
WHAT A CONSUMER?
PAYS ALONE ON TIME THEY SHOULD
GET CREDIT FOR THAT DATABASE IN
THIS IT FOR THAT DOT FOR THAT
PERFORMANCE SUPER THAT BEHAVIOR
IN THIS CASE. THIS TYPE OF DATA
WOULD BE SEALED IN A SILO
DATABASE AND NO OTHER LENDER
WOULD HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GIVE YOU THAT GOOD PERFORMANCE
FROM THAT DATA.
CONSUMER.
WE ESTIMATE THAT THERE ARE FORTY
FIVE MILLION CONSUMERS IN THE
UNITED STATES MANY OF THEM IN
CALIFORNIA.
WHO ARE CREDIT INVISIBLES
THEY WOULD BE THERE DON'T HAVE A
CREDIT REPORT? UP FULL CREDIT
REPORT MANY OF THEM DON'T EVEN
HAVE A FINANCIAL IDENTITY.
AND IF WE'RE GOING TO FORCE
LENDERS TO REPORT TO A DATABASE
WE THINK IT WOULD BE WISER. TO
USE EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE OF
CREDIT REPORTING SYSTEMS THAT
ALREADY EXIST.
THERE WE THEREFORE WE CAN BUILD
THOSE.
CONSUMERS CREDIT FILES
GIVE THEM MY FINANCIAL IDENTITY.
AND GET THEM ON THE ROAD TO
BETTER PRICED.
TERMS AT AND SERVICES IN
INTEREST RATES AND OTHER
COMPETITIVE FINANCIAL MARKETS.
THAT'S OUR CHIEF CONCERN.
ANOTHER CONCERN IS THAT.
WHAT?
WHETHER INADVERTENTLY OR NOT.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
CREATING A CREDIT BUREAU IN THIS
ACT.
THE CREDIT THE DEFINITION OF A
CREDIT BUREAUS ANY.
ANY ENTITY INCLUDING A
GOVERNMENT OF.
AGENCY.
THAT COLLECTS FINANCIAL
INFORMATION AND SHARES IT WITH
THE LENDER FOR PURPOSES OF
ASSESSING ELIGIBILITY. FOR
CREDIT.
THAT IS WHAT THIS IS GOING TO DO
IT'S GOING TO COLLECT DATA FROM.
LENDERS AS GOING TO RETURN DATA
TO LENDERS FOR ASSESSING CREDIT
ELIGIBILITY FOR A SHORT TERM
LOAN SO IT IS A. CREDIT BUREAU.
.
WITH THAT COMES ALL OF THE
INDEPENDENT.
REQUIREMENTS OBLIGATIONS AND
LEGAL.
STANDARDS UNDER THE FAIR CREDIT
REPORTING ACT.
AS IMPORTS BY BOTH THE FEDERAL
AND STATE LAWS. INCLUDING THE
CONCEPT OF. MAXIMUM POSSIBLE
ACCURACY IN CONSUMER FIVE.
HEREIN WITH THESE AMENDMENTS
WERE LIMITING THE NUMBER OF
IDENTIFYING ELEMENTS THAT CAN
COME WITH A REPORTED LAW EVER
REPORTED LOAN.
I TO ONLY SOCIAL SECURITY IN A.
NUMBER.
MAXIMUM
POSSIBLE ACCURACY.
FACT THE STANDARD IN THE CREDIT
BUREAU SYSTEM AS REQUIRED BY
FEDERAL LAW IS AT LEAST A NAME.
AND ADDRESS A DATE OF BIRTH AND
A SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER.
IF YOU'RE LIMITING THE
INFORMATION THAT THE.
LENDERS CAN REPORT TO THE
CREDIT BUREAU IN THIS CASE THE
STATE.
AND THE STATE CAN'T MATCH THOSE.
LOANS TO THE RIGHT PERSON WITH
A DEGREE OF ACCURACY REQUIRED BY
THE BE IN VIOLATION OF THE LAW.
AND WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IS YOU
WOULD HAVE MERGED.
OR TRACK OR.
.
OR.
SEPARATED RECORDS AND THAT IS
YOU MAY BE DENYING.
SOMEONE CREDIT
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT MATCH THE
RIGHT LOAN FOR YOU MATCH THE
LOAN TO THE WRONG PERSON.
SO THESE ARE VERY SERIOUS
ISSUES.
OUR THEY COME WITH SEVERE
PENALTIES. THEY COME WITHOUT
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
INCLUDING CLASS ACTIONS AND JUST
TO GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE OF HOW
IMPORTANT THESE MATCHING
ELEMENTS ARE.
I WE'VE RUN TESTS ON OUR OWN
DATABASE.
THERE ARE TWELVE JUAN GONZALEZ'S
WITH SIMILAR SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS WHO LIVE AND MAIN STREET
IN SANTA ANA CALIFORNIA. SO
MATCHING THESE RECORDS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ASPECT OF THE ACCURACY
THAT WE WANT IN THESE.
AND SO BY DENYING.
LENDERS TO REPORT THESE UP
LOANS TO THE CREDIT BUREAU USING
A MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF IDENTIFYING
AND GET THEIR INFORMATION IS
VERY DANGEROUS NOW I UNDERSTAND.
THE NEED TO BALANCE.
PRIVACY AND SECURITY BUT WE
ALSO HAVE THE STANDARD OF
ACCURACY THAT MUST BE MET I
WOULD HAVE TO SAY.
THAT UNDER THIS LAW EXPERIAN
COULD APPLY.
AS THE CERTIFIED REPRESENTATIVE
TO MANAGE THIS DATABASE BUT
UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES I DOUBT
THAT WE WOULD.
BECAUSE WE COULDN'T SUSTAIN THE
LIABILITY OF IT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES SO IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
MISTER MEMBERS RAINY PERRY THERE
REGIS HAS HAD SOME HEALTH
COMMUNITY CHOICE FINANCIAL IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN JOHN CABOT TECH
ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF INDEPENDENT
BUSINESS CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU EXPLOITS.
JASON SHELTER ABOUT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FINANCIAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES.
GOD.
IF YOU'RE PATIENTS TRENT MATSON
MONEY TREE IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
AN ABSOLUTE GO CHECK IN A CASH
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
NATASHA FOREMAN WITH ADVANCE
AMERICA IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES.
EITHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSE SEEING
NONE. LET'S UP BRING IT BACK TO
OUR COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
OUR THAT YES MISGUIDED ED.
VETERANS LEARN.
SO I I YOU KNOW I'M NOT SURE I
AGREE WITH THIS NOTION THAT WE
SHOULD LIMIT EACH PERSON TO ONE
PAYDAY LOAN BUT.
LET'S JUST ASSUME THAT IF
SOMEONE WOULD WANT TO ACCOMPLISH
I'M WONDERING IF THERE MIGHT BE.
AND I EASIER WAYS TO DO IT AND
GREEN THIS BIG KNEW.
DATABASE SEEMS LIKE QUITE AN
UNDERTAKING OTHERS PRIVACY
CONCERNS APPARENTLY ISSUES OF
RELIABILITY.
POTENTIAL LIABILITY FOR THE
STATE.
I SO YOU KNOW WHAT ABOUT JUST
HAVING THE PAYDAY LENDERS ASK
PEOPLE YET ANOTHER ONE OUT.
AT THAT I DON'T THINK WOULD WORK
AND I I DON'T I DON'T HAVE ANY
EVIDENCE THAT THAT WOULD WORK
AND THAT IT WOULD GET TO THE END
GOAL WHICH IS ENSURING. THAT.
A CONSUMER.
THIS IS ONE OF MULTIPLE PRODUCTS
IF YOU NEED MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS THERE'S A
DIFFERENT PRODUCT FOR YOU AND SO
THE IDEA IS THAT THIS. BILL
WOULD NOT ALLOW INDIVIDUALS TO
STACK BUT RATHER IT WOULD DIRECT
IN TO A DIFFERENT PRODUCT THE
THREE HUNDRED OVER PRODUCT THE
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED ARE IN OVER
PRODUCT.
SO I THINK THAT THIS IS WHAT
THAT'S REALLY ABOUT.
I WOULD SAY THAT ON THERE'S
BEEN A NUMBER OF I THINK BANKING
POLICY IT DIDN'T ISSUES THAT
HAVE BEEN.
BROUGHT UP HERE AND THE BANKING
COMMITTEE DID GET THIS BILL OUT
YESTERDAY SO THOSE WERE
DISCUSSED IN BANKING ONE WAS
WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S A MERRY
OF ONE. A LOAN AT A TIME THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ANY EVIDENCE THAT
THIS IS CREATING A CREDIT FOR I
THINK THAT THERE IS SOME
DIFFERENCE IN OPINIONS THERE.
AND AND THE ISSUE OF CREDIT
REPORTING ALL TOGETHER IS I
THINK THAT IT VIA A DIFFERENT
ISSUE FOR THE BANKING COMMITTEE.
AS FAR AS THE DATABASE IS
CONCERNED AND WE KNOW THAT THE
COMMITTEES YEAH STAFF WAS VERY.
HELPFUL IN HELPING US MARY DOWN
WE'RE VERY MUCH INTERESTED IN
MAKING SURE WE DON'T COLLECT
MORE WE DON'T COLLECT LESS THAN
THE INFORMATION WE NEED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL WE COLLECT JUST THE
RIGHT INFORMATION THROUGH VERY
OPEN TO HAVING DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT.
WHAT EXACTLY IS THE RIGHT
INFORMATION AND WHAT EXACTLY IS
THE RIGHT TOOL AND THAT? WERE
ABSOLUTELY READY I MEAN TO TO
HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
ABOUT THE DATABASE ITSELF
THAT'S HELPFUL THANK YOU AND BUT
YOU KNOW IF SOMEONE GOES INSIDE
AND THEY ASK OUR IDEA OF ANOTHER
PAY ONE OUT IN PERSON SAYS.
YES I DO THEM I CAN'T IS A STAR
YOU'RE ON ELIGIBLE ONE OF ONE
NETWORK.
YEAH WELL THEY'D WANNA VERIFY
THAT INFORMATION I THINK THAT
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO VERIFY THE
INFORMATION JUST LIKE WE VERIFY
OTHER INFORMATION OUT THERE FOR
FINANCIAL SERVICES. ON THIS IS.
SHORT TERM.
YOU KNOW BARRING LOAN OF SORTS
AND SO I THINK THAT WE WOULD DO
THAT FOR OTHER LOANS AND SO IT'S
IMPORTANT TO DO IT TO MAKE
PEOPLE AND BE TRUTHFUL ABOUT THE
CONCERN. I THINK IT WOULD BE
DIFFERENT IDEA I THINK IT COULD
BE DIFFERENT THINGS I THINK THAT
COULD BE ONE OF THEM I ALSO
THINK AND. THAT PEOPLE HOW YOU
KNOW HAVE BEEN KNOWN TO GO GET
MORE THAN ONE A DAY AND SO THE
IDEA IS THAT.
WHAT WHT THAT THE OF THE GOAL
IS FOR THE CONSUMER TO GET THE
RIGHT PRODUCT AND IF THE THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS THE PAYDAY LOAN
ITSELF ISN'T THE RIGHT PRODUCT
FOR THEM AND THEY NEED MORE?
THAN THEY SHOULD GO DIFFERENT
ONE AND AND ALL OF THE PRODUCTS
OUT THERE HAVE DIFFERENT LEVELS
OF THE.
GUIDELINES AND RESTRICTIONS IN
TERMS OF WHAT KIND OF THE
GOVERNMENT'S LAWS AROUND THEN
I'M IN THE CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
AS IN TIME YEAH I'M TRYING TO
HELP YOUR COUSINS AT A LOT OF
CONCERNS AROUND THE DATABASE SO.
I KNOW WHAT YOU JUST HAD SOMEONE
SIGN SOMETHING SAYING THIS IS MY
ONLY PAID A ONE WITHOUT WORK DO
THINK.
I KNOW SO I MEAN JUST IN THE
SAME WAY THAT WE DON'T ASK OF
PEOPLE WHETHER OR NOT THEY'VE
EXCEEDED THEIR CREDIT YOU KNOW
LIMIT ON THEIR CARD AND PEOPLE
USE IT I THINK IT'S ALONG THE
SAME WAY THAT SHOULD BE A SYSTEM
IN PLACE. THAT.
THE YOU KNOW BUSINESS IS ABLE
TO TRACK
AND SO THIS IS REALLY ABOUT
MAKING SURE IN TRACKING AND
MAKING SURE THAT THE BUSINESSES
AND COMPLIANCE AND ALSO MAKING
SURE THAT THE CONSUMER IS
DIRECTED TO THE RIGHT PRODUCT.
OKAY HIGH AND I I SEE THAT POINT
I GUESS I GUESS MY THOUGHT IS
THAT YOU KNOW SOMEONE IS.
WHEN TO LIE IN ORDER TO GET ONE
OF THESE LOANS ARE GOING TO YOU
KNOW FIND AFFINITY PER YEAR
SOMETHING THEN THAT'S PRIDE HAVE
PERSON THAT WOULD THEN BE
WILLING TO GO OUT AND TRY TO
FIND. YOU KNOW SOMEONE REGULATED
TYPE OF WOUND SOME KIND OF
WONDERING. AT HOW MUCH BENEFIT
REALLY A GET OUT OF THE DATABASE
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THE COST
BENEFIT THERE AYE I WOULD BE
RUNNING THE BILL IF I DIDN'T
THINK THAT THERE IS A BENEFIT.
TO IT UPON.
SO I AM VERY CLEAR THAT I
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS A BENEFIT
TO THIS I BELIEVE THAT IT IS
ALSO ABOUT HELPING THE CONSUMER
AND GUIDING THEM.
I YOU KNOW AS SOMEONE WHO'S
WALKED INTO MULTIPLE OF THESE
PAID A LEN STORIES AROUND THE
STATE AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO GET THE RIGHT INFORMATION TO
MAKE SURE I MEAN WHEN YOU GO OUT
TO THE GROCERY STORE AT ONCE YOU
START TO KNOW YOUR GROCERY STORE
TO. MAKE A DECISION ON WHETHER
YOU'RE GONNA GO TO COSTCO OR
WHETHER YOU'RE GOING TO NOTICE
MARGARET YOU SIR BASED ON THE
NEEDS I THINK IT'S ABOUT
UNDERSTANDING. AND THE PRODUCTS
THAT ARE OUT THERE UNDERSTANDING
THE NEED AND MAKING SURE THAT
FOR WHATEVER YOU'RE SHOPPING
WHERE EVERY ARE GETTING.
AT THE PRODUCT THAT MEETS THAT
NEED THAT YOU HAVE THAT THERE'S
A SYSTEM IN PLACE AND TO VERIFY
THAT THAT'S THE RIGHT PIECE FOR
YOU I MEAN. IN MY MIND I THINK
LOANS AND FINANCES ARE IMPORTANT
ENOUGH TO HAVE YOU KNOW A DOUBLE
CHECK AND MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE.
YOU KNOW GETTING FOLKS INTO THE
RIGHT.
PRODUCT THAT THEY NEED I THINK
THAT THERE'S ALSO LONG TERM A
IMPACTS TO WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
THEY'RE STACKING.
YESTERDAY THERE IS A ROBUST
CONVERSATION IN THE COMMITTEE
ABOUT WHAT STACKING MEANS AND
WHAT THE NUMBERS REALLY LOOK
LIKE FOR AN INDIVIDUAL AND HOW
YOU KNOW THERE ARE A HIGH
PERCENTAGE OF INDIVIDUALS IN
CALIFORNIA THEY GET THE SAME
ONE.
MORE THAN TEN TIMES IN A ROW AT
A FORTY FIVE DOLLAR FEE ON AT
THAT POINT THAT SEE THAT YOU'VE
ADDED AN ACCUMULATED IS MUCH
MORE THAN THE LOAN ITSELF. AND
SO I THINK THAT THERE'S A NUMBER
OF AT OF PIECES OF EVIDENCE THAT
LEAD ME TO BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
ACTUALLY THE RIGHT APPROACH FOR
A AS OPPOSED TO JUST HAVING
SOMEONE VERIFY THEMSELVES.
OF ONE OTHER THAT DISCUSS SIDE
ISSUE AYE AYE KNOWS THE BILL'S
TAG MAJORITY VOTE BUT THERE'S
THIS.
AFTER THE THAT.
.
YOU KNOW DOESN'T REALLY SEEM TO
AND THIS IS REALLY BENEFIT
BENEFIT THE FOLKS WHO ARE PAYING
FOR IT IS EGGMAN LOOKED AT
WHETHER THIS IS MORE PROPERLY
CONSIDERED A FEAR ATTACKS AND
WHETHER THIS MIGHT ACTUALLY BE A
TWO THIRDS OF I JUST HATE FOR IT
TO. GO THROUGH THE DOOR SUDDENLY
IN IN COURT AFTERWARDS.
I I'M SORRY CAN YOU CLARIFY WHAT
FEE AND WHERE DID YOU SEE THAT
SO THE LICENSEES ARE THE FOLKS
WHO ARE ACCESSING THE DATABASE
ARE THEY.
I THINK IN YOUR BILL AS OPPOSED
TO PAY A FEE IN ORDER TO. ACCESS
IT.
IT'S A LICENSE.
YEAH SO WE HAVE LICENSES GET ALL
OVER BUSINESS COMMUNITIES HAVE
LICENCES THEY PLAYED THEY PAY
FOR AN ADULT LOT OF DIFFERENT
INDUSTRIES NOT JUST IN THIS
PARTICULAR FINANCE WHEN. OTHER
THAT CORRECTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE ARE. I I DON'T WANT
TO SHARE WITH YOU THAT.
YA FROM MY PERSPECTIVE I THINK
IT'S ALWAYS HELPFUL TO HAVE MORE
INFORMATION. GAIA BUT YET I
THINK OUT WE DON'T WANT TO BE
EXCESSIVE WE AND COLLECTING THE
INFORMATION AND ALSO WE WANTED
TO PROTECT THE.
CONSUMERS INTO MISSION AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE IN AT LEAST TO OUR
COMMITTEES FOCUSES PRIMARILY ON
PRIVACY AND CONSUMERS. SO AS
WELL AS TO WHETHER KNOCKED OUT
YOU KNOW WE SHOULD GRAN DIED
ADDITIONAL PAYDAY LOANS TO TO
CONSUMERS I THINK. I THINK I
BELIEVE THAT YOU MENTION THAT
YOU HAVE HAD THAT DISCUSSION
THIRD DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT
YESTERDAY SO WE WILL NOT GONNA
RE HASHED OUT HERE. SO ARM SO IN
GENERAL I THINK IT YOU KNOW THIS
CONCEPT BY IKE I COULD SUPPORT
AND ON YET YOU KNOW I THINK IF
THERE'S WORK TO BE DONE I URGE
YOU TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS SO FROM THIS POINT
ON. AND SEE IF THERE'S A YOU
KNOW WAIT HERE.
GETS MORE ON A BIAS FROM THE UP
OPPOSITION AS WELL.
SO WE GOT THAT WHICH LIKE THE
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN I.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHEN WAS WE
HAVE QUORUM THEN WILL LOOK AT
THAT GUN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I BELIEVE YOU HAVE ONE MORE
BILL.
AND.
LET'S SEE.
THAT WOULD BE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
THAT'S AB THIRTY TWO OH SEVEN.
AB THIRTIES.
CAN I START YAK NDA HIM.
RIGHT YOU YOU MAY BEGIN GREAT
THANK YOU A. B. THIRTY TWO SEVEN
WILL PROVIDE IMPORTANT CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS FOR THE THOUSANDS OF
CONSUMERS SERVICE BY THE FINANCE
LENDERS AND BROKERS LICENSE.
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA FINANCING
LAW. UNDER EXISTING LAW THE
DEFINITION OF BROKER IS VAGUE
AND CIRCULAR LEADING TO THE
CONFUSION OF FROM LENDERS ABOUT
WHICH ENTITIES THEY CAN PARTNER
WITH AND WENT WHEN ARRANGING
LOANS.
FURTHER THE DEFINITION OF BROKER
IN EXISTING LAW WAS FORMULATED
LONG BEFORE THE RISE OF THE
INTERNET AND EVOLUTION OF ONLINE
WILL LEND ONLINE LEAD GENERATION
SO OUR LAWS NEED TO BE UPDATED.
WITH THIS ONLINE ACTIVITY IN
MIND LEAD GENERATE BARRIERS
PROVIDE VALUABLE MARKETING
SERVICES TO A WIDE RANGE OF
INDUSTRIES HOWEVER MANY ONLINE
LEAD GENERATORS THAT SERVE THE
LENDING INDUSTRY PROVIDE MORE
THAN JUST MARKETING SERVICE.
THESE ENTITIES ACT AS BROKERS
WHEN THEY'RE TRYING WHEN THEY
BRING BARS AND LENDERS TOGETHER
TO ARRANGE A LOAN BASED ON
SENSITIVE DATA PROVIDED BY A
PROSPECTIVE. A PROSPECTIVE PARA
BORRAR THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
ONLINE THE GENERATORS TO
CONTINUE TO OPERATE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THEY BELIEVE BE
REQUIRED TO BE LICENSED BY THE
DEPARTMENT. OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT AS THE STATE'S
FINANCIAL REGULATOR THE DB
IS CHARGED WITH REGULATING HOW
BROKERS INTERACT WITH CONSUMERS
TO ENSURE THAT BROKERS DO NOT
ENGAGE IN UNFAIR OR DECEPTIVE
PRACTICES TO STEER CONSUMERS.
INTO LOANS THAT DO NOT MEET
THEIR NEEDS.
I COMMIT TO WORKING WITH
INDUSTRY TO ENSURE THE BILL
APPROPRIATELY ADDRESSES THE
CONSUMER PROTECTION CONCERNS IN
OUR LENDING MARKETS WITHOUT
PLACING UNNECESSARY BURDENS. ON
THE BSINESSES THAT PROVIDE THE
SERVICES.
THE BILL HAS THE SUPPORT OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS OVERSIGHT
AND A COALITION OF CONSUMER
ADVOCATES WHO ARE HERE TODAY TO
VOICE THEIR SUPPORT. AND HERE
AGAIN WE HAVE SUSAN.
MARTINDALE WHO'S GOING TO
COMMENT.
HELLO AGAIN CHAIRMAN MEMBERS US
IS AND MARTIN DEL WITH CONSUMERS
UNION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE HERE WE. SUPPORT EFFORTS
TO CLARIFY IDBI JURISDICTION
OVER COMPENSATED THIRD PARTIES
OR HELP ORIGINATE LOANS FOR
CONSUMERS ALTHOUGH THE RISE OF
THE INTERNET HAS LED TO THE
PROLIFERATION OF ONLINE LEAD
GENERATION SERVICES. YOU'RE
HELPING TO BROKER A LOAN YOU'RE
HELPING TO BROKER A LOAN AND SO
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
THERE'S OVERSIGHT OF THIRD
PARTIES. THAT UPS.
TYPICALLY BECAUSE THEY'RE BEING
COMPENSATED HAVE AN INCENTIVE TO
GET SOMEONE AND ABOUT LOAN AND
SO WHAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IS
THAT THERE IS REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT AND THAT THE DB .
IS GOING IN AND CHECKING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE WHO ARE IN A
MARKETING THESE LOANS HANDLING
SENSITIVE INFORMATION PREPARING
DOCUMENTS AND REALLY ACTING AS
AN AGENT OF THE LENDER WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THOSE FOLKS ARE
BEING REGULATED SUPERVISED. ON
OUR SUBJECT TO BACKGROUND CHECKS
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT COME WITH
THE DB O. BROKERS LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS SO FOR THESE
REASONS WE THINK THIS IS A
SENSIBLE WAY TO UPDATE EXISTING
LAW TO MAKE SURE THE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS KEEP UP. WITH
TECHNOLOGY.
AND THAT'S WHY WE SUPPORT THE
THE BILL AND REQUEST LIKE THAT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
EDITION WOULD STILL HAVE GOOD
AFTERNOON RONALD COLMAN HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION CLICK
ALSO HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
I GUESS IT UP ON THE DS FROM THE
CENTER FOR RESPONSIBLE LENDING
ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME UP
.
SHE LIKE TO MAKE ROOM FOR ONE
MORE YET DAVID KEENE TANA BUT.
GET THAT.
OKAY.
DAVID CANTON WITH THE ONLINE
LENDERS ALLIANCE AND WE ARE HERE
IN A POSITION OF OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED.
BUT THAT BEING SAID WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
AUTHOR AND HER COMMITTEE STAFF
AND WE FEEL VERY OPTIMISTIC THAT
IS AS THIS BILL MOVES THROUGH TO
THE NEXT COMMITTEE.
BASED UPON OUR CONVERSATIONS
THAT I THINK WE SHOULD GET TO A
PLACE WHERE WE ARE.
IN IN MUTUAL AGREEMENT SO A BUT
TO ELABORATE A LITTLE MORE IN
OUR CONCERN I HAVE WITH ME
DONALD ON THE HEAD OF COMPLIANCE
WITH A LICENSE LEAD GENERATOR.
LOAN CALL.
RIGHT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
GOD MAKE YOU DAVID IN A.
SO.
DID TODAY'S.
QUITE SPECIAL WHEN AND THAT'S
BECAUSE I AS A YOUNG UCLA
STUDENT A.
I I STILL RECALL MY PARENTS ARE.
PUSHING ME TO GET A PHOTO WITH
THAT CHAIRMAN SHALL.
THEY WERE RESIDENTS OF SAN
GABRIEL.
SO THIS IS THAT KIND OF A FULL
CIRCLE FOR ME.
JUST A SO SO WE'RE HERE TODAY TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL I WANT.
AMENDED.
BUT.
WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR. SENATE
CHAIRPERSON LIMON IN OUR
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WILLINGNESS
TO WORK WITH US SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT.
IS SOME OF THE MAIN CONCERNS OF
THIS BILL IS THAT.
IT.
IT DOESN'T SEPARATE TO THE
DEFINITION OF A BROKER AND A
LEAD GENERATOR.
THEY'RE TWO COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT THINGS.
BROKER WILL HELP YOU GET YOUR
PAPERWORK SIGN. SPED THE HANDLE
THE APPLICATION THEY NEGOTIATE A
BETTER DEAL FOR YOU.
LEAD GENERATOR LIKE US LOCAL.
WE DON'T.
WE DON'T DO THAT WE SIMPLY
CONNECT THE CONSUMER TELANDER WE
SIMPLY.
AND MAKES INTRODUCTIONS AND SAY
HERE'S THE CONSUMER WE DON'T DO
ANY NEGOTIATION WHERE WE DON'T
DO ANY.
HANDING HANDLING OF THE
APPLICATION.
SO. IN CONCLUSION LEAD
GENERATORS LIKE US OR A CRUCIAL
PART OF CONSUMER PROTECTION.
SNEH THOUGH REASON I KNOW THAT
IS BECAUSE THE MY TEAM AND I WE
BET OUR LENDERS EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
AND WE REVIEW MARKETING CONTENT
EVERY SINGLE DAY TO MAKE SURE
THEY'RE NOT DECEPTIVE.
TO CONSUMERS.
SO PLEASE ALONE PLEASE CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH US AND WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT ONE IS
PLACE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER SCOTT
GOVERNOR BEHALF CALIFORNIA
FINANCIAL SERVICES ASSOCIATION
LIKE I THINK THE CONSULTANT FOR
A TRAFFIC ANALYSIS THE ONLY
THING IT'S MISSING OUR.
SUGGESTIONS THAT HAD A HOW TO
IMPROVE THESE ITEMS.
I AGREE WITH THE PRIOR WITNESS
OF LIKE TO ADD ONE THING THAT
THE BILL IS SOMEWHAT. OPEN
ENDED.
AS REFERENCE BY THE STAFF AND
THEN GOES FURTHER BY SAYING
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
WHICH MEANS EVERYTHING IN THE
BILL OF THE DEFINITIONS IN THE
BILL. COULD BE FURTHER EXPANDED
BY DB .
PROBLEMATIC WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE'S SHOULD TAKE THAT
ROLE AND NOT GIVE CARTE BLANCHE
TO THE RIGHT REGULATOR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BEFORE WE GO TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES A LIKE TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM.
MADAM SECRETARY WELCOME PLACE
CHILDCARE CAT KILEY. BAKER.
BERMAN.
CALDERON.
IRWIN.
MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE HERE.
VARIOUS.
KING.
I SELECT TO ENTERTAIN MOTION TO
APPROVE TO TODAY'S AGENDA
CONSENT AGENDA.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FOR THE V. NINETEEN
SIXTY SEVEN.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY NINE.
AB TWENTY EIGHT TWELVE. AND AB
THIRTY TWO TWENTY NINE.
SHALL TYPE I. HIGHLY. AYE BAKER.
BERMAN ON I CALDERON.
IRWIN.
I MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE I REYES IF. I KING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO LET'S A
RESUME AND NOT GO BACK TO THE
WITNESSES WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IV COULD IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND ALSO TELL US THE
ORGANIZATION THAT YOU'RE
AFFILIATED WITH HOW WOULD BE
VERY HELPFUL.
SEEING NONE ARE.
WEINER'S NO TUNERS IS BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE ARE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THOSE BEEN MOVED.
AND SECOND IT.
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
LET ME SHARE A COUPLE THOUGHTS
WITH THE ARM.
I.
ALSO AGREE THAT.
.
ALI GENERATORS SO ON MAYBE IF
COULD BE DIFFERENTIATED FROM
BROKERS.
BECAUSE WHEN I WAS IN PRACTICE I
I ALSO HAVE TO DEAL WITH BROKERS
ARE FINDERS AND THE LIKE. AYE
YET UP.
ARE CONSUMERS NEED TO BE
PROTECTED REGARDLESS WHETHER THE
CONTACT WAS A BROKER OR A LEAD
GENERATOR WILL FIGHTER SO I
THINK THIS IS A GOOD A GOOD
BILL.
ARM AND I THINK THAT UP THERE
MIGHT BE ARE ISSUES THAT WE NEED
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH FOR
THAT DOWN THE ROAD AND I AM.
PLEASED TO SEE AND HEAR FROM THE
CAN THIS TREE FOLKS THAT THEY'RE
WILLING TO WORK WITH YOU AND
VICE VERSA SO ARE CONSIDERING
THE FACT THAT THE BILL IS GOING
TO GO TO. TO BANKING NEXT.
SO I THINK YOU GUYS WILL HAVE A
CHANCE TO KIND OF.
DUKE IT OUT. SO THIS WEEK THAT
I HOPE YOU WORK IT OUT.
SO.
I AM PLEASED TO SEE THAT SO.
WOULD DOUBT I LIKE TO.
HERE OF YOUR CLOSING ARGUMENTS
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND I THINK YOU'RE CORRECT
WE DO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
DEFINITIONS ARE THERE I THINK
THE MOST SIMPLE THIS WAY THIS IS
ABOUT. AND HOW LENDERS AND
BUYERS GET PAIRED TOGETHER AND
UNDERSTANDING WHO HAS WHAT ROLE
AND MAKING SURE CONSUMERS HAVE
PROTECTIONS IN AND IN TERMS OF
EVERY ROLE THAT THE.
INVOLVED IN CONNECTING THE
LENDERS IN BARS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I WITHOUT DOUBT MADAM
SECRETARY ROLL CALL PLEASE.
DO PASSED TO BANKING AND
FINANCE.
CHAU AYE AYE KILEY. NO BAKER.
BERMAN.
I.
CALDERON.
WHEN. I MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE NO.
REYES.
I TING.
IT DOESN'T COST.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MUCH NEXT WE
HAVE MISTER CHU IS UP NEXT I
BELIEVE.
AND MR CHU HAS.
ITEM NUMBER SIX.
WELCOME MR CHIU IN THE YOU HAVE
TWENTY AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FOUR
GRAY ANYTIME YOU'RE READY YOU
MAY BEGIN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
FOUR. WOULD ALLOW IMMIGRANTS TO
START AND RUN BUSINESSES BY
ALLOWING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT
LICENSE BUSINESSES TO ACCEPT.
A CALIFORNIA DRIVER'S LICENSE
AND INDIVIDUAL TAX ID NUMBER OR
A MUNICIPAL ID.
WHILE THE SNOW IN OUR STATE THAT
THE ECONOMIC SUCCESS OF
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN BUILT BY THE
TREMENDOUS WORK. OF OUR
IMMIGRANT WORKERS AND BUSINESS
FOUNDERS.
IMMIGRANTS CONTRIBUTE THIRTY
TWO PERCENT OF OUR STATE'S GDP
ONE OUT OF THREE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS IN OUR STATE ARE
IMMIGRANTS AND IN RECENT YEARS.
FORTY FIVE PERCENT OF ALL NEW
BUSINESSES WERE FOUNDED BY
IMMIGRANTS.
UNFORTUNATELY ABOUT HALF OF THE
CITIES IN OUR STATE REQUIRE AN
APPLICANT FOR A BUSINESS LICENSE
TO PROVIDE A SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER. THIS HAS BEEN A SYSTEMIC
BARRIER TO MANY CALIFORNIANS
SEEKING ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY
THROUGH BUSINESS OWNERSHIP.
RESTAURANTS AND SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS HOUSE CLEANERS AND BABY
SITTERS INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS
AND PROFESSIONAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS.
THIS BILL PROVIDES A BUILT ON
PREVIOUS STATE LAWS THAT ALLOW
APPLICANTS FOR LICENSES TO
PROVIDE A FEDERAL ID NUMBER. AS
WELL AS CITIES THAT ALLOW FOR
MUNICIPAL ID'S THIS IS
CONSISTENT WITH FEDERAL LAW
WHICH AUTHORIZES STATES THAT
MAKE PROFESSIONAL AND COMMERCIAL
LICENSES AVAILABLE TO IMMIGRANTS
REGARDLESS OF STATUS.
THE BILL ALSO PROTECTS THE
NUMBERS COLLECTED BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FROM DISCLOSURE.
EXCEPT AS REQUIRED TOADMINISTER
THE PROGRAM OR COMPLY WITH THE
STATE LAW OR A FEDERAL COURT
ORDER AND I ALSO SHOULD HAVE
STARTED BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS IN ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS.
WITH THAT I WANT TO THANK OUR
SPONSORS THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER AND THE
LAWYERS COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS AND TURN IT OVER TO OUR
WITNESSES.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SUSHIL
JACOB AND I'M A STAFF ATTORNEY
AT LAWYERS COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA. A CO SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY FOUR. LAWYERS
COMMITTEE FOCUSES ON CIVIL
RIGHTS IN THE ECONOMY
PARTICULARLY ON EXPANDING ACCESS
TO ENTREPRENEURSHIP FOR
MINORITIES AND IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES.
THE NEED FOR THIS BILL AROSE
FROM OUR WORK WITH IMMIGRANT
BUSINESS OWNER CLIENTS.
AND FROM PARTNER ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE INCLUDING THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WHERE WE LEARNED
THAT MANY LOCALITIES REQUIRE
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS ON LOCAL
BUSINESS APPLICATIONS.
FOR EXAMPLE ONE OF OUR CLIENTS
IS BROUGHT TO THE U. S. AT THE
AGE OF FIVE.
SHE GRADUATED FROM HIGH SCHOOL
AND COULD NOT ATTEND COLLEGE.
INSTEAD SHE STARTED A BUSINESS
IN YOUR COMMUNITY SELLING HOME
DECOR ITEMS.
AND PORTED FROM HER HOME REGION
OF MEXICO.
HOWEVER DUE TO OAKLAND SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER REQUIREMENT SHE
COULDN'T PERSONALLY OBTAIN A
BUSINESS LICENSE.
INSTEAD SHE ENDED UP OPENING THE
BUSINESS AND HER YOUNGER
SISTER'S NAME.
BECAUSE HER SISTER HAD A SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER.
THAT TEMPORARY FIX
CREATED MANY OTHER PROBLEMS FOR
OUR CLIENT BECAUSE HE WAS
DEPENDENT ON HER SISTER DESIGN
ALL OF HER BUSINESS DOCUMENTS
INCLUDING GETTING BANK LOANS.
SUCH BARRIERS PREVENTED OUR
CLIENT FROM EXPANDING HER STORE
TO ADDITIONAL LOCATIONS.
BECAUSE OF THE FEAR OF
ADDITIONAL LIABILITY AND CAUSING
STRAIN IN HER RELATIONSHIP WITH
HER SISTER.
THE CLIENT HAD SINCE OBTAINED A
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER AND
TRANSFER THE BUSINESS TO HER
NAME.
AND OUR CLIENT WOULD LIKE
LAWMAKERS TO KNOW THAT MANY
UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE ARE
STRUGGLING TO SURVIVE IN
CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE THERE AND
UNABLE TO LEGALLY GET JOBS.
AND LOCAL BUSINESS APPLICATIONS
THAT REQUIRE SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS PLACE FURTHER BARRIERS
ON THEIR ABILITY TO SURVIVE AND
REMAIN HERE. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY AND.
M. YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR NECKS
WHEN HIS PLACE THAT AFTERNOON
MISTER CHANG COMMITTEE MEMBERS
JEAN AT THE SILVA GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS MANAGER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER. WE ARE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THESE EFFORTS TO REMOVE
BARRIERS.
TO BUT IT BUSINESS OWNERSHIP BY
CLARIFYING THAT OTHER FORMS OF
GOVERNMENT ID MAY BE USED TO
APPLY FOR A BUSINESS LICENSE
WHILE ALSO MAINTAINING SOME
CONFIDENTIALITY OF THAT PERSONAL
INFORMATION.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU SAID
THIS LEGISLATION IS REALLY
CONSISTENT WITH LOCAL AND STATE
LAWS THAT FULLY INTEGRATE
IMMIGRANTS INTO OUR STATE'S
ECONOMY AND PUBLIC LIFE. WHILE
ALSO SUPPORTING REGULATORY
COMPLIANCE AND PROTECTING THE
PRIVACY RIGHTS OF OUR RESIDENTS.
EVERYDAY IS A NEW HEADLINE
REGARDING THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORTS TO
TARGET IMMIGRANT FAMILIES AND WE
MUST CONTINUE TO ENSURE THAT OUR
RESIDENTS ARE PROTECTED AGAINST
THEIR EFFORTS TO CRIMINALIZE AND
DEPORT CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE A
CRITICAL PART OF OUR SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC FABRIC. WE THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU FOR HIS
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP ON PASSING
PRO IMMIGRANT LEGISLATION AND WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS AYE
EFFORT TOWARDS JUSTICE INCLUSION
AND ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES PLEASE COME FORWARD.
YOUR NAME AND YOUR ORGANIZATION
PLACE.
NO I BOTTOM ALL REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
NEXT PLEASE.
HELLO ANGELINA ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE.
I INGRAM IS CELIA OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU
NICE.
EVEN HUMANISM BE HAVE A BRADLEY
DEFENSE STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
A LITTLE COUSIN OF US IN OF
IMMIGRANT PARENTS.
HERE'S A CALIFORNIA CITIZEN AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU MUCH.
OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE ARE BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
BILL'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
OF.
NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS SIR WHICH
LIKE A CLOSE MISTER.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S SUPPORT I KNOW THAT
WE ALL UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT
ARE IMMIGRANT. OF BUSINESS
FOUNDERS ARE TOURIST ECONOMY AND
WITH THAT.
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN WITH THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF MADAM SECRETARY
RECALL PLEASE.
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FOUR DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
CHAPTER AYE KILEY LOW BUT NOT
VOTING BAKER.
BERMAN.
I. CALDERON.
IRWIN. AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE. NO.
RENTS. ARE.
FOR.
YOUR BILLS ON CALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
IT BRINGS US TO ON MISTER BLOOM.
I BELIEVE YOU HOW OF OUR AB
TWENTY NINE NINETY EIGHT.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IT'S GOOD
TO BE HERE.
ANYTHING ELSE
AS ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN ON THE
AGENDA.
TWENTY NINE NINETY EIGHT SO
ANYTIME YOU'RE READY YOU MAY.
BEGIN THANK YOU MUST SHARE
MEMBERS THIS BILL PROHIBITS THE
SALE OF CERTAIN MATTRESSES
JUVENILE PRODUCTS. AND A
POLLSTER RE UPHOLSTERED
FURNITURE IN CALIFORNIA IF THEY
CONTAIN TOXIC FLAME RETARDANTS.
THE BILL SEEKS TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS IN
PARTICULAR CHILDREN AND
FIREFIGHTERS WHO ARE OFTEN
EXPOSED TO THESE CHEMICALS AND
THEIR DERIVATIVES. AT FAR HIGHER
LEVELS THAN THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
FOR DECADES FLAME RETARDANT
CHEMICALS HAVE BEEN ADDED TO
MANY HOUSEHOLD PRODUCTS
INCLUDING MATTRESSES SOFAS AND
JUVENILE PRODUCTS.
WE NOW KNOW THAT THESE CHEMICALS
THEMSELVES ARE TOXIC CAUSING A
NUMBER OF ADVERSE HEALTH EFFECTS
IN INDIVIDUAL X. EXPOSED TO
THEM.
INCLUDING REPRODUCTIVE
IMPAIRMENT NEUROLOGICAL IMPACTS
ENDOCRINE DISRUPTION AND CANCER.
FLAME RETARDANTS ARE DANGEROUS
TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC BUT THEY
POSE A PARTICULARLY HIGH THREAT
TO
PACIFIC POPULATIONS INCLUDING
CHILDREN AND FIREFIGHTERS.
INFANTS ARE OFTEN EXPOSED TO
FLAME RETARDANT CHEMICALS
THROUGH CONTAMINATED DUST AND
BREAST MILK AND HAVE BEEN FOUND
TO HAVE THESE CHEMICALS IN THEIR
BODIES. AB THREE TO FIVE TIMES
THAT FOUND IN THEIR MOTHERS.
FIREFIGHTERS ARE ALSO EXPLETIVES
TO FLAME RETARDANTS AND THEIR
DERIVATIVES AT HIGHER LEVELS
THAN THE GENERAL PUBLIC WHEN
FLAME RETARDANT CHEMICALS BURN
THEY RELEASED CARCINOGENIC
SUBSTANCES. KNOWN AS DIOXINS AND
FURANS.
THESE CHEMICALS ARE INHALED BY
FIREFIGHTERS AND LINGER ON
PROTECTIVE CLOTHING EVEN AFTER
FIREFIGHTER LEAVES THE SITE OF A
FIRE.
WE ARE SEEING HIGHER RATES OF
CANCER AMONG FIREFIGHTERS THAN
EVER BEFORE AND FLAME RETURNS
ARE SEEN AS A MAJOR CONTRIBUTOR.
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN CALIFORNIA
UPDATED ITS FLAMMABILITY
STANDARDS DETERMINING THAT THE
ADDITION OF FLAME RETARDANT
CHEMICALS. DO NOT ADD TO FIRE
SAFETY AND INSTITUTING A NEW
STANDARD THAT DOES NOT REQUIRE
THEIR USE
TODAY MANY MANUFACTURERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. HAVE
VOLUNTARILY REMOVED THESE
CHEMICALS FROM THEIR PRODUCTS
HOWEVER STRAGGLERS CONTINUE TO
REMAIN IN WE CANNOT FULLY
PROTECT THE PUBLIC. WITHOUT A
RESTRICTION ON THE SALE OF
SPECIFIC PRODUCTS
CONTAINING THESE CHEMICALS.
THE PRODUCTS AFFECTED BY THIS
BILL MATTRESSES UPHOLSTERED
FURNITURE AND JUVENILE PRODUCTS
DO NOT NEED FLAME RETARDANTS IN
ORDER TO MEET. STATE AND FEDERAL
SAFETY FIRE SAFETY.
OF STANDARDS.
AB TWENTY NINE NINETY EIGHT PUTS
THE CONSUMER SAFETY FIRST.
AND IT WILL PROTECT OUR
CHILDREN.
IT WILL AS WELL PROTECT THE
HEALTH OF FIREFIGHTERS AND
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL ARE OUT OF OUR CASA NOVA.
ON BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND CHRISTY
BOMA ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS
THAT VERY MUCH EFFORTS WHEN HIS
PLACE.
SO THANK YOU CHAIRMAN CHAO
PRIVACY CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS OUT
OF OUT OF GAS AND OF I'M THE
POLICY MANAGER AT THE CENTER FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH.
I'M HERE TO URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
NINE NINETY EIGHT TO PROTECT
CHILDREN FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES FROM TOXIC FOR
MATERNA CHEMICALS OF SERVE NO
EFFECTIVE PURPOSE AND FURNITURE
MATTRESSES AND CHILDREN'S
PRODUCTS.
FOR OVER TEN YEARS THE SENATE
FROM BY MENTAL HEALTH HAS BEEN
WORKING TO PROTECT PEOPLE FROM
THE PROVEN HEALTH THREATS OF
TOXIC FOR RETURNING CHEMICALS.
AND OVER THOSE TEN YEARS WE HAVE
SEEN THE FOLLOWING PATTERN.
SCIENTISTS DOCUMENT UNACCEPTABLE
HEALTH EFFECTS OF FIRE RETARDANT
CHEMICAL.
THE CHEMICALS RESTRICTED
REGULATED BANTER PHASED OUT BY
THE INDUSTRY.
THE INDUSTRY PLACES OFTEN RETURN
TO CHEMICAL WHAT THE NEW ONE.
THEN ALL TOO OFTEN WE DISCOVER
THAT THE REPLACEMENT CHEMICAL
CAUSES MAJOR HEALTH CONCERNS
PROBLEMS SUCH AS REPRODUCTIVE
HARM TO BOTH WOMEN AND MEN.
DESTRUCTIVE TO THE BODY'S
HORMONE SYSTEM DECREASED IQ IN
CHILDREN CANCER IMMUNE
DISORDERS.
INDEED PUREVIEW RESEARCH
DEMONSTRATES THAT MANY FLAME
RETARDANT CHEMICALS INCLUDING
THOSE ADOPTED A SAFER
REPLACEMENTS ARE HIGHLY TOXIC TO
PEOPLE.
MANY OF THESE CHEMICALS FOR
EXAMPLE OR GANO HOW'D YOU NEED A
FLAME RETARDANTS ARE ADDED TO
PRODUCTS THEY MIGRATE INTO THE
MIGRATE INTO THE DUST AND WE TO
CHRONIC IN HOME EXPOSURE FOR
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES.
I MUST ALSO NOTE THAT THESE
TOXIC FLAME RETARDANT CHEMICALS
DISPROPORTIONATE FACT WINNABLE
COMMUNITIES.
CALIFORNIA'S BUREAU OF HOME
FURNISHINGS AND THURMOND
SOLUTION HAS PIERCY FOUND THE
FLAME RETARDANT CHEMICALS DO NOT
PROVIDE MEANINGFUL FIRE SAFETY
BENEFIT TO FURNITURE.
FURTHERMORE THE CONSUMER PRODUCT
SAFETY COMMISSION WHAT SETS
FLAMMABILITY STANDARDS FOR
MATTRESSES HAS STATED THAT PLANE
RETURNS ARE NOT NEEDED TO MEET
STANDARDS ITS STANDARDS.
THE BUREAU.
RIGHTLY SO REVISED ITS
PLAYABILITY STANDARDS PROVIDE
FIRE SAFETY WITHOUT THEM
RETARDANTS AND EXEMPTED THE
JUVENILE PRODUCTS COVERED BY
THIS BILL FROM FAME ABILITY
STANDARDS.
BECAUSE THE PRODUCTS DO NOT POSE
A SIGNIFICANT FIRE SAFETY RISK.
STUDIES FROM BOTH THE UNITED
STATES AND THE UNITED KINGDOM
KINGDOM CORROBORATE THESE
DECISIONS AND CLEARLY
DEMONSTRATE THREE ESSENTIAL
FACTS.
ONE AS USED A FURNITURE THE
CHILDREN'S PRODUCTS THESE TOXIC
CHEMICALS DO NOT PROTECT PEOPLE
FROM FIRES.
THAT IS TO SAY THE LEAST TOXIC
CHEMICALS PERFORM NO USEFUL
FUNCTION IN THESE PRODUCTS
TWO. MANUFACTURES CAN AFFORD WE
ME FILM ABILITY TANDARDS
WITHOUT THESE CHEMICALS.
AND THREE IF THEY PUT OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS IN DANGER.
THE MAJORITY THESE PRODUCTS
MAJORITY OF PRODUCTS IN EACH OF
THESE CATEGORIES ARE ALREADY
BEING PRODUCED WITHOUT FULLY
RETURNED CHEMICALS UNFORTUNATELY
A SIGNIFICANT MINORITY OF
LAGGARDS IN THESE PRODUCT
CATEGORIES CONTINUE TO EXPOSE
CALIFORNIANS. TO THESE DANGEROUS
CHEMICALS THAT'S WHY AB TWENTY
NINE NINETY EIGHT AIMS TO
ADDRESS AND THAT'S WHY IT'S
NEEDED.
I URGE AYE VOTE.
ON THIS BILL ARE TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA FAMILY CHILDREN AND
OUR COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
WITNESS SORRY SECOND WITNESS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CONGRESS THE BELMONT
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS. OF
PLEASE TO BE CO SPONSORS OF THIS
MEASURE THEY GO JUST ADD THAT.
NOBODY UNDERSTANDS THE SOURCE
AND SPREAD OF FIRE BETTER THAN
FIREFIGHTERS.
BUT EVERY TIME A FIRE FIGHTER
PUTS ON A UNIFORM THEY'RE
REPRESENTING A PROUD. AND HIGHLY
SKILLED PROFESSION.
AND THEY DEPEND THEIR LIVES
DEPEND ON UNDERSTANDING FIRE
BEHAVIOR IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
HOW HE'D ENERGIES TRANSFER
DURING EMERGENCY AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY HOW TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC?
WE AREN'T SCIENTISTS GEMMA
BEHIND ME THE EXPERTS BUT WE ARE
FIRE BEHAVIOR EXPERTS.
AND WHAT WE KNOW IS THERE IS NO
UTILITY FOR THESE CHEMICALS IN
THESE PRODUCTS THERE IN THIS
BILL.
A THEY BRING HARM TO
FIREFIGHTERS AND WHEN THEY WHEN
THEY BURNED AND THEY BRING HARM
TO THE PUBLIC.
SO THE CLEAR CONCLUSION AS THE
RISK IS NOT WORTH THE HARM. IT
BRINGS TO THE PUBLIC SO WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
EXACTLY MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS GREG HAYES HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE TERRACE SYSTEMS
THEY ARE WE MAKE IT NON TOXIC A
FLAME RETARDANT SHALL. I THAT IS
SAFE ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY
AND WE ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL I THINK IMAGE NEXT
PLACE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MORTON CARB
ALTERNATIVE STRATEGY GROUP ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA ALISON
SPORT THANK YOU EXPERTISE.
GENEVIEVE AVEDON ON BEHALF OF
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS
OF THE BILL AND SUPPORT.
ADDITIONALLY THE SEPT FIVE
DRYERS INSTITUTE SEVENTH
GENERATION ADVISORS AND PLASTIC.
POLLUTION COALITION ALL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MATCH NEXT PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MOST EMMA WITH
SHOT YOUR ENTRY ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
PLACE.
DANIEL SILVINO ASSOCIATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I ALREADY HEN AND PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC INTEREST RESEARCH GROUP
CALPERS ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU THANKS PLACE.
PALLETS ALANIZ FELONIES GROUP ON
BEHALF OF VOICE FOR CHOICE
ADVOCACY AND SUPPORT AT U. NEXT
PLACE.
AND WHAT ABOUT SOME OF ON BEHALF
OF CLEAN WATER ACTION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
SO THIS TIME LIKE INVITA TO THE
TASK OF OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS N TIM'S CHEST
ACHE WITH AMERICAN CHEMISTRY
COUNCIL I. APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO.
SHARE OUR CONCERNS WITH THE
BILL AS DRAFTED.
I'M OUR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
IS CENTERED AROUND THREE.
PRIMARY POLICY ISSUES.
NECESSITY.
THE IMPACT AND INNOVATION OF
FIRE SAFETY. AND THE UNDERLYING
BASIS FOR SCIENTIFIC BASIS FOR
THE BILL I'M GONNA TOUCH ON A
COUPLE OF THESE AND AND THEN ASK
DR THOMAS MIGHT STOP FOR HIS HIS
COMMENTS.
OF FIRST THE DEFINITION OF OF
WINTERTIME CHEMICAL NOT BILL.
IN OUR VIEW WOULD NOT ONLY
RESTRICT THE USE OF THOSE WOMEN
TOWARDS THAT ARE CURRENTLY ON
THE MARKET TODAY. BUT WAS
TRICKED THE USE OF ANY FLAME
RETARDANT.
DEVELOP IN THE FUTURE.
INCLUDING THOSE SENTENCES THAT
HAVE NOT YET EVEN BEEN
CONTEMPLATED.
THE BILL DOES NOT TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE RICK GARZA THEIR
CHEMICAL COMPOSITION HAS A
PROPERTIES ANY POTENTIAL LOOKS
EXPOSURE YOU COULD. INDUSTRY TO
CREATE THE GREENEST MOST
SUSTAINABLE OF EFFICIENT
CHEMISTRY.
THAT WOULD APPLY TO FLAME*
PROPERTIES.
AND THAT BILL WOULD BE THAT THAT
CHEMISTRY WOULD BE PROHIBITED
UNDER THIS BILL. THERE'S
CONVERSATION EARLIER ABOUT FIRE
SAFETY STANDARDS IN THE STATE
AND GENERALLY SPEAKING FIRE
STANDARDS PRESCRIBED MATERIAL OR
PRODUCT TEST THAT MEASURES FIRE
PERFORMANCE. IN TERMS OF
IGNITION RELEASE HEAT RELEASE
FLAME SPREAD ECCENTRIC.
THOUGH SANDERS DON'T NECESSARILY
PRESCRIBE.
HOW TO ACHIEVE THOSE DESIRED
OUTCOMES AND AND IT IS TRUE
THAT%
THE STATE SPAM ABILITY STANDARD?
ONLY ACCOUNTS FOR FURNITURE TEST
FOR SMOLDERING IGNITION SOURCES
LIKE CIGARETTES. DOES NOT AND
THAT THEREFORE DOES NOT DEMAND
THE USE OF THESE CHEMISTRIES
HOWEVER SOME MANUFACTURES MAY
FEEL. THAT THERE IS STILL VALUE
IN USING THIS CHEMISTRIES TO
IMPROVE SMOLDERING RESISTANCE OR
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL PRODUCT
SAFETY AGAINST SMALL OPEN FLAMES
LIKE CANDLES. OR DECREASE THE
RATE OF FIRE DEVELOPMENT WHEN
FURNITURE IGNITES THIS BILL
WOULD MAKE THAT IMPOSSIBLE.
SECONDLY BRIEFLY THE STATE IS
HOME TO A UNIQUE REGULATORY
PROGRAM THAT'S OPERATED BY THE
DEPARTMENT TOXICS.
I CAN SAY FOR CONSUMER PRODUCTS
PROGRAM REQUIRES DTS HE TO
ESTABLISH A PROCESS TO IDENTIFY
PRIORITIZE.
EVALUATE AND IF NECESSARY
REGULATE CHEMICALS THEY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY.
TO RESTRICT THOSE.
IN A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT USES
IN OUR VEW WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
REGULATORY PROGRAM IS THE MORE
APPROPRIATE VENUE. FOR
DISCUSSING THESE COMPLEX
SCIENTIFIC QUESTIONS.
FINALLY OF THE STATE'S EXISTING
FURNITURE LABELING LAW ALREADY
REQUIRES A LABEL ON RESIDENTIAL
FURNITURE INFORMING CONSUMERS
WHETHER OR NOT AND I DON'T
CONTAINS A FLAME RETARDANT
CHEMICAL.
CONSUMERS HAVE THE ABILITY TODAY
TO CHOOSE PRODUCTS THAT CONTAIN
FLAME RETARDANTS ARE NOT WE
BELIEVE THIS LEGISLATION
DISCOURAGES INNOVATION.
ARTIFICIALLY LIMITS CONSUMER
CHOICE AND UNNECESSARILY
RESTRICTS THE ABILITY OF
MANUFACTURERS TO USE THESE FIRE
SAFETY CHEMISTRIES IF THEY CHOSE
TO DO SO. AS A FOR THESE REASONS
THAT WE WOULD URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO OPPOSE THE BILL IN ITS
CURRENT FORM THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
WHEN HIS PLEASE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO
THIS AFTERNOON MY NAME IS THOMAS
BETTS BY WAY OF BACKGROUND HAVE
APPEASED AND TALKS COLLEGE A.
THE WORKING IN THE FIELD FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS I'M BOARD
CERTIFIED IN THE UNITED STATES
AND ALSO REGISTER AS A SEX CAO
JUST IN EUROPE. AND HERE AT THE
REQUEST OF BCC I JUST WANT TO
PROVIDE A PERSPECTIVE REALLY ON
TWO OR THREE POINTS ONE.
NOT ALL FLAME RETARDANTS ARE
CREATED EQUAL IN AS A
TOXICOLOGIST I'VE TAKEN A LOOK
AT THE VARIETY OF FLAME
RETARDANTS ACROSS VARIOUS
CHEMICAL CLASSES AND SOME SICK
SERIOUSLY. CLEARLY ARE MORE
SERIOUS. UP POTENTIAL HAS RISEN
RISKS AND OTHERS AND I THINK AN
EXAMPLE OF HOW THIS WAS ANALYZED
BY THE DESIGN FOR ENVIRONMENT
PROGRAM OF THE US EPA ABOUT
THREE OR FOUR YEARS AGO WHEN
THEY PUBLISHED A.
A LOOKING AT ALTERNATIVES TO
FLEXIBLE POLYURETHANE FOAM THEY
HAD AS SPECTRUM OF OF SAFETY IN
ENVIRONMENT PROFILES AS WELL SO
I THINK LOOKING AT THAT IS A
VERY IMPORTANT THING TO DO AS
THAN GROUPING THEM ALL TOGETHER
I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND. THAT THE
TEMPTATION TO DO THAT AND YOU
CAN TAKE CARE OF A WHOLE AREA AT
ONCE BUT MANY OF THINGS YOU MAY
END UP. BANNING ARE ONES WHICH
WOULD BE ACCEPTABLE AND COULD
PROVIDE A BENEFIT AGAIN BENEFITS
NOT MY AREA BILL THE STANDPOINT
OF RISK I THINK THE RISK IS. IS
MIDDLE FOR SOME OF THOSE
CHEMICALS IN CERTAIN USES.
AND SECOND OF ALL WITH REGARD TO
FIREFIGHTERS IT'S AN EERIE I
TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY OFTEN I'LL
GET ASKED. QUESTIONS BY
COMPANIES IF WE DO THE FOLLOWING
WITH THIS IMPROVE THE HEALTH OF
THE PUBLIC OR OF USERS OR PEOPLE
DOWNSTREAM FROM THE A A
CHEMICAL.
AND IT WOULD HAVE TAKEN A LOOK
AT THE FIREFIGHTERS SURE LOOKED
AT VERY CAREFULLY THE CLEARLY IS
AN ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED. WHEN IT COMES TO
CANCER THERE'S NUMBER OF SLAVES
ISSUE INCREASING CANCER A
PROBABLY THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
WAS ONE DONE BY NINE ASH WHICH
IS PUBLISHED THREE OR FOUR YEARS
AGO. LOOKING AT THIRTY THOUSAND
CANCER IF.
THE CITY FIREFIGHTERS AND THE
EX IS SO INCREASES IN SEVERAL
TYPES TYPES OF CANCER.
RESPIRATORY CANCER WHICH THEY
ASCRIBE TO EXPOSURE TO ASBESTOS
BECAUSE IT'S IT'S KIND OF CANCER
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT.
THEY NEVER MENTION FLAME
RETARDANTS BUT THEY DID MENTION.
THAT THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
HAZARDOUS EXPOSURES AND THIS
GOES INCLUDING ASBESTOS AND
DIESEL EXHAUST FEELS AWESOME
ANOTHER THING WHICH UP
FIREFIGHTERS ARE EXPOSED
PARTICULAR BACK IN THE. IN THE
FIREHOUSE THE THIS IS QUOTING
FROM IT THE NATIONAL BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE IT TO YOU THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THESE HAVE
EXPOSURES AND HEAVIEST BUSES AND
DIESEL EXHAUST. AND DIGESTIVE
CANCERS APPEAR SMALL COMPARED TO
EFFECTS OF OTHER FACTORS SUCH AS
DIET WILL BE SEE FIELDS GOT
PHYSICAL ACTIVITY TOBACCO USE
AND ALCOHOL CONSUMPTION WE FOUND
SIMILAR RISK FOR ORAL FEARING
SHE'LL ILLYRIAN SHE'LL. WHICH
UPPER RESPIRATORY CANCERS
COMPARED THE US POPULATION
SIMILAR TO JUST OF CANCERS RISK
FACTORS POLICE AYE TO TOBACCO
AND ALCOHOL CONSUMPTION WITH
LESSER EVIDENCE THAT EXPOSURE TO
WOOD DUST SMOKE. ASBESTOS POLY
AROMATIC HYDROCARBONS WHICH ARE
FOUND IN SMOKE AND ACID MISS MAY
INCREASE THE RISK THERE'S NO
MENTION OF FLAME RETARDANTS.
SO I THINK THERE ARE THINGS THAT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED WITH REGARD
TO FIREFIGHTERS IMPROVE THEIR
HEALTH I DON'T THINK THIS WOULD
HELP AT ALL. ONE THING I THINK
WOULD HELP IN THIS IS GETTING
THE AREA OF INDUSTRIAL HYGIENE
ARE THE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
CANCER FIREFIGHTER. FIREFIGHTER
CANCER SUPPORT NETWORK MAYBE
YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH SOME OF
THOSE MOST OF THOSE RELATE TO
HYGIENE.
DEALING WITH TURNOUT GEAR
CLINICAL EQUIPMENT VERY
PRACTICAL THINGS WHICH COULD BE
DONE TOMORROW THEY DON'T REQUIRE
PRODUCTS TO BE BANNED IN. THE
OVERTIME REMOVED IN THE MARKET
IT DOESN'T REQUIRE COMPLEX
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK BUT I MEAN
AS IN MY PROFESSIONAL OPINION
THAT WOULD MAKE A DIFFERENCE OF
EXPOSURE FIREFIGHTERS TO
CARCINOGENS IMMEDIATELY. THAT
SOMETHING THAT IT DEFTLY TAKES
TRAINING IT TAKES MONEY AND
ENERGY BUT I THINK THAT WOULD
CLEARLY BENEFIT THE FIREFIGHTERS
CERTAINLY MORE THAN THIS BILL
WOULD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ANY
HACKMAN I'M HERE ON BEHALF THE
JUVENILE PRODUCT MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENT EVERYTHING
FROM CRIBS TO STROLLERS TO CAR
SEATS.
WE ARE CONCERNED WITH AB TWO
TWENTY NINE NINETY EIGHT.
UNLESS IT'S AMENDED.
SAFETY IS OUR NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY WE DON'T MAKE PRODUCTS
AND PROVIDE THEM TO CONSUMERS
FOR USE WITH INFANTS AND
JUVENILES.
UNLESS WE BELIEVE THAT THEY'RE
SAFE AND WE HAVE BEEN A LEADING
INDUSTRY AND REMOVING FLAMER
TURNS WHEN THEY'RE NOT NECESSARY
WE WORK FOR THE STATE ON TV ONE
SEVENTEEN AS MENTIONED BY ONE A
SUPPORTERS US LEGISLATION. TO
EXCLUDE JUVENILE PRODUCTS THAT
WE DON'T HAVE TO INTENTIONALLY
ADD ADD THOSE FLAME RETARDANTS.
HOWEVER.
THERE ARE TWO SPECIFIC
INSTANCES OF THIS BILL
RECOGNIZES THAT WE'RE MANDATED
TO USE FLAME RETARDANTS EITHER
TO ME TO YOU WELL STANDARD FOR
SAFETY FOR ELECTRONIC COMPONENTS
OR FOR CAR SEATS BEGIN THE BILL
ADDRESSES BOTH OF THOSE ISSUES.
WERE ASKING THAT THERE BE
UNIFORM STATEWIDE STANDARD WITH
REGARD TO THIS ISSUE.
SAN FRANCISCO'S MOVE FORWARD IN
THIS AREA AND THEIR THEIR BILL
SPECIFICALLY DIFFERS WITH THIS
LEGISLATION AND WE'RE HOPEFUL WE
CAN HAVE A UNIFORM STATEWIDE
STANDARD. SO AGAIN.
WE WE ARE CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE SPONSORS OFFICE IN MY
COURAGE BECAUSE IT ALSO.
LOOK FOR STATEWIDE UNIFORMITY
ON THIS ISSUE THANK YOU. THANKS
VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
YOUR NAME. THANK YOU
MISCALCULATION OBSOLETE.
I'M HERE TODAY FOR THE
INTERNATIONAL SLEEP PRODUCTS
ASSOCIATION. WERE NATIONAL TRADE
ASSOCIATION THAT REPRESENTS
MATTRESS MANUFACTURERS.
NOW WE AGREE WITH MR BLOOM IN
THE PROPONENTS OF THIS BILL OUT
WE DON'T WANT TO TAKE TO THAT.
THAT THAT THERE ARE BAD THIS IS
GOING TO BE VERY QUICK THAT
THERE ARE BAD CHEMICALS THAT
SHOULD BE OUTLAWED.
THE PROBLEM IS THE WAY HE
DEFINES CHEMICALS IN THIS BILL.
WHICH SAYS THAT.
FIRE RETARDANT CHEMICAL MEANS
ANY CHEMICAL THE CONTRIBUTES TO
RETURNING FIRE.
IS SO BROAD THAT COMPLETELY
INERT THINGS LIKE SAND SILICA
WHICH WE DO USE OUR MATTRESSES
WE CAN'T USE UNDER HIS BILL. SO
THE DILEMMA PUTS THE MATTRESS
MANUFACTURES AND IS THAT.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THEY DON'T
USE THE BROMINATED FIRE
RETARDANT CITIES CONCERNED ABOUT
OF THEIR CANDLE HALOGENS OR SOME
OF THESE OTHER CHEMICAL
COMPOUNDS FOR THE PROBLEMS.
EVEN THE BENIGN COMPOUNDS
THAT WE MUST USE TO MEET FEDERAL
OPEN FLAME STANDARDS AND TO MEET
FEDERAL SMOLDERING CIGARETTE
STANDARDS WE CAN'T USE THE
BENIGN UP A CHEMICAL STRATEGIES.
UNDER HIS BILL SO IF HIS BILLS
ENACTED THE WAY IT IS TODAY.
WE CAN'T MEET THE FEDERAL
STANDARD.
AND IF WE USE THE PRODUCTS THAT
WE NEED TO MEET THE FEDERAL
STANDARD THAT WE CAN'T MEET
MISTER BLOOM STANDARD THIS IN
TWENTY NINE NINETY EIGHT.
SO THIS BILL IT'S IT SOUNDS
GREAT TO GET BAD CHEMICALS OUT
OF FURNITURE MATTRESSES WERE ALL
FOR THAT.
WE DON'T HAPPEN TO USE THOSE AND
THE BUT NINE CHEMICALS THAT WE
DO USE WOULD BE COMPLETELY
OUTLAWED BY THIS BILL SO WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO REACH SOME SORT
OF CONCLUSION.
UP RA OF RESOLUTION ON THAT A
ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN ANNUAL
SALES OF MATTRESSES WON'T HAPPEN
IN THE STATE THE DATE STATE
GENERAL FUND TO GIVE IT TO THE
TUNE OF ABOUT EIGHTY MILLION A
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO GET. IT TO
THE TUNE OF ABOUT TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS YOUR TAX REVENUE WILL
LOSING. AND THE HOUSES OF JOBS
AS WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THERE.
NEXT PLACE FOR YOURSELF OF OKAY
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
JOHN CABOT TECH ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL FEDERATION OF
INDEPENDENT BUSINESS CALIFORNIAN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MARGARET CLAD SAMBA HAVE TO
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITION.
BUT HER IMAGE THANKS PLACE.
MELISSA WARNER ON BEHALF OF THE
RETAIL INDUSTRY LEADERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION RETURN
MATCH.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SCENE AND UP BRING
BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
A MISTAKE IS BAKER. IN AND I.
IT IT'S REALLY GOING TO THE
DEFINITION OF FLAME RETARDANT.
AND SEEN WHAT JUST HOW BROAD IT
IS IN MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO NARROW IT TO WHAT IS
HARMFUL. AS AND STILL HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO ALLOW WHAT MIGHT.
WITH TECHNOLOGY OR OTHERWISE BE
ABLE TO BE HELPFUL.
IS PARA NEVER NEVER FIND FIND
IN THE CRIB FIND THE MATTRESS
FINDING ALL THE EQUIPMENT AND
WANTING TO MAKE SURE THAT. OVER
THE LIFE OF MY KIDS NOTHING IN
THERE IS CREATING THAT DASTAN
CREATING THAT. ETHER WHATEVER
THAT WE WANT THEM TO HAVE BUT I
DO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BREADTH OF THE TERM FLAYED
RETURN IT AND WONDER IF THE
AUTHOR MIGHT.
SHARE PERSPECTIVE ON HOW.
AND THAT IS NOT OVERRIDE.
WE ARE CURRENTLY WORKING ON
LANGUAGE WITH OPPOSITION WERE
HAPPY THAT LISTEN TO THEIR
SUGGESTIONS BUT SO FAR WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO COME TO
AGREEMENT I BELIEVE MISTER
COUSIN OVER MAY BE ABLE TO. SHED
MORE LIGHT ON THAT YEAH I THINK.
TO ECHO THOSE THAT COMMENT
WOULD MORE THAN HAPPY TO WORK
WITH.
SEE PRODUCT ASSOCIATION ON ONE
THING WE WOULD LIKE IS FOR MORE
INFORMATION ARM WE UNDERSTAND
THE U. CELICA I'M WE WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO KNOW IF TO USE IN ANY
OTHER TYPE OF FIBERS OF FABRIC
SO THEY MAY BE.
CONSIDER FLAME RETARDANT
CHEMICALS ARM AND SO WE WERE
JUST WAITING ON THAT INFORMATION
SO THAT WE CAN LOOK AT IT
EVALUATING SEE WHAT KIND OF
LANGUAGE WE CAN CREATE A WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE. I'M BUT
WE HAVE NOT RECEIVED THAT.
IT IT'S HARD TO DRAFT LANGUAGE
WHEN WE DON'T KNOW THE
SUBSTANCES WERE TALKING ABOUT
AND I ALSO LIKE TO ADD THAT THE
FLIGHT RETURNING DEFINITION
THAT'S CURRENTLY IN STATUTE HAS
BEEN IN STATURE FOR FIVE YEARS
AND MANY INDUSTRIES HAVE
COMPLIED WITH THINK CONTINUE TO
COMPLY WITH IT.
YEAH I THINK YOU.
KNOWING THAT THINGS KEEP MOVING
ALONG WE KEEP CHANGING I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
OF A BRIDE.
THAT'S MY PRIMARY CONCERN WITH
DESI I APPRECIATE THE INTENT AND
THEM THINK FOR THE ANSWERS.
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE.
.
FIRST ELECTED TO HOUSE BOTH
SIDES IS TO RELEASE AFTER
TODAY'S HEARING IS TO REALLY SIT
DOWN AND TRY TO WORK ON THE
DEFINITION A LITTLE BIT. LA I DO
AGREE THAT THAT IT MAY HAVE TO
BE FINE TUNED SLIGHTLY.
WE DON'T I'M SURE THE AUTHOR
DOES WANT TO INCLUDE EVERYTHING
IN SIGHT SO I'M SO I'M GONNA ASK
MAKE THAT THE OZ RIGHT NOW
OPPOSE ISIS IT DOWN. AND WORK IT
OUT.
HAVING SAID THAT.
I THINK AS FAR AS FAR AS THE.
THE ISSUE REGARDING THE TSC. I
THINK IDEALLY I WOULD AGREE THAT
THE TSC WOULD BE GUARANTEED TO
THE MOST IDEALS. ENTITY TO DO IT
BUT IN LIGHT OF THE FACT THAT
THEY ARE SORT OF RESOURCES US
ALSO TO QUESTION IS WHETHER OR
NOT WE WANT TO WAIT TILL DTS
SEATED TO GET GET INVOLVED. OR
OR DO WE WANT TO TAKE ACTION ALL
IN LIGHT OF THAT THE BODY OF
RESEARCH THAT'S OUT THERE THAT
INDICATES THAT THAT THESE
CHEMICALS ARE NOT EFFECTIVE. AND
ARE NOT NEEDED AS I AS WE HEARD
EARLIER. AND YOU KNOW HOW WE CAN
ADJUST TO SIT SIT BACK AND DO
NOTHING I MEAN YOU KNOW MY
FEELING IS NOW WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING. SO.
IN LIGHT OF THE YOU KNOW THE
POTENTIAL HARM THAT COULD CAUSE
CHILDREN AND FIREFIGHTERS AND
THE LIKE AND AND THAT'S WHY I'M
I WANT TO HAVE I WANNA SEE THIS.
BILL MOVE FORWARD BUT THAT I YOU
KNOW I WANT TO REPEAT THE FACT
THAT I WANT TO ASK YOU GUYS TO
SIT DOWN AND WORK IT OUT. TO
THAT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AMBER'S.
MISTER SHE HE AND A NUMBER OF
THE OTHER FOLKS WHO'VE TESTIFIED
KNOW THAT.
I'M MORE THAN WILLING TO SIT
DOWN AND HASH OUT DETAILS OF
BILLS AND I MAKE THAT COMMITMENT
TO YOU AND THE COMMITTEE AS WE
MOVE FORWARD NINE.
I CAN'T PROMISE OF RESOLUTION
BUT I'M HOPEFUL THAT WILL REACH
ONE AND SAID THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I RECALL.
BILLS REMOVED.
DO I HAVE A SECOND.
AND SECOND AT THEIR LOCAL
PLEASE.
AB.
TWO TWO NINE NINE EIGHT
DO YOU PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
JUMPED HIGH AYE KILEY NO NO
BAKER.
BERMAN. I.
CALDERON.
IRWIN. AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE NO REYES.
TEN.
THE BILL IS ON CALL YOUR THREE
VOTES THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
I. AM TOLD THAT MISTER COOPER IS
PRESENTING TOOL BILLS IN A
SEPARATE COMMITTEE SO LET US.
TAKE CARE OF THE BILLS THAT WE
HEARD AS A SUBCOMMITTEE. AND OUT
FOLLOWING THOSE WHO ARE HURT
WITHOUT. EMOTION.
WE DO WE STILL HAVE SEVERAL
BILLS TO PRESENT BUT BEFORE WE
GET TO THOSE BILLS MEMBER BILLS.
I LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY ONE.
THE BILL'S MEMBERS AT THIS IS A
STEINORTH GOES INSECT OF.
MOVED AND SECONDED THE ROLL
CALL PLEASE.
AB SAM
ANYONE.
APPROPRIATIONS
SHALL DIE AYE KILEY.
I BAKER.
I BERMAN.
CALDERON.
IRWIN.
I MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE. I AM REYES.
TEN.
THAT BILLS ON CALL FIVE VOTES
NECKS BILL THAT WE HEARD AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE WAS ITEM FIVE.
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY TWO THAT'S.
LEVINE.
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY TWO TO HAVE
A MOTION HOW.
HARRY.
WE DO NOT A MOTION GET.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ONE
OUR ITEM NUMBER EIGHT TWO TWO
TWO FIVE.
THAT'S A LOW MOAN. REGARDING
STATE GOVERNMENTS DURING A
RECORDING OF.
ELECTRONIC MEDIA THIS WHEN ON
CLOUGH. A STORAGE AREA DO I HAVE
A MOTION ON TWENTY TO TWENTY
FIVE.
BILLS AND MOVED SECONDED.
A LOCAL POLICE.
AB TWENTY TO TWENTY FIVE.
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
JUMPED HIGH AYE KILEY.
I BAKER.
I BERMAN.
CALDERON.
IRWIN I.
MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE I REYES T..
DODD THOUGH HAS FIVE VOTES.
ON CALL.
NEXT BILL WE HAVE ITEM TEN
THAT'S.
TWENTY FOUR OLD TO THAT SO LOW.
ON CANNABIS PERSONAL
INFORMATION.
DO I HAVE A MOTION.
FOR TWENTY FOUR OH TO.
THE DOES MOVED TO HAVE A SECOND.
SECOND IT THERE PLEASE CALL
ROLL.
AB TWENTY FOUR O. TO IS THE DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SHALL I MY KILEY. NOT VOTING.
BAKER. AYE BERMAN.
CALDERON.
IRWIN.
I. MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE. I REYES.
TING.
THAT WAS FOUR ZERO SO FAR THAT
BILL IS ON CALL AND FINALLY WE
HOW. THE B. THIRTY TEN THEN
THAT'S A LOW MOAN BILL ON
CALIFORNIA DEFERRED DEPOSIT
TRANSACTION LAW.
AS THE PAYDAY LOAN ONE.
ITEM EIGHTEEN. DO I HAVE A
MOTION FOR THE B. THIRTY TEN.
THOSE BEEN MOVED TO HAVE A
SECOND.
NOT YET SO WE'LL COME BACK TO
THIS.
SO.
NOW LET'S GO TO OUR MEMBERS I
BELIEVE WE HAVE OF.
QUITE A FEW BILLS LEFT ON THE
AGENDA.
AND I BELIEVE HER.
MISS IRWIN IN MISTER OBERNOLTE
BOTH HAVE A BILL AND OUT AND
SEE.
MISERABLE NINETY. WANT TO GO
FIRST WITH THE ONE.
WE CHOSE WAS GUITAR MIGHT.
MISS IRWIN WHICH LIKE GOPHERS
SO WHAT YOU WANT TO GO NEXT
LOCAL LAST.
OKAY THATCHERISM.
AND THAT IS ITEM.
.
NUMBER ELEVEN THAT'S TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY SIX
ON CHARITABLE ORGANIZATION.
CROWDFUNDING.
SO.
ANYTIME YOU'RE READY YOU MAY I
SEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS A. B. TWO FIVE FIVE
SIX IS A BILL THAT WILL
MODERNIZE OUR STATE LAWS
REGARDING CHARITABLE GIVING.
TODAY CHARITABLE FUNDRAISING IS
DRASTICALLY DIFFERENT THAN IT
WAS TEN YEARS AGO. NOW IT'S
COMMONPLACE HAVE CHARITY DRIVES
DONE COMPLETELY ONLINE CROWD
FUNDING FOR CHARITABLE GIVING IS
BECOMING THE NORM.
AND OUR LAWS HAVE NOT KEPT UP
WITH THESE. TRENDS AB TWO FIVE
FIVE SIX WILL UPDATE
CALIFORNIA'S CHARITABLE GIVING
LAWS TO ENSURE THAT ONLINE
GIVING PLATFORMS ARE OPERATING
WITHIN THE INTENT OF THE LAW.
AND THAT DONORS AND CHARITIES
ARE PROTECTED.
I APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
WORKING WITH ME ON THE
AMENDMENTS AND I WILL COMMIT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THE AG'S
OFFICE WHICH HAS BEEN PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND TODAY
HAVE A. REPRESENTATIVE FROM
PAYPAL TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF
THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME IN
THE YOU MAY. PROCEED.
I'M OCT AYE DAUGHTER MUCH IS
SENIOR DIRECTOR OF PAYPAL AND
PRODUCT MANAGEMENT.
I ALSO SERVE AS OUR HEAD OF
GLOBAL BECAUSE RELATED PRODUCTS.
ON BEHALF OF PAY PAL AND PAY PAL
CHARITABLE GIVING FUND SHALL
CALL PPG F. I'M HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
FIVE FIVE SIX. PVDF IS ITSELF A
FIVE ONE C. THREE CHARITY AND A
SEPARATE LEGAL ENTITY FROM
PAYPAL.
JEFF PARTNERS WITH PAYPAL TO
OFFER A CHARITABLE GIVING
PROGRAM WHERE DONORS CAN BROWSE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF CHARITIES
AND PAYPAL'S ONLINE CAUSE HUB.
DONATIONS TO THE CAUSE OF ARE
MADE TO PPG F. WHICH IS ISSUES A
TAXI TO THE DONOR.
WHEN A DONOR MAKES A DONATION
HERE SHE CHOOSES A CHARITY FOR
PEOPLE YOU HAVE TO READ GRANT
THE FUNDS TO.
RIGHT NOW.
DONORS CAN ONLY CHOOSE FROM
THOUSANDS OF CHARITIES THAT ARE
ENROLLED PPG HALF.
PEOPLE JEFF LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
OFFER DONORS THE OPTION TO
SUPPORT NOT JUST ENROLLED
CHARITIES IN THE CAUSE OF BUT
VIRTUALLY ANY CHARITY THAT IS IN
GOOD STANDINGWITH THE IRS
ANOTHER REGULATORS.
PAYPAL COVERS ALL TRANSACTION
FEES IN THE CAUSE OF TO ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT OF DONORS
DONATION GOES TO THE RECOMMENDED
CHARITY.
PAYPAL ALSO OFFERS PROMOTIONS
DURING CERTAIN TIMES OF THE YEAR
WHERE CONTRIBUTES AN ADDITIONAL
MATCHING PERCENTAGE THE DONATION
TO CHARITY.
LAST YEAR THROUGH THE BECAUSE
HARDEN PPG UPS OTHER BUSINESS
PARTNERS PDGF RAISED. OVER A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR OVER
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF CHARITIES.
INTERNET ENABLED TITLE GIVEN IS
A GROWING PART OF THE CHARITABLE
SECTOR DONORS VALUE THE
CONVENIENCE OF AN ONLINE BASED
PLATFORM AND WE WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CHOOSE FROM A
BROAD ARRAY OF CHARITIES.
WHILE CHARITABLE GIVING WAS
ALMOST FLAT OVERALL FROM JANUARY
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN.
GIVING VIA INTERNET PLATFORMS IS
UP THIRTEEN PERCENT OVER THE
SAME TIME PERIOD.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FIVE FIVE SIX
CREATES AN IMPORTANT EXEMPTION
FOR ONLINE CHARITABLE GIVING
PLATFORMS LIKE PPG OFF ALLOWING
THEM. WHEN A NUMBER OF
CONDITIONS ARE SATISFIED TO
OFFER POTENTIAL DONORS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DONATE TO
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
ADDITIONAL CHARITIES THAT HAVE
NOT YET ENROLLED CHARITABLE
GIVING PLATFORM.
IN OUR EXPERIENCE WHEN DONORS
CAN CONNECT TO A GREATER RANGE
OF CHARITIES THEY'RE BOTH MORE
LIKELY TO GIVE AND GIVE MORE
GENEROUSLY.
UNDER THE CURRENT LAW.
THE PRIOR WRITTEN CONSENT OF A
CHARITY AS NECESSARY TO INCLUDE
ANY CHARITY IN THE ONLINE
DATABASE IS A POTENTIAL
RECIPIENT OF A DONATION.
PVDF WOULD THEREFORE HAVE TO
OBTAIN HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
WRITTEN CONSENTS TO LIST
ADDITIONAL CHARITIES ON THE COST
OF INCLUDING FROM CHARITIES THAT
MIGHT BE LESS IN THE DATABASE
BUT NEVER BE SELECTED FOR A
DONATION.
WHO WERE EXPAND THE OPTIONS
BEYOND THE EMERALD CHARITIES?
THIS BILL WOULD ELIMINATE THE
WRITTEN CONSENT REQUIREMENT
PLATFORM MEET CERTAIN CONDITIONS
THEREBY VASTLY EXPANDING NUMBER
OF CHARITIES THAT RECEIVED
DONATIONS.
THE BILL CONTAINS IMPORTANT
PROTECTIONS FOR BOTH DONORS AND
RECIPIENT CHARITIES.
OR CHARITIES ONLINE PLATFORMS
ONLY BE ABLE TO LIST OTHERWISE
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE INFORMATION
ABOUT A CHARITY AND MUST PROVIDE
A MECHANISM FOR PROMPT REMOVAL
FROM PLATFORM TO CHARITIES
REQUEST.
THESE PLATFORMS MUST ALSO
PROVIDE DONATIONS WITHIN A
SPECIFIED TIME PERIOD TO
BENEFITING CHARITIES.
ALONG WITH AN ACCOUNTING OF ANY
FEES IMPOSED.
FOR DONORS THE BILL REQUIRES
THESE ONLINE PLATFORMS RIGHT
IMPORTANT VETTING FUNCTION BY
LISTING ONLY CHARITIES IN GOOD
STANDING WITH THE IRS AND
CALIFORNIA REGULATORS. AND
SAFEGUARDS DONORS PERSONAL
INFORMATION BY SEVEN
RESTRICTIONS ON WHEN AND HOW
DONOR DATA CAN BE SHARED WITH
BENEFITING CHARITIES.
THE BILL ALSO SETS FORTH A
NUMBER OF REQUIRED DISCLOSURES
THAT PLATFORMS MUST MAKE QUALIFY
FOR THE EXEMPTION.
THERE ARE WELL OVER A HUNDRED.
EXCUSE ME THERE WELL OVER A
MILLION CHARITIES IN GOOD
STANDING WITH THE IRS AND THE
BILL'S EXEMPTION PROVIDES A
PRACTICAL METHOD. ENABLING
CERTAIN QUALIFYING PLATFORMS TO
LIST A WIDE ARRAY OF CHARITIES
WITHOUT A TIE OBTAINING PRIOR
WRITTEN CONSENT FROM EACH.
THIS PROVISION WILL UNDOUBTEDLY
INCREASE DONOR CHOICE IN OVERALL
TITLE GIVING WHILE PROTECTING
CHARITIES AND DONORS FROM ABUSE.
DISASTER RELIEF IS ONE TANGIBLE
EXAMPLE OF WHERE THE ABILITY TO
LIST CHARITIES WITHOUT OBTAINING
PRIOR WRITTEN CONSENT IS
CRITICAL.
SMALLER LOCAL CHARITIES THAT
COULD BENEFIT FROM DONATIONS
JOINT DISASTERS TYPICALLY HAVE
NOT PREVIOUSLY PROVIDED CONSENT
TO A PLATFORM.
THE BILL WOULD ALLOW US ANOTHER
PLATFORM TO ROUTE DONATIONS TO
SUCH CHARITIES QUICKLY AND
WITHOUT GETTING CONSENT FROM
THEM AT TIMES WHEN THEY ARE
ENGAGED IN THEIR IMPORTANT WORK.
I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MANY MEMBERS GREG HAZEM HAPPENED
TECHNET AND SUPPORT A VERY MUCH
A NICE PLACE.
GIVEN THE KILLINGS INTERNET
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU OPPOSITION PLEASE COME
ON UP.
WELCOME CAN OFTEN CHAIR MEMBERS
BLACK SHEPHERD REPRESENTING THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
FOUNDATIONS WE ARE A TRADE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING. THIRTY
TWO COMMUNITY FOUNDATION MEMBERS
ACROSS THE STATE OUR POSITION
CURRENTLY IS CONCERNED WE HAVE A
DETAILED LETTER THAT WE
SUBMITTED TO THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE.
WE WENT I THINK IS A MEMBER
IRWIN FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS
ISSUE YOU KNOW THIS IS
IMPORTANT.
I'M GOING TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR IN THE SPONSOR
OF THE BILL AND ULTIMATELY OUR
GOAL IS TO ENSURE THAT THAT
DONOR.
THAT DONOR INTENT IS HONORED
AND THAT GIVING PRACTICES ADHERE
TO THE HIGHEST ETHICAL STANDARDS
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AN EX WHEN HIS PLACE. AYE
AYE GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS JENNIFER FEARING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NONPROFITS WHERE
I STATEWIDE POLICY ALLIANCE. OF
MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE VOICE OF
CALIFORNIA'S NONPROFIT COMMUNITY
AND SOME ARE AT TO MY COLLEAGUES
ARE ARE LETTER THAT WE SUBMITTED
IS. A ALSO ONE JUST EXPRESSING
CONCERN WE APPRECIATE THE
OUTREACH THAT PAYPAL AND IS A
MEMBER IRWIN HAVE DONE TO
INCLUDE US IN THE DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT THIS BILL BUT. AS
ARTICULATED IN THE LETTER WE
HAVE ONGOING CONCERNS THE
BIGGEST ONE OF WHICH SIMILAR TO
MR BIRD IS AT RELATES TO
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE DONATIONS
DIRECTED BY A DONOR TO A
PARTICULAR NONPROFIT USING THE
CROWDFUNDING PLATFORM. ARE
DETERMINED BY THE PADS ON ARE
NOT TO BE TRANSFERABLE FROM ONE
REASON RATHER TO THAT. NONPROFIT
THE FREE MARKET IN THE BILL
CURRENTLY PROPOSES THAT
CONSPICUOUS JUST COST DISCLOSURE
TO THE DONOR THAT THE NONPROFIT
MIGHT NOT RECEIVE THE
CONTRIBUTION IS ADEQUATE. BUT
COME ON PROFITS RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREES WITH THAT WE BELIEVE
IT ANYONE SOLICITING FUNDS FOR A
CHARITABLE ORGANIZATION SHOULD
BE COMMITTED TO PROCESSES THAT
ENSURE THE DONORS DESIGNATIONS
ARE PRIORITIZE. AND OR THE
DONORS ARE GIVEN OPTIONS IF
THEIR DONATION CAN'T BE
COMPLETED FOR SOME REASON AND
PAYPAL HAS CONVEYED IN OUR
CONVERSATIONS THAT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE INFREQUENT. SO
IT SEEMS POSSIBLE AND NOT OVERLY
BURDENSOME TO DEVELOP A PROCESS
THAT DOESN'T ALLOW CROWD FUNDERS
TO INDEPENDENTLY CHOOSE
ALTERNATIVE CHARITIES WITHOUT
THE DONORS AND PUT. OUR OUR TO
OTHER CONCERNS RELATE TO HOW
LONG IT WOULD TAKE THE
CROWDFUNDING PLATFORM TO
TRANSFER THE FUNDS FROM THE
DONOR ON TO THE ORGANIZATION.
AND THE NEED FOR A CLEARER
DEFINITION OF OF CROWDFUNDING
SOLICITOR FOR CHARITABLE PURPOSE
THAT IN PARTICULAR IDENTIFIES
WHETHER DONOR ADVISED FUNDS OR
GIVING CIRCLES. JUST AS EXAMPLES
WOULD BE CONSIDERED AS CROWDFUND
ARE SUBJECT TO THE PROVISIONS SO
WE DEFINITELY AGREE THAT
CALIFORNIA LAW HASN'T KEPT PACE
WITH OPPORTUNITIES. FOR
CHARITABLE FUNDRAISING CREATED
BY CUT FUNDING COMPANIES BUT. WE
THINK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD PROCEED WITH CAUTION AND
CARE HERE TO ENSURE THAT A VERY
WIDE NET IS CAST WITH THE
PHILANTHROPIC AND NONPROFIT
SECTOR TO ENSURE THAT OPTIONS
HERE WEIGHED CAREFULLY. AND
ANALYZE TO SORT OF CUT DOWN ON
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES SO WE
HAVE WORKED WITH A SEMI
GOVERNMENT ON CHARITABLE
FUNDRAISING RELATED BILLS IN THE
PAST AND EXPECT TO STAY. AT THE
TABLE WITH HER THE SPONSORS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE AND
AND OTHERS AS A IF YOU CHOOSE TO
MOVE THIS BILL FORD SO THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES ARE.
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING NONE OF IT SO BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ON MISTER
OBERNOLTE HAS A QUESTION.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN I AM VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO WITH THE BILL I HAVE A
COUPLE OF CONCERNS THAT I WANTED
TO. MAKE YOU AWARE OF.
.
FIRST OF ALL I THINK THAT.
THAT LANGUAGE IN THE BILL NEED
SOME CLARIFICATION AND TO START
WITH I THINK. THAT YOU NEED TO
CLARIFY WHAT YOU MEAN WHEN YOU
SAY CHARITABLE PURPOSE.
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT DEFINED
ANYWHERE IN THE BILL AND.
IF YOU ARE REFERENCING WHERE
IT'S DEFINED IN DIFFERENT PEER
PART OF STATE CODE I THINK THAT
YOU ARE EXPLICITLY SAY TERRIBLE
PURPOSE AS DEFINED IN SECTION
BLAH BLAH BLAH BLAH. NOT OR IF
YOU WANT TO COME UP WITH YOUR
OWN DEFINITION I THINK YOU
SHOULD DO WITH THEIR THE SECTION
BUT I CERTAINLY SHOULDN'T DON'T
THINK THAT YOU SHOULD LEAVE IT
UP TO. INTERPRETATION WHAT
EXACTLY A CHARITABLE PURPOSE IS.
ARM AND IN A BROADER SENSE.
I'M CONCERNED THAT.
AND BECAUSE
THE ADVENT OF CROWDFUNDING LENDS
ITSELF TO. A MUCH MORE LOCAL AND
SMALL SCALE KIND OF TRANSACTION
BETWEEN.
DONORS AND CHARITABLE CAUSES
THAT WE MAKE SURE THAT AS WE TRY
TO PROTECT.
THAT RELATIONSHIP THAT WE DON'T
STIFLE THAT ACTIVITY AND I'LL
GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF THE KIND OF
THING THAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
SO IF I'M.
TRYING TO RAISE MONEY BECAUSE I
FIND OUT A FRIEND HAS CANCER AND
I KNOW THAT HE CAN'T SUPPORT HIS
FAMILY. DURING THIS TRYING TIME
SO ARE DOES THAT MAKE ME. A.
.
A CROWD FUNDING SOLICITOR
WILFRED SOLICITOR FOR CHARITABLE
PURPOSE.
MY PERHAPS I'M USING A PLATFORM
LIKE GO FUND ME OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT OR PERHAPS I'M DOING
IT ON MY OWN. BUT IT SURE SEEMS
LIKE THAT'S NOT A CIRCUMSTANCE
WHERE THE STATE HAS AN INTEREST
IN REQUIRING THAT PERSON TO
REGISTER WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
.
IN IN FILE AN ANNUAL REPORT IT
AND I HAVE ANOTHER CONCERN.
IF YOU ALONG THAT SAME LINE I
MEAN I REALIZE IT'S KIND OF A
WORST CASE SCENARIO BUT.
I MEAN LET'S SAY BECAUSE THAT
YOUR BILL SAYS THAT. THAT MAKES
ME A CONSTRUCTIVE TRUSTEE OF
THAT MONEY THAT I'M. GATHERING I
MEAN IF IT TURNS OUT THAT I WAS
MISLED MY FRED DOESN'T HAVE
CANCER ANY. USE MY MONEY TO GO
TAKE A VACATION TO THE CARIBBEAN
YOU KNOW DOES THAT MEAN THAT
THAT YOU KNOW I HAVE A.
A RESPONSIBILITY TO THE DONORS
OF THAT MONEY BECAUSE I
REPRESENTED THAT HE DID HAVE
CANCER I JUST THINK THAT WE NEED
SOME SOME LANGUAGE IN THERE TO.
TO PROTECT THAT KIND OF
SITUATION SO I WOULD LOVE TO
HEAR YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT THAT.
LET THE EXPERTS AT.
.
ADDRESS THOSE DETAILS BUT A LOT
OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ARE THE DETAILS OBVIOUSLY.
HAVING AN INDIVIDUAL DO THE
CROWD FUNDING FOR TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT THAT BELONGS IN THE
BILL ARE SHOULD BE EXEMPTED ALSO
SO. WE'RE WORKING WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS BILL DOES EXACTLY WHAT IT
IS.
INTENDED TO DO AND MAYBE YOU
CAN COMMENT ON THE SPECIFIC SURE
I WE WE SHARE THE SAME POINT OF
VIEW THAT EXACTLY AND THAT TYPE
OF SITUATION THAT. THIS BILL IS
NOT INTENDED TO MAKE THAT
INDIVIDUAL.
PURSUE S. REGISTERS SO ANY
CLARIFICATIONS THAT MAKE THAT
MORE CLEAR WE WERE ON THE SAME
PAGE WITH. OKAY GREAT ART Y.
JUST THINK IN GENERAL AMBIGUITY
IS SOMETHING WE TRY TO AVOID AND
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
KIND OF THE. SITUATION IS.
IT IS DOT STIFLED BECAUSE THE
THE WORST THING WE COULD
ACCOMPLISH IN TRYING TO PROTECT
THAT RELATIONSHIP. IS TO
DISCOURAGE THE KIND OF GIVING
THAT IS NOW OCCURRING WHERE
PEOPLE ARE GETTING MORE INVESTED
IN THE WELL BEING OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND THEIR QUINCES IN
THEIR AND THEIR FRIENDS. THAT
WHICH I THINK IS A VERY HEALTHY
THING FOR SOCIETY I WOULD HATE
TO PUT A DAMPER ON THAT BUT TO
THEM SO THAT A VERY SUPPORT OF
THE BILL HAPPY TO SPORTY TODAY.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR.
COMMENTS.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED TO HAVE
A SECOND AND SECOND IT.
.
IN OUR.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
I JUST WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THESE.
DETAILS WE WE DON'T WANT TO
LEAVE ANYTHING VEGAS ONE AND UP
WITH YOU KNOW AT THE END OF THE
PROCESS TO HAVE A BILL THAT'S
THAT DOESN'T HAVE ANY OF THESE
UNINTENDED COSTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CONSIDERING
THE FACT THAT THIS IS ONLY FOR
ITS COMMITTEE THE BILL IS GOING
THROUGH SO I WILL WITH
SUPPORTING IT IS ALSO WITH THAT
THE MAN SECRETARY LISA PROCOL
PLEASE.
AB TWO FIVE FIVE FIX
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
TELL AYE AYE KILEY. AYE BRITAIN
BAKER. AYE BERMAN. AYE CALDERON.
AYE IRWIN AYE AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE. I REYES.
I TING.
HERE BILL IS OUT I THINK IT'S
YOU HAVE SEVENTY EIGHT YEPI
VOTES I BELIEVE YOU HAVE A
SECOND BILL.
THAT IS.
.
ITEMS
SIXTEEN TWENTY THE.
EIGHTEEN.
THIRTEEN.
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTEEN THIRTEEN
THAT I THIRTEEN.
AND.
THIS WOULD CODIFY VERBATIM THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT
CREATED THE CAL.
CALIFORNIA CYBERSECURITY
INTEGRATION CENTER ANOTHER BILL.
THAT WAS OF.
THAT WERE ANOTHER BILL WAS UP
PROPOSED LAST YEAR BUT WAS
VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR AND THAT
AUTHOR IS GOING TO BE A WORKING
WITH ME ON THE BILL. OTHER
GOVERNORS OF MESSAGE NOTED THAT
CAL SEASICK NEEDED MORE TIME
FLEXIBILITY TO MATURE INTO ITS
MISSION.
AS CHAIR OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON CYBERSECURITY I RECENTLY HELD
A JOINT HEARING WITH CHAIR CHAO
AND THIS COMMITTEE.
AND WE HEARD HOW FAR CAL SEASICK
HAD COME ESPECIALLY IN THE LAST
SIX MONTHS SINCE THE GOVERNOR'S
VETO. THIS BILL IS INTENDED TO
GIVE THE GOVERNOR ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO EVALUATE HIS
VISION FOR KELSEY SICK BEFORE HE
LEAVES OFFICE. CYBERSECURITY
WILL UNFORTUNATELY BE A
CONTINUING THREAT FACTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA JUST AS MENACING AS
FIRES EARTHQUAKES AND FLOODS.
OUR STATE DESERVES A PERMANENT
RESPONSE CENTER TO MEET THE
THREAT AND AB TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTEEN CAN PROVIDE THAT
CERTAINTY TO CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH JOE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF A BILL.
CNN OPPOSITION.
CNN.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MR OBERNOLTE GUY AT THANK YOU
MISTER OBVIOUSLY VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THE BILL DISAPPOINTED THE
GOVERNOR VETOED MY BILL LAST
YEAR THAT WOULD HAVE DONE THE
SAME THING.
THE.
SO IF INDEED YOU DID NOT SUPPORT
THE BILL LAST YEAR VOTED AGAINST
IN THIS COMMITTEE ON THE FLOOR
AND I'M WONDERING WHY WHAT'S
CHANGES AT THE IS AT THE CAL
CIRCUS. HAS COME A LONG WAY
SINCE THEN AND IT CAL SICK HAS
COME A LONG WAY SINCE THEN AND
IT'S ALSO DISCUSSIONS WITH.
YES THEY DIDN'T THINK THEY WERE
FAR ENOUGH ALONG TO AND KIND OF
PUSH FOR A SOLUTION LIKE THIS.
AND WE THINK WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF
MATURITY IN THE LAST SIX MONTHS
TO A YEAR.
SO WHAT GIVES YOU CONFIDENCE
THAT THE GOVERNOR WILL FEEL
DIFFERENTLY ABOUT IT THIS YEAR
WELL MAYBE WITH BOTH OF US ON
THE BILL PEOPLE AND PRIVATE HAVE
SIGNED. OBVIOUSLY A VERY
SUPPORTIVE AND I WISH YOU MUCH
LUCK.
AS MUCH LIKE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I DO RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT.
OF MOST OF THE STRUCTURE HAS
BEEN IN PLACE.
AND OPERATING SMOOTHLY AND I'M
ALSO HOPEFUL THAT THE GOVERNOR
WAS SIGNED IT THIS TIME AROUND
AND MISTER OBERNOLTE IF YOU LIKE
TO BE A CO AUTHOR. LUCK WITH
THIS.
ACTUALLY I THINK I THINK FOR
WORKING OUT I'M HOPING TO WORK
OF BEING A JOINT AUTHORED BUT
WE'LL SEE OKAY VERY GOOD. WITH
THAT THE MEN OF SECRETARY
PLEASE.
WE SPOKE ABOUT.
AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTEEN TO PASS
TO GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION.
CHAO HIGH I KILEY. AYE BAKER.
AYE BERMAN. AYE CALDERON.
I IRWIN AYE AYE AYE MULAN.
OBERNOLTE AYE VARIOUS.
ON.
EIGHT THEY TO ZERO YOUR BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
THINK THAT'S THE U. TWO BILLS
AND MISTER OBERNOLTE I THINK YOU
HAVE A BILL.
THAT WOULD BE ITEM NUMBER NINE
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY FIVE ON
VOTER REGISTRATION DATABASE.
ANYTIME YOU'RE READY MAKE LIKE
MR CHAIRED A COLLEAGUES IN.
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN PRESIDENT
OBAMA. ESTABLISHED A
PRESIDENTIAL COMMISSION ON
ELECTIONS ADMINISTRATION TO
STUDY WAYS IN WHICH THE
ADMINISTRATION OF ELECTIONS IN
THE UNITED STATES COULD BE DONE
MORE EFFICIENTLY. AND IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE COMMISSION
RELEASED ITS REPORT AND ONE OF
THE PRIMARY RECOMMENDATIONS.
WAS THAT STATES
GOD COLLABORATE AND ESTABLISH A
WAY OF EXCHANGING VOTER
INFORMATION TO MAKE SURE THAT
VOTER ROLLS WERE ACCURATE.
SO.
IN RESPONSE TO THAT THE
ELECTRONIC REGISTRATION
INFORMATION CENTER OR AREA
BECAUSE IT'S CALLED WAS CREATED
TO TO FACILITATE. AND BE A DEPOT
FOR THIS EXCHANGE OF INFORMATION
AND IN THE YEARS SINCE THEN
TWENTY THREE STATES HAVE JOINED
ERIC. UNFORTUNATE CALIFORNIA IS
NOT YET ONE OF THEM SO THIS BILL
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY FIVE
WOULD AUTHORIZE NOT REQUIRED BUT
AUTHORIZES THE SECRETARY OF
STATE. TO JOIN CALIFORNIA TO.
ERIC I WANT TO. THANK THE.
PREVIOUS COMMITTEE FOR THE
ROBUST DISCUSSION IN ELECTIONS
ABOUT THIS BILL A ONE OF THE
PRIMARY CONCERNS THAT WAS
RAISED.
WAS THE SAFETY OF THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION OF CALIFORNIA VOTERS
AND IN THAT COMMITTEE I AGREED
TO TAKE AMENDMENTS AND DOUBLE TO
USE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT.
TO TAKE AMENDMENTS THAT.
THAT CLARIFY THE CIRCUMSTANCES
UNDER WHICH. THE SECRETARY OF
STATE MAY JOIN ERICA ON A READ
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
AGREEING TO A WE'RE GOING TO ADD
A SECTION DE THAT SAYS BEFORE
JOINING. THE ELECTRONIC
REGISTRATION OF FATE INFORMATION
CENTER THE SECRETARY OF STATE
SHALL REVIEW AND EVALUATE THE
ELECTRONIC REGISTRATION
INFORMATION CENTER SECURITY
PROCEDURES AND PROCESSES.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE MAY JOIN
THE ELECTRONIC REGISTRATION
INFORMATION CENTER ONLY AFTER
MAKING A DETERMINATION THAT IT
WILL ADEQUATELY PROTECT. ALL OF
CALIFORNIA VOTERS DATA SO I
AGREE WITH THAT THE COMMITTEE
THAT.
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT SO I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE THAT AMENDMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION.
AND AFTERNOON MY INGRAM WITH THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IRRESPECTIVE
PHILLY OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE
OF THE SIGNIFICANT PRIVACY
CONCERNS THAT ARE RAISED BY
JOINING ERIC.
THE PROVISION OF NON
WITHSTANDING ANY OTHER LAW MEANS
THAT THE SECRETARY OF STATE
WOULD BE SHARING THIS DATA WITH
ERIC DESPITE CALIFORNIA'S STRICT
PRIVACY STATUTES. THE PLACE
EXPLICIT PROHIBITIONS ON SHARING
THIS LANGUAGE
THAT MEANS CALIFORNIA CAN SHARE
WITHOUT THE INDIVIDUAL'S
KNOWLEDGE OR CONSENT SENSITIVE
VOTER FILE MOTOR VEHICLE AND
POTENTIALLY OTHER GOVERNMENT
DATA. THIS IS DIRECTLY COUNTER
TO THE VEHICLE CODE GOVERNMENT
CODE AND CIVIL CODE SECTIONS
THAT SAY THIS DATA WILL NOT BE
SHARED. IT ALSO CONFLICTS WITH
ARTICLE ONE SECTION ONE OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION WHICH
GUARANTEES THE RIGHT TO PRIVACY.
WE THINK THE PROPOSED PRIVACY
MMN IS INSUFFICIENT ERICA AS A
NON GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
CAN CHANGE ITS BYLAWS AT ANY
TIME. WITH JUSTIN MAHER VOTE OF
THE GOVERNING BOARD WHICH IS
MADE UP OF THE MEMBER STATES.
MOREOVER RECENT PROBLEMS WITH
ERIC HAVE SHOW THE FLAWS WITHIN
THE SYSTEM WHEN WISCONSIN JOINED
IT.
IT WAS IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
AND IN THE FEBRUARY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN PRIMARY. IN MILWAUKEE
ALONE APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED
RESIDENTS WHO HAD NOT MOVED HAD
NONE THE LESS HAD THEIR VOTER
REGISTRATIONS DEACTIVATED DUE TO
A FLAW IN THE PROCEDURE.
PROCESSING THROUGH ERIC ELECTED
OFFICIALS THINK THAT THEY'RE OUT
WALKING ABOUT THREE THOUSAND
VOTERS WERE AFFECTED BY THIS
FLAW. WE THINK THIS BILL IS
UNNECESSARY CALIFORNIA ALREADY
HAS SEVERAL VOTER REGISTRATION
PROCESS IN PLACE TO STREAMLINE
AND CLEAN UP THE REGISTRATION
PROCESS. WE'VE STREAMLINED VOTER
REGISTRATION AT THE DMV VOTERS
CAN AUTOMATICALLY UPDATE THEIR
DMB REGISTRATIONS IN OUR COUNTY.
AND THE DMV HAS ADAM AT IT I
ADDED AUTOMATIC VOTER
REGISTRATION WE ALSO ADDED VOTE
CAL IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WHICH
ALLOWS FOR BETTER SHARING
BETWEEN OUR FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
AND THIS WILL BE THE FIRST YEAR.
THAT SAME DAY REGISTRATION THAT
HAS GONE INTO A FACT WHICH
ALLOWS VOTERS TO CLEAN UP THEIR
REGISTRATION. THESE REFORMS TO
BE GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO PLAY
OUT RATHER THAN THIS APPROACH
WHICH SHARES ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S
VOTER DATA INTO A FLAWED SYSTEM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING NINE THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED INSECT MISTER CALDERON GO
AHEAD QUESTION BIG YOU.
AT SOMEONE MEMBER OBERNOLTE.
.
A BIT MAYBE YOU CAN ADDRESS
SOMETHING FOR ME I KNOW WITH
ERIC THE FIRST.
TWENTY STATES THAT JOIN THE
SYSTEM MORE ALLOWED.
A SEAT AT THE TABLE CALIFORNIA
BE ABOUT TWENTY FOUR SO WE
WOULDN'T. HAVE COME THIS
OVERRIDING VETO POWER
REPRESENTATION ON THAT BOARD.
AND SO MY CONCERN IS.
YOU YOU WHAT IS OUR LEGAL
RECOURSE IF WE TURN OVER OUR
INFORMATION.
AND.
GUILT FLORIDA WITH SOMEBODY
ELSE DECIDES.
SHARE OUR INFORMATION WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AT MY CONCERN
IS ALSO THE FACT THAT.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT RIGHT
NOW.
IS ACTING IN A WAY THAT I DON'T
AGREE WITH AND IS SPECIFICALLY
TARGETING.
YOU KNOW STATES LIKE OURS WHEN
IT COMES OR VOTER ROLLS I VOTED
FOR THE BILL IN ELECTIONS.
.
BECAUSE I DO AGREE THAT WE NEED
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO UPDATE.
ARE VOTER ROLLS AND MAKE SURE
THE INFORMATION IS IS AS
RELEVANT UP TO DATE IN AND CLEAN
BUT ALSO THE SAME TIME WHEN IT
WOULDN'T WHEN WE COME TO THIS
COMMITTEE WE'RE GETTING THESE
PRIVACY ISSUES. I'M JUST
CONCERNED WE DON'T HAVE. ANY
LEGAL RECOURSE TO PREVENT OUR
INFORMATION THAT WE WILLINGLY
TURN OVER.
WHETHER CHECK BY THE SECRETARY
OF STATE OR NOT.
TO BE SHARED WITHOUT OUR
CONSENT IN THAT WE WOULD HAVE NO
ABILITY TO CONTROL THAT ONCE A
DECISION HAD BEEN MADE.
I COMPLETELY RESPECT THAT
CONCERNED.
.
THE ERIC DECLARE IT IS A
COMPLETELY SEPARATE ORGANIZATION
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SO
IT IS NOT A FEDERAL ORGANIZATION
IS ORGAN ORGANIZATION. THAT IS
OWNED BY AND CONTROLLED BY THE
STATES THAT. MAKE UP THE
ORGANIZATION SO WE CALIFORNIA
SHOULD I JOIN WOULD BECOME A
MEMBER OF ERIC NOW YOU'RE
CORRECT THAT BECAUSE WE WERE NOT
ONE OF THE FIRST TWENTY STATES
WE MISSED THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
ON THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
AND UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS A
BILL WAS INTRODUCED LAST SESSION
THAT WOULD HAVE DONE THE SAME
AUTHORIZATION THAT WAS HELD IN
APPROPRIATIONS AND REALLY COST
US THAT OPPORTUNITY HOWEVER
HAVING SAID THAT. I AM ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT CERTAIN THAT
ERIC IS VERY MOTIVATED
INCENTIVIZED TO MAKE SURE THAT
STATES.
ESPECIALLY LARGE STATES LIKE
CALIFORNIA HAVE THEIR CONCERNS
MET.
AND.
SO I THINK THAT THEY WOULD
PROBABLY BEND OVER BACKWARDS TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
IF IF WE WERE UNHAPPY WITH THE
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS THAT THEY
HAVE ALREADY PUT IN PLACE WHICH
ARE EXTENSIVE. THAT SHOULD WE
IDENTIFY SOMETHING WE WOULD LIKE
THEM TO DO I AM VERY CONFIDENT
THAT THEY WOULD SERIOUSLY
CONSIDER DOING THAT DOWN IF THE
WORST. WERE TO COME TO PLAY TO
TO PASS IN THE SITUATION THAT
YOU'RE SEE UNFOLDS WHERE WE
DISAGREE. WITH SOME WAY THAT
THAT DATA IS BEING USED THEY ON
OUR I'M I'M SURE THE SECRETARY
OF STATE WOULD BE POLICE IN THAT
SITUATION AND BRING IT TO OUR
ATTENTION. THE AND WE WOULD
CORRECT IT AND IF NECESSARY
WITHDRAW FROM THE PARTNERSHIP.
SO MAYBE.
REALLY QUICK SUMMARY.
OTHER THAN YOUR OPENING
STATEMENT.
FOR THE CAKE FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHAT WOULD YOU
IDENTIFY AS THE SINGLE GREATEST.
BENEFIT TO JOINING THE SYSTEM
BUT TO ME THIS IS ABOUT CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT AND IF YOU READ THE
PRESIDENTIAL COMMISSIONS REPORT
THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA
COMMISSIONED ON THAT'S. THAT'S
ONE OF THE MAIN GOALS OF. OF
THEIR IN THEIR IMPROVEMENTS
SUGGEST IMPROVEMENTS THE AUTORE
PROCESS IS TO GET MORE PEOPLE
ENGAGED IN THE PROCESS OF
VOTING.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE
SELECT SUCH WOULD ALLOW US TO DO
THIS MEMBERSHIP. IS TO
PROACTIVELY REACH OUT TO PEOPLE
WHO HAVE MOVED HERE AND OFFER
THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO REGISTER
TO VOTE BECAUSE SOMETIMES THAT'S
ALL IT'S GOING TO TAKE. TO.
TO PUSH SOMEONE OVER THE EDGE
AND ACTUALLY ENGAGING IN THE
ELECTORAL PROCESS IN THE NEW
STATE THAT THEY'RE MOVING. SO IF
WE CAN ENGAGE THOSE PEOPLE TWO
OR THREE OR FOUR YEARS EARLIER
THAN WE NORMALLY WHAT I THINK
IT'S A HUGE WIN FOR US. AND
THAT'S IN ADDITION TO ALL THE
OTHER BENEFITS THEY'RE CLEANING
UP THE VOTER ROLLS WOULD HAVE.
I THINK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMING COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE.
.
I'M GONNA ASK YOU TO CLOSE BUT
THE BEFORE I DO THAT I I JUST
TELL I'M SKINNER SHARE WITH YOU
THAT I I DON'T FEEL VERY
COMFORTABLE GOING UP ON THIS AT.
THIS BILL.
.
FOR THE. WHEN THE BILL CAME UP
LAST TIME LAST YEAR I ALSO
STAYED OFF.
WASN'T CONCERNED ABOUT THE.
THE BILL ITSELF ARE AND AND OUR
A AND I THINK THERE ARE
ALTERNATIVE WAYS TO HANDLING
THIS AND. AND I THINK IT'S BEEN
MENTIONED THAT THE WISCONSIN
INCIDENT THAT THEY'RE INVOLVED
ON DOZENS OF DOZENS OF OUR
VOTERS WHO WHO SO INFORMATION
WAS PERCHED. SO ITS CONCERN
ABOUT THAT AND I WASN'T DIRECTLY
IN CONNECTION WITH THE SYSTEM
ERIC SO. SO ON YOU KNOW AND IT'S
BEEN ALSO MISSION THAT ABOUT THE
TO THE BOARD OF A BOARD OF
DIRECTORS.
THE POSSIBILITY THAT CALIFORNIA
MAY NOT BE AT THE TABLE SO THAT
ALSO CONCERNS ME SO I'M GONNA
ALSO SAY STAY OFFTHIS TIME. ON
BUT I'M THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED
AND SECONDED SO.
IF THERE ARE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS I'M GONNA
HOUSE AMEND SECRETARY TO DO
RECALL THAT MISTER CHAIR LOW ON
SECOND CLOSE. CLOSE BUT SO
SORRY.
ABSENT ONE THING I DID WANT TO
ADDRESS IN THE CLOTHES WAS TO.
TALK ABOUT THAT SITUATION THAT
OCCURRED IN WISCONSIN BECAUSE I
THINK THERE'S BEEN A
MISPERCEPTION THAT THAT WAS
BECAUSE OF ERIC'S INVOLVEMENT
AND ALTHOUGH THOSE VOTERS WERE
IDENTIFIED.
THROUGH THE PARTNERSHIP WITH
ERIC IT WAS THE STATE OF
WISCONSIN WHO ELECTED TO SEND
OUT A POSTCARD TO ALL THOSE
VOTERS THAT SAID. PLEASE LET US
KNOW THAT YOU'RE REALLY HERE OR
YOU'LL BE REMOVED AND THE PEOPLE
THAT DIDN'T RETURN THE CARD WERE
REMOVED FROM THE DATABASE THAT
WAS A THAT ACTION THAT
WISCONSIN.
ELECTED TO TAKE AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WOULD NOT OCCUR
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND ABSENT
THAT ACTION BY WISCONSIN THERE
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN THEIR
PROBLEM WITH THOSE VOTERS SO IS
ONE TO BE CLEAR ABOUT THAT I
MEAN ERIC. IS JUST A PURVEYOR OF
INFORMATION WHAT WE DO WITH THE
INFORMATION IS UP TO US
NOT UP TO THEM.
I AND THE OTHER POINT I WANTED
TO MAKE IS I REALLY THIS COMES
DOWN TO A QUESTION OF. WHETHER
OR NOT YOU AGREE WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION OF PRESIDENT
OBAMA'S COMMISSION IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN BECAUSE ONE OF
OUR PRIMARY FINDINGS WAS THAT
THE ELECTIONS PROCESS WOULD BE
ENHANCED BY STATES GETTING
TOGETHER. AND SHARING THIS THIS
INFORMATION WITH EACH OTHER
BECAUSE IF YOU AGREE WITH THAT.
THEN YOU OUGHT TO VOTE FOR THIS
BILL AND LET'S WORK TOGETHER IN
MAKING SURE THAT THE PRIVACY OF
THAT DATA IS PROTECTED I COMMIT.
THE SHOULD THIS BILL WILL MOVE
FORWARD I WILL WORK WITH ANYONE
THAT HAS CONCERNS ABOUT PUTTING
APPROPRIATE PRIVACY RESTRICT
RESTRICTIONS IN THE BILL BECAUSE
I'M HONOR PERCENT CONFIDENT
THAT.
ERIC WILL.
IF IF THOSE PROTECTIONS ALREADY
IN PLACE AREN'T ALREADY IN PLACE
WILL WORK WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE COMFORTABLE ME IF YOU DON'T
AGREE WITH THE COMMISSION. THAT
ABSOLUTELY YOU SHOULD VOTE NOR
LAYOFF IF YOU AGREE WITH THE
COMMISSION. PLEASE VOTE GAS DOWN
I WILL COMMIT TO WORKING WITH
YOU TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ADDRESS
THOSE PRIVACY CONCERNS SO WITH
THAT I WAS WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. BY AS A
BILL MOVE WOULD MOVE FORWARD TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND PROBABLY ON
SUSPENSE AGAIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I THINK IT.
A MAN SECRETARY RECALL PLEASE.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
CHAO NONVOTING NOT VOTING.
HIGHLY I'VE AYE BAKER.
I BERMAN. AYE CALDERON.
IRWIN.
MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE BY AYE REYES.
TING.
FOR. YOUR BILL ISN'T ALL LEGAL
VOTES THANK YOU.
AS WE'RE WAITING FOR MR COOPER
TO CHINA'S.
I DO HAVE SEVERAL BILLS THAT
I'D LIKE TO PRESENT SO AT THIS
TIME I TO TURN THE GALA OVER TO
MY VICE CHAIR MISGUIDED.
THE FILE ORDER YEAH.
THANK.
BUT I DO WHILE OTHERS.
GENNARO.
THAT'S A BIG.
GOV ALRIGHT WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH.
ITEM TO THAT IS E. V. EIGHTEEN
FIFTY NINE.
ALRIGHT.
HOLY ES SAYS WITNESSES AND THE
KING A.
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
FITS ALL I WILL ACCEPT AS
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS. OF THE
AMENDMENTS LISTED ON PAGES FIVE
AND SIX ANY OF THE ANNOUNCES
THAT THE AMENDMENTS WILL
ESSENTIALLY DO THE FOLLOWING
NUMBER ONE. REQUIRE CCR IS TO
BEGIN TO IMPLEMENT A SOFTWARE
UPDATE WITHIN THREE DAYS OF
BECOMING AWARE OF THE
VULNERABILITY. AND REQUIRE FULL
INSTALLATION OF A SOFTWARE
UPDATE WITHIN THIRTY DAYS OUT AS
OPPOSED TO TEN DAYS CURRENTLY IN
THE BILL.
OUR SECOND IT WILL REQUIRE THE
USE OF A MITIGATION MEASURES TO
A DECREASE THAT RISK OF A BREACH
AND NUMBER THREE EMPLOYMENT
TECHNICAL CHANGES.
THE BILL A. B. EIGHTEEN FIFTY
NINE WILL REQUIRE CONSUMER
CREDIT REPORTING AGENCY CCR RACE
TO PATCH VULNERABLE COMPUTER
SYSTEMS OR BE SUBJECT SUBJECT TO
CIVIL OUR PENALTIES AWARDED TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO STATE I WAS
COMPROMISED.
I'M THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN EQUIFAX
DATA BREACH RESULTED IN THE LOSS
OF ABOUT HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN
POINT NINE MILLION U. S.
CONSUMERS UP PERSONAL
INFORMATION. PRIOR TO THE BREACH
THE UNITED STATES A DEPARTMENT
OF HOMELAND SECURITY NOTIFY
EQUIFAX AND OTHER COMPANIES ON
MARCH TO EIGHT TWENTY SEVENTEEN
OF THE NEED TO PATCH SECURITY
VULNERABILITIES IN SOFTWARE.
CALL APACHE STROKES.
ARE A PERFECT SEND A
NOTIFICATION TO INTERNAL STAFF
REQUESTING A FIXED TWO D. OUT OF
HONOR ABILITY.
HOWEVER DOT PATCH NEVER OCCUR.
ALL CONSEQUENTLY BETWEEN ME
THIRTEEN AND JULY THIRTY TWENTY
SEVENTEEN HACKERS ARE EXPLOITED
ALTHOUGH VULNERABILITY TO ACCESS
SENSITIVE. PERSONAL INFORMATION
INCLUDING CONSUMER NAMES ALSO
SECURITY NUMBERS UP BIRTHDATES
ADDRESSES AND IN SOME INSTANCES
THE DRIVER'S LICENSE.
AND ALSO CREDIT CARD NUMBERS
THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE A C. C.
R. A. CONDUCTING BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA. TO BEGIN TO
IMPLEMENT. THE DO THE Q. WHAT IS
EMPLOYMENT ARM TO BEGIN
EMPLOYMENT A PATCH OF ITS
COMPUTER SYSTEM WITHIN THREE
DAYS. AND THEN COMPLETE THE
INSTALLATION WITHIN THE MOST
EXPEDIENT TIME POSSIBLE WHICH IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE INDUSTRY
PRACTICE BEST PRACTICES BUT NO
LONGER THAN THIRTY DAYS IN ANY
OUR CASE.
IF IT IS SO SUBJECT TO A
VULNERABILITY DOT COULD
COMPROMISE THE SECURITY OF OUR
COMPUTERIZED DATA CONTAINING
PERSONAL INFORMATION. ALL IF A
CCR A FAILED TO PATCH TO SYSTEM
AND A DATA BREACH OCCURS THE
BILL WOULD ALLOW A RESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA. OF WHOSE INFORMATION
WAS COMPROMISED TO BRING A CIVIL
ACTION TO RECOVER DAMAGES FOR
HIS OR HER DAMAGES TO. POSSIBLE
BET PENALTIES AND.
RECENTLY A REASONABLE ATTORNEYS
FEES AND COSTS SO WE GOT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IDOL.
FIRST WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL KAUNDA
KAISER ON BEHALF OF THE PRIVACY
RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE.
PEARCY IS A SIGN SAN DIEGO BASED
NONPROFIT CONSUMER EDUCATION AND
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION WHOSE
MISSION IS TO ENGAGE EDUCATE AND
EMPOWER CONSUMERS. TO PROTECT
THEIR PRIVACY.
WE APPLAUD ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHARLES AUTHORSHIP OFAB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE AND AGREE
THAT ANY CRA CONDUCTING BUSINESS
IN CALIFORNIA MOST
EXPEDITIOUSLY.
WORK TO ENSURE THE SECURITY OF
PERSONAL INFORMATION.
OF CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS AND WE
ARE VERY PLEASED WITH THE
AMENDMENTS I'M CHANGE FROM THE
TEN DAYS TO THREE DAYS.
.
AGAIN AS THE AUTHOR SAID AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHILD SAID WITH
THE EQUIFAX AND BREACH WE WE
THINK THAT THIS IS A TIMELY BILL
ME OR DRIVE VOTE THANK YOU.
NEXT ONE US.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MISTER VICE CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RAINY PARK AND WE HAVE
THE CONSUMER DATA INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION.
I FIRST WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
CHAIR THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANT
AND THE CHAIR STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US TO TRY TO RESOLVE SOME
OF OUR CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL.
WE UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
ADDRESSING POTENTIAL SECURITY
VULNERABILITIES IN THE SYSTEM.
WE BELIEVE THAT EACH SECURITY
VULNERABILITY HAS TO BE ASSESSED
INDIVIDUALLY TO DETERMINE ITS
RISK.
INDUSTRY BEST PRACTICES SUGGEST
THAT YOU IMPLEMENT BASED ON
RISK.
THIS LANGUAGE SUGGESTED YOU
TREAT EVERY SECURITY
VULNERABILITY AS EQUAL AND MUST
BE INSTALLED WITHIN THIRTY DAYS.
REQUIRE PATCH TO BE INSTALLED
WITH A THIRTY DAY LIMIT MAY NOT
BE THE APPROPRIATE WAY TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE.
FOR EXAMPLE WHAT IF WE FIND OUT
THAT A PATCHES THE STABILITY
PROBLEMS IN A NEW PATCH IS NOT
READY AT THE TIME ARE WE STILL
OBLIGATED TO INSTALL THAT PATCH
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS.
SPECIFICALLY TO DEMAND ON PAGE
FIVE OF THE ANALYSIS IT STATES
THAT THE COMPANY SHALL BEGIN TO
IMPLEMENT THE PATCH.
BUT WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THAT PHRASE BUT WE PREVENT PLAN
EMPLOYMENT HAS TO BE FURTHER
DEFINED WE BELIEVE IT SHOULD BE
DEFINED AS IT MEANS TO ASSESS.
PLAN AND TEST
AS THAT IS A PROCESS THAT TAKES
PLACE BEFORE PATCH CAN BE
INSTALLED.
FINALLY WE OPPOSE A PRIVATE
ACTION PART OF THE BILL AS WE
BELIEVE THIS WOULD LEAD TO
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS. WITH THAT WE
CONTINUE TO TRY TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND HOPE WE'LL HAVE SOME
SUCCESS THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SUSAN LAUGHED AT TOUGH FOR THE
CIVIL JUSTICE CESSATION IN
OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
BAKER THANK YOU I'M TO AND TO
THE FIRST ONE IS.
THE.
THE REQUIREMENTS.
THAT THIS BE WITHIN A CERTAIN
TIME PERIOD AND IT'S A SOFTWARE
UPDATE. IS A LITTLE BIT STANDS
OUT FOR ME BECAUSE SOMETIMES IN
THE AREA BILL LAW WHETHER IT'S
NOT ENTIRELY PRECISE WHAT WOULD
BE THE MOST REASONABLE THING TO
DO. IS INSTEAD OF A STANDARD
BEING THAT YOU HAVE TO.
DO YOU ACCESS AND IT NEEDS TO BE
PRECISELY THIS PRESCRIPTIVE
MEASURE IS YOU NEED TO DO
WHATEVER IS THE STANDARD.
THE MOST REASONABLE IT'S A
REASONABLE PERSON STANDARD SIR
MOST REASONABLE DECISION YOU
HAVE OR SOMETHING IS INDUSTRY
STANDARD Y. HAVE SOMETHING TO
SPECIFIC IS IT HAS TO BE A
SOFTWARE UPDATE AS OPPOSED TO.
THE MOST REASONABLE STANDARD AND
THE MOST REASONABLE RESPONSE
WITHIN THE INDUSTRY THE BEST
PRACTICES.
CAN YOU ANSWER THAT ONE FIRST.
SURE THE THE REASON WHY WE
INSERTED A DAY IN THE IN THE
LANGUAGES.
ARE BASICALLY TO.
.
ARE REQUIRED THE CCR IS TO BEGIN
THE PROCESS FIRST OF ALL WITH
RESPECT TO THE THREE DAY. SO WE
WANT TO FOCUS ALL FOCUS ON THE
VULNERABILITIES THAT WOULD.
CAUSE ANY SECURITY ISSUES NUMBER
ONE. AND I WE THINK THAT
INSERTING A THREE THEY ARE START
TIME IS GOING TO AT LEAST YOU
KNOW OUR REQUIRED THESE. TCR
RACE WHICH DEAL WITH VERY
IMPORTANT. CONSUMER INFORMATION
TO START THE BALL ROLLING. OUGHT
NOW ARE YOU KNOW AS WE HEARD IN
FACT. MANY OF THE AT THE
CONGRESSIONAL HEARING REGARDING
EQUIFAX THERE WAS TESTIMONY THAT
THEY COULD DO IT IN TWO DAYS.
ARE SO THIS IS YOU KNOW THAT THE
TH TENDER THREE DAY AND THREE
DAY PERIOD.
WAS A RESULT OF A DIFFERENT
YEAH YOU KNOW DIFFERENT
TESTIMONIES AND AND AND RESEARCH
AND BEST PRACTICE. SO SO TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION DIRECTLY
YOU KNOW IF WE JUST LEFT IT UP
LEFT NO THEY IN THERE THEN
THERE'S NO INCENTIVE TO DO THAT.
I MEAN IT'S IT'S MY. POOR ASKING
THE QUESTION I ASK MYSELF SO I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT ONE I READ.
WE TRY AND THAT IS AND LESS
CONCERNED ABOUT THE DATE.
IT'S MORE THAT IT IS
SPECIFICALLY A SOFTWARE UPDATE
THAT YOU'RE SAYING IS THE
PRESCRIPTION FOR DEALING WITH IT
WHENEVER. I'M OUT OF TIME AS
OPPOSED TO. A RESPONSE THAT IS
EITHER INDUSTRY STANDARD OR BEST
PRACTICES OR WHAT WOULD BE A
REASONABLE PERSON'S
DETERMINATION WHAT'S THE BEST
WAY TO RESPOND IT GIVES THE
INDUSTRY OR WHATEVER ISSUES MAY
BE. THE FLEXIBILITY TO DO WHAT
IS PASSED AND IT MAY NOT BE A
SOFTWARE UPDATED AB THAT'S ONE
OF THE POINTS HAVE BEEN RAISED
BY THE OPPOSITION IT IT MAY BE
ANOTHER MATTER. THAT WE SHOULD
NOT BE SO DETAILED AND.
I THAT'S WHAT I'M WONDERING WHY
YOU DIDN'T USE THAT STANDARD
THAT'S FAIRLY PREVALENT IN THE
LAW. AND IS ONE THAT ALLOWS THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT IS FLUID AND
ISN'T SO RIGID IS TO HAVE
SOFTWARE UPDATE MUST BE DONE
THIS WAY.
BOB YEAH IN FACT THE BEST
PRACTICE LANGUAGE IS PART OF THE
LANGUAGE AS WELL.
UP SO YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT
IGNORING WHAT THE INDUSTRY DOES.
SO SIMPLY SAYING THAT HE LOOK.
DO THIS THING WITHIN THE.
THE PURVIEW OF THE BEST
PRACTICE OF THE INDUSTRY BUT
START THE PROCESS SO YOU KNOW
WITHIN THREE DAYS OF OF A
NOTIFICATION GIVE IT IS THE
THING THAT THEY'RE BEING TOLD TO
DO IS TO.
USE A SOFTWARE UPDATE.
WE ARE SORRY WHEN I'M THAT'S IS
SO IS THE THING THAT THEY'RE
BEING ASKED TO DO THOSE TO BE A
SOFTWARE UPDATE AS OPPOSED TO. A
OKAY.
CORRECT AM RIGHT AND AND WE ALSO
ARE UNDER THE AMENDMENTS WERE
ALSO ASKING THE TO COMPANY TO.
ARE START THE.
MITIGATION ARE A PROCESS ALSO
TO YOU WE DON'T WANT IT WE DON'T
WANT TO CREATE A PATCH THAT
WOULD.
EXACERBATE THE SITUATION FIRST
OF ALL OUGHT TO THE IDEA IS TO
START THE BALL ROLLING BUT YET
AT THE SAME TIME IMPLEMENT SOME
KIND OF MITIGATION MEASURES TO
REDUCE YOU KNOW THE POTENTIAL.
OF HAVING A YOU KNOW. THE PAKSHA
CREATING PROBLEMS OR OR JUST
STOP YOU KNOW BASICALLY STOP THE
BLEEDING. OKAY A POINT ON THANK
YOU TYPOLOGIES SO I'M AND
RELATED TO THAT GOES TO THE
OTHER POINT THE OPPOSITION'S
RAISED IS THAT THERE MAY BE IF
WE ARE SO SPECIFIC AS TO SAY IT
NEEDS TO BE A SOFTWARE UPDATE.
OR A SOFTWARE PATCH.
AND THAT.
.
DOES NOT PROVIDE. THE
FLEXIBILITY TO EITHER ADDRESS
THE PROBLEM MAY DESTABILIZE THE
SYSTEM.
I'VE CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT POINT
AS WELL BECAUSE I MY UNDERLINGS
IN YEARS I ABSOLUTELY AGREE WHAT
HAPPENED THAT WHAT INSPIRED YOUR
BILL IS COMPLETELY INTOLERABLE
AND THERE SHOULD BE A VERY
DIFFERENT RESPONSE AND JUST.
THAT IT'S ALMOST A NEGLIGENCE
STANDARD THAT WE SHOULD USE HERE
BECAUSE I JUST SCREAMED OF
NEGLIGENCE.
BUT WE DON'T USUALLY JUDGE WHAT
SHOULD HAVE HAPPENED.
BY DID YOU DO ONE SPECIFIC
PRESCRIPTIVE RESPONSE AS OPPOSED
TO WHAT WAS PASSED IN THE
OPPOSITION HAS RAISED A POINT
THAT A SOFTWARE UPDATE MAY NOT
BE THE BEST OPTION.
HOW DO YOU ADDRESS THAT POINT?
WELL A SOFTWARE UPDATE MAY NOT
BE THE BEST SOLUTION BUT YET I
THINK WHAT WE'RE ASKING IN THE
BILL IS TO FOR THE COMPANY TO
START.
IMPLEMENTING START THE PROCESS.
WHICH DOES NOT NECESSARILY MEAN
APPLYING THAT PATCH
SO FOR THAT PARTICULAR SYSTEM
FOR EXAMPLE SO YOU KNOW WE DO
PROVIDE YOU KNOW A A A A A A
TIME PERIOD WHERE THEY HAVE TO
EVALUATE WHAT'S BEST FOR THE
COMPANY. A WEATHER NOT A ONE
APPLY TO GET UP TO PATCH ME THE
THE THE THE BILL ITSELF ALSO
DOZEN REALLY.
PENALIZE THE COMPANY IF THERE'S
NO PREACH.
SO.
IF IF IT'S IF THE COMPANY DEEMS
IT ARE PROPER TO NOT APPLY THE
PATCH IN THEIR SITUATION IT'S
THEIR PREROGATIVE ALSO BUT IT SO
LONG AS IT DOESN'T CAUSE ANY
BREACH.
AND FUTURE.
THINKING THERE IF THERE'S NO
CONNECTION THERE'S A NEXT NO
NEXUS BETWEEN APPLYING A PATCH
TO THE ULTIMATE BREACH THEN
THERE'S NO LIABILITY.
THANK YOU.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
SEVERAL THAT I UNDERSTOOD WHAT
SHOULD I DO AND I AM SUPPORTIVE
OF THE BILL IN GENERAL JUST HAD
IT A COUPLE OF YOUR SUGGESTIONS
THAT I HOPE ARE HELPFUL. SARAH
AND.
A SIMILAR TO WHAT I'VE SAID
BEFORE.
I'M.
I THINK WE NEED TO AVOID
AMBIGUITY. ESPECIALLY WHEN THE
CONSEQUENCES
THROUGH PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
ARE SO SERIOUS FOR THE PEOPLE
WHO VIOLATED THIS.
PROPOSED LAW SO.
I THINK WHEN WE SAY SECURITY
VULNERABILITY WE NEED WHEN YOU
MIGHT NEEDS TO DEFINE EXACTLY
WHAT YOU MEAN. BY VULNERABILITY
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY A SUPERFICIAL
VULNERABILITY IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT YOU WOULD WANT TO TARGET
AND ALSO WHEN.
WHEN YOU SAY A BREACH OF
SECURITY I THINK YOU NEED TO
DEFINE EXACTLY WHAT THAT MEANS
BECAUSE A SUPERFICIAL BREACH OF
SECURITY I DON'T THINK YOU'D
WANT TO TRIGGER THIS.
I AND I ALSO THINK THAT THAT YOU
MIGHT ITS DEFINITION ON EXACTLY
WHAT WHAT YOU MEAN WHEN YOU SAY
AN INJURY HAS OCCURRED. THAT
TRIGGERS THIS PRIDE RIGHT AFFECT
RIGHT OF ACTION BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY.
SUPERFICIAL INJURY IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE TARGETING
BUT OTHER THOSE ARE JUST
SUGGESTIONS ON HAVING A SPORT
THAT THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AND WE
DO INTEND THAT KIND OF FINE TUNE
THE BILL AS WE GO ALONG AND IF
INCLUDING THE DATE AND AND. AND.
YOU KNOW THE TIME PERIOD SO.
YOU KNOW WE'RE KIND OPEN TO
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
SEE WHAT'S PASS.
FOR THE INDUSTRY AS A WHOLE AS
AS WELL AS WHAT HE FOR THE
CONSUMER SO WE DON'T WANT TO. WE
DON'T WANT TO JAM SOMETHING
DOWN.
YOU KNOW THEY'RE CUT THE THROAT
IF IT DOESN'T WORK OF IT YOU
KNOW EXACERBATING SITUATION.
SO I GLOBAL POINT WELL TAKEN.
I DON'T HOUSE.
SHALL WE GET CLOSE
I A RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
ARRIVAL AND.
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT BILL
AND I I THINK.
ICE I WANNA CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE OPPOSITION TO TO FIND
OUT YOU KNOW TO FIND THAT SWEET
SPOT.
SO WITH THAT I I'D AS WE HAVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAO ON.
SO I I APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENTION
TO THE ISSUE ONE OF THE MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE OR
DEEPLY SHAKEN. BY THE BREACH THE
REFERRED TO BUT I THINK MS BAKER
HAD THE NAIL ON THE HEAD THAT I
JUST DON'T THINK A PER SE RULE.
AYE THAT AUTOMATICALLY TRIGGERS
DAMAGES MAKES SENSE IN THIS
CONTEXT.
AND THAT.
IT DOESN'T GET THE INCENTIVES
RIGHT AYE TO MAXIMIZE SECURITY
IN THAT WE MUCH BE MUCH BETTER
SERVED.
BY LIABILITY HINGING ON ON THE
NEGLIGENCE OF THE COMPANY.
IF IF HARM IS SUFFERED SO I
HAVE NO REASON FOR HIM NOT GONNA
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY BUT LOOK
FOR SEEING HOW IT EVOLVES.
MADAM SECRETARY THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO.
APPROPRIATIONS I BELIEVE AT NEW
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
IT WAS A LITTLE.
TO PASS A THAT'S MY MISTAKE WE
DO NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN FIFTY
NINE TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
JUDICIARY.
TELL AYE AYE KILEY NOW NOW
BAKER.
I BERMAN.
CALDERON. AYE IRWIN.
AYE MULLIN. AYE OBERNOLTE. AYE
REYES. AYE.
TEN.
I.
SO ITS EIGHT THE BILL THAT. LIKE
YOU IMAGE OKAY I SAW MISTER
COOPER HAD ARRIVED NAM TERRIBLE
SICK HE'S GONE UP SO LET'S
PROCEED TO MISTER I CHAO'S NEXT
BILL WHICH I BELIEVE WOULD BE.
A. B. TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN.
I'M FOR.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUT MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
.
LET ME ALSO SIDE BY ACCEPTING
THE AUTHORS AMEND AND.
IN THE AISLE IN THE.
ANALYSIS.
.
IN RESPONSE TO CONCERNS RAISED
BY THE CHAIR OF THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE DEMANDS.
TIGHTEN UP THE DEFINITION OF
DIGITAL HEALTH CARE. OF FEEDBACK
SYSTEM TO ENSURE THAT WE. WON'T
NEED TO AMEND THE STATUTE OF A
TIME IN NEW TECHNOLOGY IS
INTRODUCED.
THANK YOU SECONDLY SOME ARE
MANUFACTURERS OF ADJUSTABLE
SENSORS HAVE EXPRESSED CONCERN
OVER THE REQUIREMENT THAT
MANUFACTURERS OF A DIGITAL A
FEEDBACK SYSTEM EQUIPPED TO
SYSTEM WITH REASONABLE SECURITY
MEASURES.
ALL THIS REQUIREMENT WAS WRITTEN
TO ENSURE THE SECURITY OF ANY
SOFTWARE OR DEVICE THAT COLLECTS
INFORMATION ACCORDINGLY THESE
AMENDMENTS WOULD ALSO ACCEPT THE
MANUFACTURERS OF THE IN JUST A
BOTH ANSWER. FROM THE OBLIGATION
TO EQUIP THE EQUIPMENT WAIT THE
REASONABLE SECURITY OF FEATURES.
OF THE BILL ITSELF WOULD
IMPLEMENT REASONABLE REGULATIONS
FOR THE USE OF DIGITAL HEALTH
CARE FEEDBACK SYSTEM INCLUDING
ITEMS ALSO KNOWN AS DIGITAL
PILLS.
WHILE TECHNOLOGY STANDS TO
IMPROVE HOW HEALTHCARE IS
DELIVERED A THESE ADVANCEMENTS
DO NOT COME WITHOUT RISK HEALTH
AND MEDICAL INFORMATION IS BY
ITS VERY NATURE DEEPLY PERSONAL
AND SENSITIVE.
NEW TECHNOLOGY MAKES MEDICAL
INFORMATION EASILY AND QUICKLY
ACCESSIBLE VIA APPS IN OF
WEBSITES AND CALIFORNIA HOUSE
AND SURE THAT MEDICAL
INFORMATION HELD BY MOBILE
DEVICES IS PROTECTED UNDER ALL
PRIVACY LAWS.
HOWEVER IN ORDER TO BE
CONSIDERED MEDICAL INFORMATION
ALL THE INFORMATION GENERALLY
NEEDS TO BE GENERATED. BY A
HEALTHCARE PROVIDER INFORMATION
THAT IS GENERATED BY DIGITAL
HEALTH FEEDBACK SYSTEM MEANING
AT THE PATIENT LEVEL AND OUTSIDE
OF A MEDICAL FACILITY WILL NOT
NECESSARILY BE CAPTURE. UNDER
THE EXISTING DEFINITION OF
MEDICAL. INFORMATION.
SEVERAL FORMS OF DIGITAL
PILLOWS THAT SEND INFORMATION
FROM PLACES LIKE THE DIGESTIVE
TRACT WILL BLOODSTREAM ARE BEING
DEVELOPED. WITH A FEW ALREADY IN
USE.
NOW THESE DIGITAL PILLS WEAKENED
WHICH COMBINE OUR ADJUSTABLE
MICROCHIP SENSORS WITHOUT
WITHOUT PHARMACEUTICALS CAN
OPERATE IN A MANNER IN A NUMBER
OF WAYS.
THEY CAN CONTROL AND MONITOR THE
RELEASE OF ACTIVE FOR
PHARMACEUTICAL.
OUR INGREDIENTS AFTER INGESTION
THE CAN ALSO RECORD.
WHETHER WHEN WHERE AND IN WHAT
QUANTITIES A DRUG IS RELEASED AS
WELL AS INFORMATION ABOUT THE
PHYSICAL STATE OF THE PERSON
TAKING THAT TRIP.
SUCH AS TEMPERATURE ACTIVITY
LEVEL HEART RATE AND
RESPIRATION.
NO THE INFORMATION ABOUT WHETHER
A PATIENT TOOK HIS OR HER
MEDICATION AND HOW THAT
MEDICATION INTERACTED IN THEIR
BODIES. IS UNQUESTIONABLE
OF A MEDICAL NATURE. SO IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT THE INFORMATION
GENERATED BY THE DIGITAL SYSTEM
IS CLASSIFIED AS MEDICAL
INFORMATION AND DEVELOPERS AND
DEVELOPERS AND OPERATORS OF
HARDWARE SOFTWARE AND
APPLICATIONS USED IN CONJUNCTION
WITH. THE GERBILS ARE ALREADY
PROHIBITED FROM SHARING THE
INFORMATION WITHOUT THE
PATIENT'S INFORMED CONSENT.
ARE THE BILL WOULD BE FINE
DIGITAL HEALTH FEEDBACK SYSTEM
TO INCLUDE INFORMATION SUCH AS
DIGITAL BELT. AND ENSURE THAT
THE CONFIDENTIALITY OF MEDICAL
INFORMATION ACT WAS CMI A.
APPLIES TO INFORMATION DERIVED
FROM OR IN THE POSSESSION OF THE
SYSTEMS THE BILL WOULD ALSO FOR
THE REQUIRED A MANUFACTURER IS
EQUIPPED DIGITAL HEALTH.
FEEDBACK SYSTEMS WITH REASONABLE
AND APPROPRIATE SECURITY
MEASURES ARM.
SO A BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION I
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ARRIVAL.
OTHER NEW ISN'T SMART.
OPPOSITION.
WHAT'S YOUR TECHNICAL TERM
MISTER CHAIR FOR THOSE WHO ARE
NEITHER.
WIENERS.
OKAY.
DIGITAL BILLS. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
NEITHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION I
GOT HERE THAT.
WHAT'S THAT
DISAPPEAR OR ARE YOU GONNA BE
TESTED BY LENGTH WHATEVER SUITS
YOU.
ALL OF ROCK GRAY CALIFORNIA
LIFE SCIENCES ASSOCIATION.
CONCERNS.
WE ONE THINK THE AUTHOR IN THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
US.
WE'VE EXPRESSED THESE CONCERNS
TO THEM THIS TECHNOLOGIES IT'S
AN IN ITS INFANCY OF THE SENSORS
ARE ABOUT THE SIZE OF A GRAIN OF
SAND THEY DO NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO TRANSMIT
INDEPENDENTLY.
THEY ARE USED IN A VERY NICHE
MARKET FOR MEDICATION NON
ADHERENCE SO IN THE CASE OF A OF
A PATIENT WHO NEEDS TO TAKE
MEDICINE.
ON A VERY REGULATED SCHEDULE
THAT DOES SO FOR VARIOUS REASONS
I COULD BE MENTAL HEALTH COULD
BE.
A NUMBER OF REASONS.
THIS TECHNOLOGY WOULD ALLOW A
PHYSICIAN TO PROPERLY MONITOR OR
CARETAKER TO PROPERLY MONITOR
THAT THE PATIENT IS INGESTING
THE MEDICATION THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO TAKE WHEN THEY ARE SUPPOSED
TO TAKE IT. AYE AND TRACK THAT.
IN TERMS OF COST OF THE
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM
MEDICATION NON ADHERENTS.
COSTS ABOUT A HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND LIVES A YEAR.
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
SO AGAIN THIS TECHNOLOGY IS IS
AT THE VERY BEGINNING STAGES OF
WHERE IT COULD ONE DAY BE.
OVER REGULATING AT THIS POINT
MAY STIFLE INNOVATION AND WERE
JUST CONCERNED THAT.
.
WE BE SENSITIVE TO THOSE ISSUES
THAT WHEN REPORTS UP THANK YOU
AGAIN.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON AT MY NAME'S
FIELDING GRIEVE SOME WITH THE
ADVANCEMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ONE ASSOCIATE WITH
MY COMMENTS I WITH HIM HIS
COMMENTS.
AND ALSO TO SHARE THAT WE THINK
IT COULD BE PREMATURE AT THIS
TIME TO REGULATE THIS TECHNOLOGY
IN THIS WAY. GIVEN THE
OVERLAPPING THAT FEDERAL
REGULATIONS FTA AND I HAVE TO
SEE CURRENTLY HAVE.
FDA REGULATIONS DO AB CONSIDER
A HOLISTIC RISK BASED APPROACH
TO MEDICAL DEVICE TECHNOLOGY SO
THAT INCLUDES ALL DATA
STEWARDSHIP ISSUES BOTH
CYBERSECURITY. AND DATA PRIVACY.
AT THE FEDERAL TRADE COMMISSION
IS EXTREMELY BROAD AUTHORITY
UNDER SECTION FIVE TO REGULATE.
ON DECEPTIVE I OR UNFAIR
BUSINESS PRACTICES SO.
CURRENTLY THE THE TECHNOLOGY
THAT'S IN THE INDUSTRY IT'S HELD
OUT TO THE CONSUMER AND INTO THE
MARKETPLACE.
AS GIVING FULL CONTROL AND
OWNERSHIP OF THE DATA TO THE
ACTUAL PATIENT INCLUDING WHETHER
OR NOT THAT DATE IS GIVEN OVER
TO THE DOCTOR.
HIM HERSELF.
SO IF THAT WERE EVER FOUND OUT
TO BE TRUE THEY BEEN VIOLATION
OF THE ACT THE FEDERAL TRADE
COMMISSION COULD CERTAINLY STEP
AND THEY HAVE EXTREMELY BROAD
AUTHORITY TO DO TO DO SO. AND
THEY ALSO CURRENTLY HAVE AN MO
YOU WITH THE FDA TO TO.
COLLABORATE WITH THE FDA ON
THAT PLATFORM REGULATIONS SO
WITH THAT WE JUST EXPRESSES
CONCERNS.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES OF ANY KIND.
ALL RIGHT BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE NOW. MR CHOW DO YOU
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT JUST TO.
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS BECAUSE
IT DOES SEEM LIKE WE HAVE.
QUITE A LOT OF THAT REGULATORS
OUT THERE THERE'S THE FDA
APPROVAL PROCESS FOR EXAMPLE SO
WHAT IS THIS GONNA AT.
I THINK I THINK JUST OF THIS
BILL IS TO BASICALLY ARM.
MAKE SURE THE THE INFORMATION
THAT WE COLLECT ARE BY THESE
DIGITAL PILLS IS PROTECTED
THAT'S THE ULTIMATE UNDERLYING A
RATIONALE FOR THE BILL. NOW
CURRENTLY UNDER YOU THEIR HIP OR
CMI A TO CALIFORNIA VERSION OF
IT BUT. ESSENTIALLY PROTECTS
INFORMATION THAT'S GENERATED BY
LET'S SAY HEALTH CARE PROVIDER.
AND DOW IF IT IF IT IS STAND
IT'S A PROTECTIVE BUT ARE NOW
ALSO IF THE INFORMATION IS
RECEIVED BY THE MEDICAL PROVIDER
ALL BEEN IT'S ALSO PROTECTED YET
UNDER DISSERVICE CONSENSUS. OP
THE JET THE INFORMATION IS
GENERATED APPLIED TO DEVISE A
WHICH BEFORE IT GETS UP RECEIVED
BY THE YOU KNOW THAT THE.
POSITION FOR EXAMPLE IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT PROTECTED SO WHICH IS
TRYING TO CLOSE OUT LOW GAP
THERE SO.
YOU KNOW IF THEM YOU KNOW IT OF
IT IF DOT INFORMATION IS ALREADY
GENERATED BY A PHYSICIAN WAS
ALWAYS PROTECTED IF IT'S
RECEIVED BY VISITING IT'S A
PROTECTED BUT IT'S NOT LITTLE
KIND OF A GAP IN BETWEEN. THAT
WE TRYING TO THE PLUG SO THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL IS ALL ABOUT TO
TO THESE DEVICES THAT WOULD
GENERATE ARE YOU KNOW.
HEALTH CARE INFORMATION PLEASE
FOR DOUBLE HEART RATE OR
WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE. ON
THEN BEFORE IT REACHES THAT THE.
THE POSITIONS OF OFFICE THEN DOT
WILL YOU KNOW THERE'S LITTLE
DOUBT THAT YOU KNOW THAT.
WE TRY TO PROTECT.
TWO SO THAT'S THE ESSENCE OF THE
BILL SO IT'S A VERY TINY LITTLE
THING ARE SO THE IN FACT.
WE ALREADY HOUSE A BILL THAT I
IN FACT.
AUTHORED BY A MISTER CALDERON
LAST YEAR THAT WOULD PROTECT
THAT WOULD GIVE THE SAME IT'S
THE SAME PROTECTION TO.
THE DEVICES THAT WOULD GENERATE
I MEAN ARE YOU THIS IS SOFTWARE
AND HARDWARE.
FOLKS ARE YOU KNOW.
IT'S A DIFFERENT BILL A BILL
NUMBER FIVE YET EXACTLY WOULDN'T
BILL NUMBER THAT WAS BROUGH YOU
KNOW WE TALK ABOUT THAT LITTLE
GAP THERE.
SO I HOPE THAT CLARIFIES.
ALSO THAT THAT'S A FEDERAL LINE
AND STATE LAW.
WE DON'T STUFF I DON'T WANT TO
STIFLE IN WE INNOVATION YOU KNOW
FOR SURE.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
SO WITHOUT SEEMING LIKE A BOOK
BROKEN RECORD I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO BE SPECIFIC.
ESPECIALLY ONE THE CONSEQUENCES
OF VIOLATION OF THE LAW ARE
SEVERE AS THEY ARE HERE BECAUSE
IT CREATES NEW CRIMINAL
LIABILITY. SO I THERE'S A TERM
IN THERE THAT SAYS THAT.
WHAT'S REQUIRED A REASONABLE
SECURITY FEATURES APPROPRIATE TO
THE NATURE OF THE SYSTEM.
AND I THINK THAT WE NEED TO DO A
BETTER JOB DEFINING EXACTLY WHAT
REASONABLE SECURITY FEATURES ARE
BECAUSE I JUST CAN ENVISION A
ROOM FULL OF LAWYERS ARGUING
ABOUT. WITH EACH OTHER ABOUT
WHAT WE MET WHEN WE SET
REASONABLE SO I HAD TO TO
SUGGESTION NOT GOT A QUESTION
FOR YOU IS. I NOTICED THAT YOU
ALSO SAID REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
NOT.
THE IDENTIFICATION SITE THE.
DATA IS I DIDN'T AS
INDIVIDUALLY IDENTIFIABLE AND
I'M WONDERING WHY. YOU PUT THAT
IN THERE BECAUSE IT WOULD SEEM
LIKE ONLY THE INDIVIDUALLY
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION IS THE
ONE THAT WE WOULD HAVE FOR
PRIVACY CONCERNS ABOUT.
PA I HAVE LOOKED AT THE LANGUAGE
A BIT MORE CLOSELY BUT I I THINK
THE INTENT IS TO PROTECT. OUR
INFORMATION THAT WOULD ALLOW
ANYBODY TO OUR LINK BACK TO THE
THE. THE.
GENERATOR OF THAT OF THAT
PERSON.
BEAT OUT A PRINT PATIENT OR THE
HUESO TO ANY INFORMATION THAT
WOULD ALLOW SOMEBODY TO
IDENTIFY.
TO YOU KNOW.
THAT PERSON I THINK WE WANT
PROTECT. I WOULD AGREE DOWN BUT
I WOULDN'T CLASSIFY ANYTHING
WHICH YOU COULD LINK BACK AS
INDIVIDUALLY IDENTIFIABLE AND I
DON'T THINK THAT DATA. THAT'S
AGGREGATED FOR EXAMPLE WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF PATIENTS TOOK
THEIR PILLS.
WAS IT WHICH IS AN INTERESTING
PIECE OF INFORMATION WOULD COME
OUT OF A SYSTEM LIKE THAT I
DON'T THINK THAT THAT IS A KIND
OF INFORMATION THAT SHOULD HAVE
CRIMINAL PENALTIES ASSOCIATED
WITH IT. AS INSURANCE WILL
CONTEST OVER MARK THANKS.
SHALL WE JUST CLOSE
I SHARE AYE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
ARRIVAL SO ESSENTIALLY THIS IS
A.
WHAT WE TRY TO DO IS TO
BASICALLY MIRROR WHAT CMI A DOES
SO ON YOU KNOW ON THE ON THE
CURRENT LAW SO? THOSE JUST IT'S
JUST THE INFORMATION THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO LUMP UNDER CMA I A SO
THAT WE PROTECT THAT PIECE OF
INFORMATION I MEAN WE'RE NOT
CHANGING CMA I A WITH WILL
WHATSOEVER SO WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT.
I THINK YOU KNOW I DO APPRECIATE
THE CLARIFYING COMMENTS I GUESS
MY TAKE ON ON THIS ONE IS THIS
IS A PRETTY EXCITING AND
POTENTIALLY LIFE SAVING THAT
TECHNOLOGY HERE I THINK IT'S
WORTH. AT KEEPING AN EYE ON
WHETHER THERE'S A ROLE FOR
LEGISLATION AYE DOWN THE ROAD
OUTSIDE OF WHAT EXISTS NOW BEEN
THE ABSENCE OF ANY SORT OF
DEMONSTRABLE. NEED FOR I AM
CONCERNED THAT. YOU MIGHT HAVE
NO REAL BENEFIT BUT THEN
POTENTIAL HARM WHEN WE HAVE.
NDUSTRY IN ITS INFANCY LIKE
THIS THAT COULD BE.
CONSTRAINED BY WHAT OF
REGULATIONS FROM FROM THE SO I
DON'T HAVE A BE VOTING FOR THIS
TODAY BUT I DID LEARN SOMETHING
IN PRESENTATIONS OF THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OUT WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
WITH THE IT IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE SIXTY
SEVEN TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
SHALL I AYE KILEY NO NO.
BAKER. AYE BERMAN. AYE CALDERON.
AYE IRWIN. AYE MULLIN.
I OBERNOLTE. KNOW REYES.
TING. AYE.
SEVENTY TWO YES. THE BILL IS
OUT.
MATCHA.
AND ONE MORE FOR MISTER CHECK.
BELIEVE I'VE TOO MUCH OR IS TWO
ONE ONE ONE TWO MARK.
BUT I WAS ON CONSENT.
WHAT IS IT THAT ENTERS
PREFERENCE?
OKAY YET SO WE'RE MOVING ON TO
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY EIGHT.
BUT IT OKAY.
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY EIGHT THERE
ARE.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE HOW THE BILL
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY EIGHT WILL
ESTABLISH A VOLUNTARY PILOT
PROGRAM FOR COUNTY ELECTION
OFFICIALS. TO HAVE IN IN
INDEPENDENT CYBERSECURITY
ASSESSMENT OF THEIR ELECTION
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE STATE OF THE
NUMBER OF CYBERSECURITY
RESOURCES AT ITS DISPOSAL A
GOVERNOR BROWN'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
B. THIRTY EIGHT DASH FIFTEEN
REQUIRED THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES. WHAT?
YES OUT TO ESTABLISH AND LEAD
TO CALIFORNIA CYBERSECURITY
INNOVATION CENTER AUSSIE SICK
WITH THE. PRIMARY MISSION TO
REDUCE THE LIKELIHOOD AND
SEVERITY OF CYBER INCIDENTS OF
THAT COULD DAMAGE TO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY IT'S
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE. OR
PUBLIC OR PRIVATE SECTOR
COMPUTER NETWORKS IN THE STATE.
THANK YOU THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY AND THE
CALIFORNIA MILITARY DEPARTMENT
ARE PARTNERS IN CAL AND CAL
SICK.
ARE IN ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF THE
THREAT OF CYBER SECURITY.
TAX SO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO ENACTED THAT HE BEAT SIX
SEVENTY WHICH SHE WAS ON HIS
IRWIN SPELT.
HOW TO REQUIRE CD CMT AND OH YES
TO ANNUALLY CONDUCT NO FEWER
THAN THIRTY FIVE INDEPENDENT
SECURITY ASSESSMENTS? OF STATE
AGENCIES DEPARTMENTS AND
OFFICES.
AYE DIS AYE ESSAYS EVALUATE THE
AGENCY ON HOW EFFECTIVELY IT
PROTECTS PERSONAL IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION HEALTH INFORMATION
AND CONFIDENTIAL FINANCIAL
INFORMATION. ALONG WITH US
CONSIDERING SELF CERTIFICATION
ALL AND THE LIKE. ARE THE SHIFT
FROM A SILO THIS JOINT THEIR
APPROACH TO IT. A PUNISHER BASED
APPROACH TO ADDRESS A
CYBERSECURITY ISSUES ON THE
STATE LEVEL HAS MADE A CRITICAL
DIFFERENCE IN BETTER ADDRESSING
CYBERSECURITY CONCERNS IN A
STATE GOVERNMENT. ALL THIS BILL
IS AN EFFORT TO TAKE WHAT WE
HAVE LEARNED BY PULLING OUR
STATE SO CYBERSECURITY RESOURCES
ARE TOGETHER IMPLY AND APPLY THE
STATE'S.
THESE RESOURCES TO THERE OUGHT
TO THEIR UTMOST ADVANTAGES IN
AND CRITICAL AREAS INCLUDING
ELECTIONS.
OUR IT STATES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE'S INTENT IS TO
RECOGNIZE ELECTION
INFRASTRUCTURE AS CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND TO LEVERAGE
THE STATE'S CYBERSECURITY
RESOURCES TO ASSIST COUNTY
ELECTION OFFICIALS. IN THEIR
ASSESSMENTS OF ELECT THE
ELECTION INFRASTRUCTURE. ARE AND
FINALLY THE BILL WOULD ESTABLISH
A PILOT PROGRAM TO PERFORM SIX
SEVENTY LIKE A HIGHEST DAYS OF
THE ELECTION AYE FOR STRUCTURES
IN PARTICIPATING COUNTIES ALL
ALL OF THE I OC INFORMATION. AND
RESULTS ARE CONFIDENTIAL AND NOT
DISCLOSE A BILL TO THE PUBLIC SO
WITHOUT AYE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
WHAT IS IN SUPPORT?
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OTHER WITNESSES.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
ALRIGHT AND THE. SECRETARY OF
STEPPED OUT.
SO GIVES MR CHILD HAS TO CLOSE
ANYTHING CREATED A VILLAIN OR DO
WE NEED TO IF THE SECRETARY FOR
TURN.
I'LL GO AHEAD MR CAPTURE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN FOR YOUR
TIME AND THIS IS AN EFFORT TO
BASICALLY.
I HAVE A WE LEVERAGE OF THE
STATE RESOURCES IN IN THE AREA
CYBERSECURITY TO HELP OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. AND.
DOING ASSESSMENTS AND A
PROVIDING A SAFE ENVIRONMENT FOR
THEM.
IN THE ELECTION SYSTEM SO SO
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
ARRIVAL IN THAT THIS IS GOING TO
BE A FIVE YEAR PILOT PROJECT
AND.
WE GOTTA THINK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED THE MOTION IS DE PAST
ELECTIONS CHAO I. SHOWER AYE
KILEY AYE KILEY AYE BAKER.
BERMAN.
BERMAN I CALDERON. CALDERON AYE
IRWIN. IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE. OBERNOLTE
AYE REYES.
TING. TING AYE. BILLS ON COP.
IT'S OUT OF THE BILLS OUT.
I.
I KNOW IS MISTER COOPER'S HERE'S
IS A WHICH LIKE TODAY HAVE
MISTER COOPER'S BILL HEARD AYE
AYE YOUR DISCUSSIONS YOUR.
AND I DISCUSSION.
I'LL DO MY THING OKAY.
AUTHOR.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT.
.
HOPEFULLY THIS WILL GO QUICK. I
THANK YOU AGAIN MR AND A
MEMBERS.
AB THIRTY ONE NINETY THREE IS A
FAIRLY STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL A
JOINTLY AUTHORED BY MYSELF AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS IRWIN AND
OBERNOLTE TO ADDRESS AN ISSUE WE
HEARD ABOUT MOST. THANK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MOST RECENTLY IN A
JOINT OVERSIGHT HEARING ON
CYBERSECURITY ALL IN FEBRUARY
STATED IN THE SIMPLEST FORM WE
HAVE TO ENSURE THAT OUR. OF
COURSE CYBERSECURITY PARTNERS
NAMELY CDT. OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT ALSO CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL ARE S. EFFECTIVE
AS POSSIBLE IN SECURING OUR
STATE ALL TO THAT AND THIS BILL
SEEKS TO ENSURE THAT THE OFFICE
OF INFORMATION SECURITY OR WHY
S.. HOUSE AS COMPLETE A PICTURE
AS POSSIBLE WITH RESPECT TO
INFORMATION SECURITY IN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH. ARE CURRENTLY
UNDER EXISTING LAW THERE'S A
CLEAR DISCREPANCY BETWEEN THE
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT WE AS A
LEGISLATURE MAY BELIEVE WE HAVE
GIVEN TO ALL AYE US AND THE
ABILITY OF ALL AYE AS TO
ACTUALLY CARRY OUT THOSE DUTIES.
TECHNICALLY SPEAKING OF THIS
CONFUSION ARISES AS A RESULT OF
HOW OR WHY S. ENABLING STATUTE
HAS BEEN DRAFTED. A SPECIFICALLY
THE LEGISLATURE HAS CHARGED A
WHY S. WITH DUTIES OVER STATE
AGENCIES QUOTE UNQUOTE IN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH IN ONE PART OF
THAT STATUTE. BUT IN THE VERY
NEXT PART OF THAT SAME STATUE
ONLY CERTAIN A STATE ENTITIES
WHO ARE WOULD DIRECT REPORTING
TO GET THE GOVERNOR ARE REQUIRED
TO COMPLY. WITH A WHY S. ISSUE
STANDARD POLICIES PROCEDURES
INCIDENT NOTIFICATIONS FILING
REQUIREMENTS AND REPORT. SO
ACCORDINGLY THIS BILL REMOVES
ANY AMBIGUITY ALL IN THE LAW AND
CLEARLY STATES THAT ALL STATE
AGENCIES MUST COMPLY WITH A WHY
S. ISSUE INFORMATION SECURITY
REQUIREMENTS.
ALTHOUGH I THINK I WANT WANT TO
SAY IS THAT WHILE THIS BILL HAS
NO FORMAL OF FORMAL OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME I DO KNOW THAT SOME
OF THE CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS.
ARE INCLUDING THE.
THE AG'S OFFICE AND ALSO THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE HAVE
REACHED OUT TO AS A TO DISCUSS
CONCERNS THAT ABOUT HOW THIS
BILL MIGHT IMPACT THEIR OFFICES
IN PARTICULAR. I DO.
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT WE NEED
TO REMOVE ANY UNNECESSARY AND.
AMBIGUITY IN STATUTE.
TO BRING AS I'M MUCH OF
CONSISTENCY AS POSSIBLE CROSS
WAS THE GOVERNMENT CYBER
SECURITY AND INFORMATION
SECURITY. I WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK CONTINUE WORKING WITH THESE
OFFICES TO SEE HOW WE COULD DO.
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE ISSUES
ARE IF THAT'S POSSIBLE SO
ULTIMATELY I'M WE WANT TO MAKE
CYBERSECURITY AS STRONG AS
POSSIBLE. ARE NOW IN THE STATE
AND IN A WAY THAT REALLY ARE
MAKE SENSE SO GREAT OVER.
WE RESPECT US SO WE GOT I LIKE
TO ASK FOR YOU I DON'T THINK
YOU.
THINGS CHAO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
STATE TREASURER'S OFFICE ON
BEHALF JOHN CHIANG.
AND THE DEPUTY TREASURER OF
TECHNOLOGY AND INNOVATION IN THE
CHIEF INFORMATION OFFICER AT THE
OFFICE.
THE TREASURER'S OFFICE HAS
CONCERNS RELATED TO THE BILL IS
YOU CAN READ SEE REFLECTED IN
OUR LETTER. IT IS OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE GOAL OF
THIS BILL IS TO ENSURE OUR STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES ARE
COMPLIANT WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY. IN THE FOLLOWING
AREAS THE INFORMATION SECURITY
AND PRIVACY POLICIES STANDARDS
AND PROCEDURES AS ISSUED BY THE
OFFICE OF THE STATE INFORMATION
SECURITY OFFICER. AND THE FILING
AN INCIDENT NOTIFICATIONS
REQUIREMENTS ISSUED BY THE STATE
INFORMATION SECURITY OFFICER.
IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT OUR
OFFICES ALREADY COMPLIANCE WITH
THESE PROCEEDINGS AND DUTIES.
OUR CONCERN WITH THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENT IS THAT IT WILL EXPAND
THE SCOPE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
AUTHORITY. TO GIVE MANDATING
POWER TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY OVER
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICES REGARDING
THEIR INFORMATION SECURITY
OPERATIONS.
OUR YOU SHE WAS NOT WITH
COMPLYING A STATED EARLIER WE
ALREADY DO SO.
THE INDEPENDENCE OF CALIFORNIA'S
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICES IS PART
OF THE STATE'S SYSTEM OF CHECKS
AND BALANCES.
WHICH AS DESIGN MITIGATES THE
RISK THAT AN ENTITY EXTERNAL TO
THE AUTHORITY OF THE
CONSTITUTIONALLY ELECTED OFFICE
HOLDER. CAN UNDULY A ROAD THAT
INDEPENDENCE AND PLACE BURDENS
OF RESPONSIBILITY FINANCIAL OR
OTHERWISE WHICH DO NOT ALIGN
WITH THE PRIORITIES OF THE
ELECTED OFFICIAL.
ALTHOUGH UNIFORMITY IN STANDARDS
SECURITY IS HIGHLY IMPORTANT WE
DO NOT BELIEVE EXPANDING THE
GOVERNOR'S AUTHORITY OVER
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICES IS
NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE THE
OBJECTIVE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
KATHLEEN SHARON MEMBERS I AM AMY
ALLEY WITH A CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. AND FIRST
I WANTED TO THINK I'M ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAO FOR YOUR GRACIOUS
COMMENTS ABOUT WORKING WITH FAST
THEY REALLY APPRECIATED WORKING
WITH BOTH YOUR STAFF AND YOUR ON
COMMITTEE STAFF THIS WEEK. AND
UMPIRE WHILE MY DEPARTMENT HAS.
VERY STRONG CONCERNS WITH THE
CURRENT LANGUAGE AS IT WOULD
APPLY TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. AND WE BELIEVE THAT WE
CAN GET TO A POINT WHERE WE YOU
KNOW WE CAN ALL AG AGREE TO SOME
COMPROMISE SAYS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH YOU AS WELL AS THE OTHER.
JOINT AUTHORS.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON SUE BANG ON
BEHALF OF STATE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TOM
TOILETS AND. RESPECTFULLY HERE
WITH SERIOUS THAT TRONG CONCERNS
IN OPPOSITION OF TO THE SPELL.
AT THE SUPERINTENDENT JUST TOOK
THIS POSITION SO WE APOLOGIZE
FOR NOT SENDING A LETTER IN
ADVANCE.
BOB SUPERINTENDENT SUPPORTS
EFFORTS TO WORK WITH OTHER
AGENCIES AND TO IMPROVE
CYBERSECURITY IN FACT PART OF
EDUCATION AND ALSO COMPLIES
WITH.
A THE PROVISIONS STATS IN THE
SPELL HOWEVER HE DOES NOT
SUPPORT A REVISION OF GOVERNMENT
COACH TO GIVE. OF THAT
CALIFORNIA PART OF TECHNOLOGY
AUTHORITY OVER CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICES AS AND THE OTHER MEMBERS
HAVE SUGGESTED. THEIR FORUM WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE ABOUT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TED MAUL HOUSE OR ON
BEHALF OF SECRETARY OF STATE AL
EXPEDIA WE ARE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE DOES NOT HAVE A
POSITION ON THIS BILL WE ARE
STILL REVIEWING IT THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
CURRENT MEMBERS.
THIS EARLY.
I AM HAPPY TO BE.
THE JOINT AUTHOR OF THIS BILL
WITH YOU AND AND WITH MISTER
OBERNOLTE AND I I JUST WANNA SAY
THAT WHEN I AUTHORED.
SIX SEVENTY.
WE HAD ALL THE DEPARTMENT
SAYING THAT.
THESE THESE AUDITS OF THIS IS A
SECURITY ASSESSMENTS WERE
UNNECESSARY.
AND THEN A FEW MONTHS LATER WE
HAD.
THAT AN OVERSIGHT HEARING AND
IT TURNS OUT THAT. MANY OF THE
DEPARTMENTS WERE I NOT COMPLIANT
AND DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THE
VULNERABILITIES THAT THEY HAVE
SO OF HERE A COUPLE YEARS LATER
WE'VE SEEN INCREDIBLE STRIDES
MADE. BY REQUIRING THESE
SECURITY ASSESSMENT SO I I
REALLY DO HOPE THAT WE CAN ALL.
WORK TOGETHER AND MAKE SURE YOU
KNOW OUR OUR INTENTION IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT'S THAT.
EVERYBODY THAT LIVES IN
CALIFORNIA HAS THEIR INFORMATION
PROTECTED IN ALL THESE DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS AND AND MAKING SURE
THAT EACH OF THE CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICERS HAS A MINIMUM LEVEL OF.
.
SECURITY I DON'T THINK IS
UNREASONABLE SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN
WORK TOGETHER AND COME UP WITH
SOME SORT OF SOLUTION.
MISTER CHOW WHICH OUTLAWS HERE
ARE AT THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUT
OF FOR THE RECORD I JUST WANTED
TO STATE THAT. WE HAVE NOT
RECEIVED A COPY OF THE LETTER
FROM THREE YEARS OFFICE IN FACT
TODAY'S THE FIRST TIME WE'VE
HEARD ABOUT THAT THE CONTENT OF
THE LETTER SO. I APPRECIATE THAT
THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM FROM A
MISS JONES OFFICE HAVE TO SHARE
THAT WITH US TODAY ARE AS WELL
AS THE THE SPI BUT ARE WE ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THAT YOU KNOW ALL OF OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS AND A.
AND A STAKEHOLDERS SAID IN
RESOLVING THIS A THIS AMBIGUITY
ISSUE WHICH HAS BEEN FESTERING
FOR A LONG TIME SO. SO YOU KNOW
THE PROBLEM WITH WITH TI TEES AT
ANYA WHICH STATURE WHAT IT WHAT
PART OF THE STATUE OF THE.
ALLIGATOR CHO TO COMPLY WITH I
MEAN SO THERE'S A LOT OF
AMBIGUITY WHICH CAUSES A LOT OF
CONFUSION ON THEIR PART. SAID I
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY INTENT
TO SAY YOU KNOW WE WANT CONTROL
OVER YOU KNOW CERTAIN OFFICES I
THINK THE INTENT IS TO BASICALLY
LEVERAGE WHAT WE HOW. AT THE
STATE LEVEL AS FAR AS THE
CYBERSECURITY IS CONCERNED SO SO
WE COULD YOU KNOW WHAT WE DON'T
WANT IT YOU KNOW.
DO DOUBLE DUTY I THINK IF WE
CAN LEVERAGE AND AND YOU
UTILIZED OF THESE RESOURCES TO
THE PHONE AS I THINK THAT IS THE
ULTIMATE GOAL THAT THOUGH WE
HAVE SO WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR ABBOTT.
I THINK YOU VERY MUCH AND I I I
DO APPRECIATE THAT CAUSES
OFFICERS COMING TO FIGHT FOR
YOUR TURF I GUESS MISTER JONES
AND MISTER NEWSOME I DIDN'T GET
THE MEMO BUT I. I DO THINK THAT
EVEN THOUGH WE DON'T HAVE A
UNITARY EXECUTIVE IT MAKES SENSE
TO HAVE CONSISTENT SIDE RESERVE
PERSICHETTI PROTOCOLS ACROSS THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH SO I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. I WE HAVE A
MOTION THE SECOND IT'S YOU
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS WAS CALL
THE ROLL.
AB THIRTEEN.
THIRTY ONE NINETY THREE DO PARA.
TO APPROPRIATIONS CHAO AYE AYE
KILEY AYE AYE BAKER.
BERMAN I THOUGHT I CALDERON.
I CARE WHEN.
I MULLIN. PATTERSON I OBERNOLTE.
AYE REYES.
T.. I.
EIGHT.
THE BILL WAS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I WILL RELINQUISH THE
GAVEL TO MISTER CHAO AS A MISTER
COOPER MAY APPROACH.
WE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF ITS
KILEY.
OFF WE HELP ENDOW MISTER GROUP
YES MISTER CHAIR IF YOU DON'T
MIND I WOULD LIKE TO.
MOVE.
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY TWO BY
LEVINE I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
WAS NO MOTION EYES LONG AS THE
OTHER STATES COMMITTED TO THAT
TO THE CHANGES THAT HE WAS GOING
TO MAKE SOMEONE HAPPY TO MOVE
THE BILL ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
FOR. MAKING A MOTION TO I HAVE A
SECOND ON THAT BILL.
THE BILL IT'S BEEN SAKE.
SECOND AS WELL SO WHY DON'T WE
JUST THERE. ARE TAKE THAT ONE UP
FOR NOW IT'S JUST THERE FOR THE
MISTER LEVINE BILL WHICH IS ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
TWO. SONY. AB TWENTY ONE OF THE
TO DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CHAU HIGH ALRIGHT KILEY. NOT
VOTING. BAKER.
BERMAN. I. CALDERON.
I IRWIN.
I MULLIN. AYE OBERNOLTE. NO
RARE.
THING.
THAT THAT GOES ON BECAUSE IT'S
GOT FIVE VOTES AND THERE WAS
ANOTHER ONE THAT HAS NOT BEEN.
MOVED AYE IT'S BEEN MOVED BUT
NOT SECOND IT THOUGH.
THE BILL CORRECT SO THAT WOULD
BE.
THE BILL.
OKAY LET'S FIND OUT EXACTLY THE
BILL NUMBERS BEFORE WE GOT ON
IT.
THREE ZERO ONE ZERO THAT IS THE
BILL NUMBER.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
THAT.
PLEASE CALL WROTE.
AB THREE ZERO ONE ZERO TWO
PASSES AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CHILD HI FI.
KILEY NO. BAKER.
BERMAN BUT I CALDERON. AYE
IRWIN.
AYE MULLIN.
I OBERNOLTE KNOW GRANTS.
TING.
FIVE TO TWO THAT BILL IS ON CALL
FIVE TO TWO ON.
MS JACOBY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE SO YOU HAVE AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY NINE AND THAT'S ITEM
FOURTEEN ANYTIME YOU'RE READY
YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST
LET ME BEGIN BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH MY
STAFF IN THE BILL.
I'LL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THEY MAKE THE BILL
BETTER. A BETWEEN SEVEN SIXTY
NINE EXPENSE PERSONAL PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS NOTICING LA ONE
INDIVIDUAL DRIVER'S LICENSE DMV
ISSUED.
SCARE AND NEW TECHNOLOGY ALLOWS
BUSINESS IS THE ABILITY TO
QUICKLY SCAN AND I DO YOUR
DRIVER'S LICENSE. AND LIFT AND
RETAIN SEVERAL PIECES OF
PERSONAL INFORMATION.
CURRENT LAW PLACE PERSONAL
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS WE BUSINESS
LIFE INDIVIDUALS ID OR DRIVER'S
LICENSE BUT NOT IN THE I'D YOUR
DRIVER'S LICENSE IS STAND. BY
ADDING THE WORDS CAN'T TO
EXISTING LAW THE BILL SURE SINCE
THE PERSONAL INFORMATION IS
PROTECTED.
THIS IS THE BILL LIMITS THE USE
OF ANY DATA THAT'S COLLECTED
ONCE AGAIN IMPROVE THE BARS AND
NIGHTCLUBS RETAINING OR SHARING
DATA.
IN TWO THOUSAND THREE
LEGISLATURE ENACTED THE DEFECT
PREVENTION ASSISTANCE ACT WHICH
AMONG OTHER THINGS AUTHORIZES
BUSINESSES FIBER DRIVER'S
LICENSE OR ID CARD. ANY
ELECTRONIC DEVICE FIRST
SPECIFIED PURPOSES AND PROHIBIT
THE BUSINESS OF RETAINING OR
USING. A THE INFORMATION
OBTAINED FOR ANY PURPOSE OTHER
THOSE AUTHORIZES. A BETWEEN SIX
SEVEN SIXTY NINE UPDATES YAK
REFLECT THE USE OF NEW
TECHNOLOGIES WHICH SCALE ID'S.
YOU'LL HAVE IN YOUR POSSESSION
ONE OF THESE THINGS A. TEMPLATE
AND BASICALLY. ALONG THE BALLERS
ON CASE THREE MARCH KISSED YOU
MULTI GOOD A BAR THE SKINNER
DRIVER'S LICENSE TO TAKE A
PHOTOGRAPH OF YOU.
AND THAT IS RETAIN FOR AT LEAST
NINETY DAYS FROM BY SOME
BUSINESSES.
SILICON'S BAND PATRONS OF YOUR
PROBLEM BUT WHAT'S INTERESTING
IS THE FACT. THAT.
AT A BAR TYPICALLY OTHER BARS
YOU GO TO LIKE A AT BJ'S OR
SOMEWHERE ELSE.
FORCES VERIFY YOUR LICENSE
PLATE WITH MAJOR DRIVERS LICENSE
IS DO LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
SO.
THERE DO RETAIN A LOT OF
INFORMATION SO IT'S VERY
TROUBLING. AND WHAT IS THAT IF
WAS DON'T THAT INFORMATION SUCH
REASON FOR THE BILL SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR FIRST
WITNESS PLEASE.
SHE NOT HAVE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION WE'RE
ACTUALLY NOT SUPPORT I DON'T
MUCH EVERYONE IS IS POOR BUT I
DID WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
WERE NEUTRAL ON THE BILL I WANT
TO THANK HIM FOR WORKING WITH US
AND STAFF I THINK YOUR STAFF
FOR.
THEIR ANALYSIS AND HELPING TO
NARROW THE DOUBT BILL DOWN ON TO
THE ISSUE THAT.
THE SOMEWHAT MEMBER RAY SO WE
APPRECIATE THE GOOD WORK OF ALL
THE PARTIES THANK YOU THANK YOU
MATCH NEXT PLEASE.
HI SARAH BOOT ON BEHALF OF THE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE ONE ECHO
THOSE SENTIMENTS WE HAD ISSUED A
LETTER OF CONCERN BUT THE
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS
AND THANK. MISTER COOPER IN A
STAFF ALL THE WORK THEY PUT INTO
THAT AND.
OUR CONCERN HAS BEEN REMOVED
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS PLACE.
CLIFF COSTS WHEN THEY HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA NEW CAR DEALERS
ASSOCIATION ELECT A PILE ON AND
SAY THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING WITH US. AND WE RAISE
SOME CONCERNS AS A STAFF
DILIGENTLY ADDRESS THEM AND WE
APPRECIATE THE FACT COMMITTEES.
WORK AND AND RECOMMENDATIONS TO
HELP RESOLVE THE ISSUE AND WE
ARTIFICIALLY NEUTRAL THE BILL
CLICKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPPOSITION PLEASE HOW COME ON
UP.
SEEING NONE LET'S UP BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEN AND THE BILL HAS BEEN.
MOVED AND SECONDED THAT WHICH
LIKE THE CLOSENESS WITH. RESPECT
WE ASK YOUR AYE VOTE TAKE VERY
MUCH OF A COMPANY'S.
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY NINE.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
SHALL I ALL I HIGHLY AYE AYE.
BAKER.
BERMAN UP BY CALDERON.
I IRWIN. I AM MULLIN. AYE
OBERNOLTE. AYE REYES.
TING.
THE BILL IS OUT CONGRATULATIONS
THAT YOU THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. ON.
THAT'S THE LAST SPILL.
SO IF I COULD ASK MADAM
SECRETARY TO.
LIVE THE COST AND ALSO JUST GO
DOWN THE LIST OF FROM THE
BEGINNING OF THAT'S OKAY AND
PLEASE.
BECAUSE. ALL OF US YES. THERE
BUT BECAUSE
YEAH.
JUST ABSENT MEMBERS.
SELECT OUT OUT OUT HOW START
GUESTS AND THEN. YES.
NOW OKAY IS COMING.
OKAY SO.
WE'LL GET READY AND.
LIBERTY AND.
OKAY. ALRIGHT.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY ONE TO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
BERMAN. I HAVE I CALDERON. AYE
MULLIN. AYE REYES.
TING.
IT'S EIGHT. EIGHT ZERO THAT
THOSE OUT.
ITEM TO PLEASE.
AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE DEAR
PARENTS TO PREPARATIONS HEALY
DEPARTED JEWISH HISTORY.
BERMAN ODD I.
THAT'S IT NINETY ONE NINETY ONE
THAT BILLS OUT THERE.
NEXT ITEM IS AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
SEVEN THAT'S CHAO BILL.
ON DIGITAL KO
.
SORRY TICKET TO GET THAT.
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN DO
PASS IS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
REYES.
THAT'S IT.
HOW CAN OAK YEAH RATES IS THE
ONLY?
HIS ACCOUNT AGAIN WHAT'S THEIR
BACK ON. THE COUCH
OKAY.
SEVENTY TWO SEVENTY TWO.
NEXT ITEM IS SET ON. NUMBER FIVE
FELL AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY TWO.
LEVINE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY TWO TO PASS.
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
BAKER.
GRAY DAVIS AND TING.
FIVE TWO ONES SO THAT BILL IS
THE LONG CALL.
NEXT ITEM IS US ITEM SIX AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FOUR TO.
ON BUSINESS LICENSES.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THAT THE DO PATH OF THE TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
BAKER.
CALDERON. AYE MULLIN.
I KEY.
SO CAN.
SIX THREE ONE SIX TWO AND A BILL
IS OUT THERE.
NEXT ITEM SEVEN EP TWENTY ONE
NINETY FOUR HAS BEEN PULLED. AND
NEXT ITEM IS.
NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY TO
TWENTY FIVE LIMON THAT'S ON
STATE GOVERNMENTS DURING.
RECORDING ELECTRONIC MEDIA
THAT'S KLAUS SERVICES.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BERMAN.
I.
CALDERON. I.
MULLIN. I.
REYES. T..
PERHAPS THE OF IT TO THE EIGHT
TWO ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT THERE
NECKS BILL IS SO ITEM NUMBER
NINE AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
FIVE OBERNOLTE. ON VOTER
REGISTRATION DATABASE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CALDERON.
ARE IRWIN.
NO.
I. REYES.
TING.
THE VOTE.
SIX SIX TWO ONE SIX ZERO ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT THERE ARE NEXT
BILL IS.
ITEM TEN AB TWENTY FOUR OH TO.
BLOW ON CANNABIS PERSONAL
INFORMATION PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
BERMAN AYE CALDERON. AYE.
MULLIN.
I REYES.
T..
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT NEXT IS THE
ITEM ELEVEN AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
SIX IRWIN ON CHARITABLE
ORGANIZATIONS.
CROWDFUNDING.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MULLIN.
I.
T..
THAT'S NEITHER NINETY ZERO THAT
DOLLARS OUT THE NEXT. ITEM
TWELVE AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY A
CHILD THAT'S ON ELECTION
INFRASTRUCTURE.
.
OBERNOLTE.
BECAUSE THERE A TWO ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT.
NEXT ITEM IS FOURTEEN B TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY NINE COOPER ON OUR
PRIVACY DRIVERS LICENSE
INFORMATION PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
NOW TAKE IT.
VOTING.
COOPER WHEN WE JUST HAVE.
SO HERE.
THAT'S ARE THAT THAT'S IT'S
EIGHT THAT'S A AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY NINE COOPER PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS SPEAKER.
RACE.
I.
EIGHT.
A TWO ZERO THAT BELL IS OUT NEXT
WE HAVE ITEM SIXTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT THERE ARE THIRTEEN IRWIN
ON. CALIFORNIA'S CYBERSECURITY
INTEGRATION CENTER PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
IRWIN.
AND.
DIVINITY.
WHAT'S IT LOOK AT EACH OTHER
EIGHT ZERO THAT DOLLARS OUT NEXT
WEEK HOW ITEM SEVENTEEN AB
TWENTY NINE NINETY EIGHT BLOOM.
ON DOING ALL PRODUCTS FLAME
RETARDANT MATERIALS PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS BAKER.
CALDERON. ARE. MULLIN.
I REYES. AYE TEAM.
SIXTY TO SIXTY TWO THAT BILL IS
OUT NEXT TO YOU HOW. EIGHTEEN
ITEM EIGHTEEN AB THIRTY TEN
LIMON ON CALIFORNIA THE FIRST
DEPOSIT TRANSACTION LAW. THAT'S
A PAYDAY LOANS UP PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
REYES AYE AYE. TEAM.
SIXTY TWO SIXTY TWO THAT BILL IS
OUT THERE NEXT ITEM NINETEEN A.
B. THIRTY ONE NINETY THREE. CHAO
ON INFORMATION SECURITY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
REYES.
I.
I'M SORRY BAKER AND PAINLESS
AREAS LIKE A.
RIGHT IF I. THAT'S NINE TWO ZERO
NINE ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT THERE
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM TWENTY AB
TWELVE. THIRTY TWO OH SEVEN. THE
MALL ON CALIFORNIA FINANCING LAW
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BAKER.
CALDERON.
I.
MULAN.
I. T..
SO CAN.
SIXTY TO THAT BILL IS OUT SO
PLEASE CALL THE OFTEN MEMBER ON
THE CONSENT AGENDA PLEASE.
THIS IS CONSENT.
DOT WOULD INCLUDE A. B.
NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN BERMAN.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY NINE
BONTA AB TWENTY EIGHT TWELVE OF
THE MALL AND. THIRTY A. B.
THIRTY TWO TWENTY NINE BIRTH
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBER ON
THE CONSENT AGENDA.
BAKER.
CALDERON. I.
MULLIN.
I T..
THAT'S EIGHT TWO ZERO CONSENT
YES OKAY EIGHT ZERO
CONSENT THAT TO ALL THOSE BILLS
ARE OUT. ON SO THAT WE CONCLUDE
THE.
BECAUSE YES GO AHEAD AND NOW
FOR FOR ADD ONS RIGHT.
ABSOLUTELY YES.
IF YOU GO BACK SO OKAY POINT WE
COULD EITHER COLUMN OUT WHEN SHE
COMES BACK WHERE WE CAN.
YOU CAN ANAHIT WHICH LIKE ANNA.
TO CHECK TWENTY.
ONE.
THE GATES Y. GO DOWN THE LIST
AGAIN.
OKAY WHILE WE DO THAT.
AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTEEN WE'VE
GOT MULLIN.
YES I.
AND TING.
THAT IS NINE TO.
OKAY SHOULD WE DO THE REST OF.
THE BILLS FOR HOMES VARIOUS TO
ADD ON.
A GREAT. LIFT GIVE ME A MOMENT
OKAY HOW IT SEES MODOC
OFFENSIVE.
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT.
RIGHT.
OKAY WHILE I CALL MOUNTAIN YOU
CAN JUST TELL.
GO.
OKAY STARTING WITH ITEM ONE AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY ONE STEINORTH A
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
RENTS.
ITEM TWO A. B. EIGHTEEN FIFTY
NINE CHAO. CUSTOMER RECORDS.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MMHM OKAY.
I DON'T THINK.
THE CARE. AND.
THAT WASN'T HOW CAN.
SO WHEN I DO THAT'S OKAY YOU
NONE AB TWO TWO FIVE RAY.
I'VE TWO TWO TWO FIVE SIGN.
I.
THAT'S NINE TWO ZERO THING I.
TING AYE THAT'S TEN.
TWO ZERO.
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY TWO. REYES.
THING. I'M RARE SIDE.
TING.
NOT VOTING.
I FIXED
TWO ONE.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY FIVE
RANTS.
NOT VOTING.
TING.
NO.
NOW.
SIX ZERO SIX TWO ONE.
AB TWENTY FOUR OH TO.
BREATH.
I.
TING ARE.
THAT'S NINETEENTH.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY EIGHT
REYES.
I.
AND BAKER.
IT'S NINE ZERO.
WE ALSO PUT IT ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
TING AYE ON THE CONSENT
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN.
REYES.
I.
THAT'S EIGHT TO TWO.
BELIEVE THAT.
IS IT FREE.
SORRY.
I.
AND REYES.
WE HAVE MR TWENTY WHAT WAS IT
CALLED.
LEE TURNED TO GET THE SENTENCE.
FULLY TO.
YEAH
.
SHARE THE.
I WAS OFFER YES THAT IS OFFER
YOU I'M SO SORRY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IT.
VOIGTS.
SO THEIR WE HAVE EVERYTHING FROM
OF TENURE AND THIS IS WHAT I'M
DOING RIGHT NOW OKAY.
HE CONFIDENTLY.
SO AB SEVENTEEN ANYONE TANG HAI
I. THAT'S TEN.
TWO ZERO.
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTH OF THAT WHEN
THIS SOUNDS.
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FOUR TING.
AYE.
AND BAKER.
SEVEN TO.
ON TWENTY ONE.
AB TWENTY FIVE. FIFTY SIX
TING AYE.
TEND TO ZERO.
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY NINE
BAKER.
TING AYE AYE.
NINE.
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTEEN TING AYE AYE TEN
DESERVE.
AB TWENTY NINE NINE EIGHT.
TING AYE ARE AND BAKER.
TING AYE.
SEVEN.
AB THIRTY TEN.
BAKER.
TING AYE AYE.
SEVEN TO TWO.
A. B. THIRTY TWO OH SEVEN.
BAKER.
TING AYE AYE.
THEY GET THEM REVENUE TO.
THAT'S IT.
I FEEL.
AS BIG MONEY.
OKAY LOLA.
OKAY GOTCHA.
WELL LET ME